ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERONE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HIM SENATE BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES CHAU
JUNE CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ BRADY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL- SEND PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK BURKE SO. RAMOS RADIO
LOOSE REBA ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEAM
VELADERO VIA POOL BY VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOULD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YASIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
GOOD GOVERNMENT DEMANDS THAT WE
BALANCE PASSION WITH PATIENCE.
LEADING NEITHER FALL TO THE
WAYSIDE. MAY GOD GRANT US INNER
STRENGTH AND ENDURING OPTIMISM.
SO THAT WE MAY CONTINUE TO FIND
JOY IN OUR WORK. MAY THIS BE
GOD'S WILL I MEAN. THANK YOU
MA'AM YES SIR YES OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG FLAG
SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. AS HE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE MISTER GARCIA
PLEASE PUT YOUR HAND OVER YOUR
HEART. THEY BEGIN. BASICALLY.
ZERO SAN. FOR THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. REALLY HAVE A PREVIOUS
DAY'S ASSEMBLY JIM SOCCER
WEDNESDAY TWENTY TWENTY TWO ONE
THE MEDI SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
CHIU MEMBER SEVENTY DISTRICT
WAS CHEAP CHEAPER WITH THE
REYES S. MOVE AND MISTER FLOOR.
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS JOURNAL BE TO WITH
PRESENT SEVENTY THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
OF DEFERRED REPORTS OF WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR. THE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
EXCUSED ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THE ABOVE THE LAW AND WHEN TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINE B. TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP FLOOR
AMENDMENTS. ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
AB TEN FORTY THREE THREE OF US
ITEM FORTY AB SIXTY EIGHT SALAS.
MR FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR WE
WITHHOLDING INSTANCE IN ASTRAL
VOTE. MR FLOOR A WITHHOLDING.
MS RAMOS MOVES ME GIVE SECONDS.
ON THE RULES OF MEMBERS THIS IS
A PER VOTE. CLARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OF PROCEDURAL VOTE MAYES
REYES IS ASKING AN AYE VOTE
FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A VOTE.
THIS IS A PROCEDURE OF MEMBER.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION. MS
RACES ASKING FOR NINE AND A
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO. THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL EYES
FORTY SIX NO SIXTEEN THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED MS REYES YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZE. PERCENT
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER SB SEVEN HUNDRED BUT ALSO
FROM THE INSURANCE COMPANY TO
THE LABOR AD EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. I SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THERE ARE. SIX THERE'S A FLOOR
AMENDMENT AT THE DESK THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH CAUCUSES
TO TAKE UP AS A BATCH OF VOTE I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ADOPT THE FLOOR AMENDMENTS WITH
ONE VOICE VOTE AFTER THE CLERK
HAS READ THE BILL'S. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FORTY THREE LOSE. WITH
AMENDMENTS BILL SIXTY EIGHT
SOLACE WITH AMENDMENTS SOME
BILL TROUBLES. THREE OF US WITH
A MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
LOSE WE WITH A MINUTES ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FIFTY P. APPROVED
WELL WITH A MEMBERS. AND
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX RESEARCH SHE
WITH. WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALTHOUGH AND
SAY. SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT
WAS A MEMBERS ARE TOP.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. AND THE FILE IS
STICK. THIS IS ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THIS IS
MISTER KALRA. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB. FIFTEEN OH SIX.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
OH SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AN ACCOLADE IN THE PREVAILING
WAGE MISTER KALRA EMAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ANY DETAILS EXPECTS A
SIMPLE TECHNICAL CHANGE THE
DEFINITION LOCALITY FOR PURPOSE
OF CAPTURING. WHERE PUBLIC
WORKS BEFORE NOT A PREVAILING
WAGE LAW THE BILL HAS NO
REGISTER OPPOSITION OR
SOMETHING ELSE WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA C.
NOTICE. OF CLUB CLUB ROLE. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE- CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER EYES FORTY
KNOWS THAT MEASURE PASSED FILE
FOR. THROUGH A LEVY PASS RETAIN
THIS IS FOR ITEM. AB SEVEN
HUNDRED. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
BY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM ACKLEY IN
THE CRIME PROCEDURE MR CUTTING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
CURRENTLY TO IN CASES ARE CHEN
REQUIRE TO BE PERSONALLY
PRESENT DURING TRIAL OR
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION HOWEVER
UNDER CURRENT LAW A DEFENDANT
MAY BE ABSENT AFTER THE TRIAL
OR PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION HAS
COMMENCED IN THEIR PRESENCE
THIS LIMITATION HAS BECOME A
MAJOR ISSUE DURING THE COVERED
PANDEMIC AB SEVEN HUNDRED WOULD
ALLOW A PRELIM OR TRIAL TO
PROCEED. IN A DEFENDANT'S
ABSENCE UNDER CERTAIN ERROR
CONDITIONS INCLUDING THAT THE
DEFENDANT IS REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL AND THAT THE DEFENDANT
HAS VOLUNTARILY CONSENTED TO
COMMENCING THE PROCEEDING AFTER
BEING INFORMED OF THEIR RIGHTS
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE'VE WORKED
WITH CDA CD PA AND THE ACLU TO
ENSURE THE BILL STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE OF JUDICIAL
KANEMI IN CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK MISS
CUNNINGHAM. SENIOR DEBATE.
CLICK MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON VOTER OUT OF A MALMO OF.
RESIDE OF. WELL CLOSER
TELEVISED A NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB FORTY BY
MISTER CHOW CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FOR SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO WITHOUT
LEADING TO A IN THE CLEARING
THE URGENCY TO FACT MERELY.
MISTER CHOW MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JUST AND MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SO WERE PERMIT
THE CITY OF AL HOW. NDL HOW
UNIFY SCHOOL TO CONDUCT A LOT
IN ORDER TO PROCEED WITH ITS
TRANSIT. FROM AT LARGE TO BUY A
ELECT. FOR MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
OF A- IN ORDER TO COME WITH CAL
VOTING ACT OF THOUSAND AND ONE.
DURING NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION MEASURE
G. WHICH APPEAR ON THE BALLOT
SOUGHT TO REMOVE THE CITY
CHARTER ALL REFERENCES TO THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HOWEVER VISAGIE ONLY
APPEAR ON THE BALLOTS OF VOTERS
RESIDING IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA AND NOT ON THE BALLOT
SO VOTERS YOU KNOW HAMMER
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO
RESIDE OUTSIDE OF THE CITY
BOUNDARIES. UNDER EXISTING LAW
CHARTER AMENDMENT FOR CITY MUST
BE SUBMITTED TO VOTERS AND AN
ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION CONSEQUENTLY THE CITY
OF ALL HAMBRE AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE PROHIBITED FROM
CONDUCTING A SPECIAL ELECTION
TO AMEND THE CHARTER PRIOR TO
THE NEXT STATEWIDE ELECTION ON
NOVEMBER TWELFTH NOVEMBER EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THEREFORE WE
NEED TO CREATE A SPECIAL
EXCEPTION AND GOVERNMENT CO TO
PERMIT THE CITY OF ALHAMBRA AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT
A SPECIAL ELECTION BEFORE. S.
IS ADDED ON TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DISTRICT BILL WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IBM.
THANK YOU MISTER SHALL THE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE
URGENCY. ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I TIRTY SIX NO SIX ON THE
URGENCY I FIFTY SIX NO SIX ON
THE MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES
PASS A RETAINER FILE ITEMS
FOURTEEN. THROUGH. TWENTY ONE.
WE ARE AT FIVE TWENTY TWO. AB
NINE SEVENTY BY MR MCCARTY
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY ANOTHER SINAK LETTING
US OWNING MISTER MCCARTY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL AS
A MEASURE TO ENCOURAGE FRANKLY
ENTICE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PERMIT MORE CHARGING STATIONS
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE KNOW
FOR GOING TO ADDRESS OUR
CLIMATE CANGE AND AIR
POLLUTION CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO ADDRESS
MOBILE SOURCES THAT'S ELECTRIC
VEHICLES BUT ALSO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE IS A BIG
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE. THIS WOULD
FOLLOW UP ON A BILL FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH SHOWS MAJOR NON
COMPLIANCE AND PERMITTING THESE
CHARGING STATIONS ASKING
ARRIVAL THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY C. NOTICES
DEBATE- CARCLUB THEY'RE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE OUT OF. OKAY
FOR. ALL MEMBERS FOR AT ABOUT.
NOON. CLERK WILL WE WERE CLOSER
THE TIME BUT I FEEL TWO KNOWS
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASS. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEN. MR HOLDING
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS AS WE HAVE SEEN DEMAND
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
GROWING AND WITH OUR STATE'S
GOAL OF FIVE MILLION EV'S BY
TWENTY THIRTY WE NEED TO ENSURE
DRIVERS HAVE ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN
THEY ARE ON THE ROAD. BUILD OUT
OF THE V. CHARGERS IS OCCURRING
IN MANY AREAS BUT WE ARE
RELYING HEAVILY ON THE STATE'S
ELECTRIC INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO FILL THE NEED WE
MUST BE SURE THAT PUBLIC
UTILITY PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES ARE FILLING THE GAP
IN THEIR TERRITORIES AS WELL.
THEY SERVE A THIRD OF OUR
STATE'S ELECTRIC CUSTOMERS THIS
BILL WILL DO JUST THAT BY
REQUIRING ALL PO USED TO MAKE
PUBLIC CHARGING AVAILABLE THEY
HAVE FULL LATITUDE ON HOW TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN INCLUDING
CHARGING FOR THE SERVICES AND
WORKING WITH PRIVATE INDUSTRY
TO FILL THE NEED. THIS BILL AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD I
COMMIT TO WORK ON EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR HOLDER.
SENIOR DISCUSS DEBATE ON ITEM
FOR CLUB. THE CEREMONY MEMBERS
OF OUT OF. HOME VOTE. DESIRABLE.
BURKE CLOSER ALL TO ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT NO NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FOLLOWED FIVE
SIX NINETY SO CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SICK NINETY SO BY
ASSEMBLY SHALL OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE FORCE. MISTER
CHOW MAY OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER IN MY AB SIX NINETY
SO WHICH CREATE A- FOR THE
STATE TO APPLY MANAGE AND
FOREST REST PROJECTS ON U. S.
FOREST SERVICE LANDS THROUGH AN
EXPANDED AND FORMALIZE GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY. WILDFIRES
ARE CONTINUING AND GROWING
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA THE
FREQUENCY SIZE AND INTENSITY OF
WILDFIRES IS INCREASING EVERY
YEAR MANY MAJOR WILDFIRES START
ON THE 57% OF CALIFORNIA'S
FOREST LANDS OWNED AND MANAGED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
THEN SPREAD TO AND DAMAGE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE DNA AS THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITY OF ALLOWING SEATS TO
CONTRIBUTE FUNDING AND STAFFING
TO ADVANCE FOREST AND WATERSHED
RESTORATION ON FOREST SERVICE
LANDS AB SIX NINETY SEVEN
FORMALIZES AND EXPANDS THE DNA
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL
ACCELERATE THE PACE AND SCALE.
OF ECOLOGICALLY BASED FORCE
MANAGEMENT AND REDUCE STATE
WILDFIRE RISK THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ALBERT. HEY MICHELLE MISTER
GALA YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER- GRIEVE. VERY MUCH
OF THE OF THE BILL OF
SUPPORTING A GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY PROJECTS- US STILL DO
HAVE A CONCERN IN THE IN THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE LIMITING-
WHAT PROJECTS THAT WE WOULD BE.
FAST TRACKING SUPPORTING- TO
ONLY THOSE SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL WOULD LIKE TO SEE AS THIS
MOVES TO THE PROCESSES I'M SURE
WILL- THAT WE ENSURE THAT IT
COVERS ALL PROJECTS THAT WE
NEED TO DO IT WITHIN OUR WILD
LANDS WITHIN OUR FOR US- TO
ENSURE THAT THIS GOOD WORK THAT
WE KNOW NEEDS TO GET DONE ON
FEDERAL LAND- IS ACCOMPLISHED
SO. I WOULD JUST WANTED TO
STATE THAT CONCERN THAT WE AS A
MOVE FOR WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAKE THIS AS BROAD AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. ENGLISH GALLAGHER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM MR CAL
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT SUGGESTION GOING
FORWARD I'LL BE HAPPY TO LOOK
AT THE A POSSIBILITIES ARE TO
INCLUDE ANYBODY THAT- WOULD
PLAY A ROLE IN THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I SWEAR ABOUT. LOCAL
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. TO
THE SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP IS
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FIVE AND TWENTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE AB SEVEN OH
SIX BY MR COOLEY. CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AN ACT
RELATING TO THE LEGISLATURE.
LAWLER YOU MAY OPEN COLLEAGUES
EMPLOYEES TO BRING YOU AB
SEVENTY SIX IS A OF RIGHTS TO
LET'S SAY. IN THE ON ADMIN OF
THE CAPELA OF PRIDE. INDIA OF
THE FOR THE TO THE LESS WING
HAVE CERTAIN FOR REQUIREMENTS
NEED TO FOR THIS I KNOW A BILL
DEALING WITH THE WEST WING AND
THE SAN HOUSE FALL. AS A
CONTINGENT. THIS BILL UP A
POSSUM AND GO WITH THIS TO THE
WEST WING. AND IT'S REALLY
PROVIDED BY LESSER FOR V. A
VEHICLE THAT A THE READY
REQUEST I WILL. THANKS COOLEY.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
OF COURT LIBERAL. RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS OF ARE THEM. ALL OF
DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE TYLER ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS HERE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASSER FROM ITEM THIRD THIS IS.
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
BY QUIRK ACKLEY THE COMMUTER.
DR QUIRKY MAILBOX THANK YOU
SPEAK MEMBERS. AB FIVE CHAU MY
THIS BROAD PERMITTING PROCESS
TO ENSURE ADELINE WITH A-
FEDERAL. MAKE SURE THE LOCAL
MAKE TO SAY WITHIN THAT
MANDATED TIME. THAT ARE
TYPICALLY TWO TO THREE MONTHS
ON THE TYPE OF PRODUCT. ALSO
FOR- OR THE STE TIME FOR A-
SHOW CLOCK AND AS WELL AS FOR
THE X. DEEMED PRIOR. AT THE CAN
OF THE SHOW CLOCK. OF
ADDITIONAL WE'VE REACHED AGREE
WITH LOW GUY THEY ARE SAID AND-
A LETTER SAYING THE THEY'VE
GONE NEUTRAL AND WITH THE MAN
WERE TO ON. TWENTY- AND DIREST
I YOUR I. FROM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE COURT THIS NOAM SEEKING
RECORD. CARCLUB RURAL. HE SAID
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS ARE OF A- ALL
OF. THIS. WELL CLOSE ROLE TYLER
I SIXTY ONE KNOWS THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS A RETAINED ON FILE
ITEMS THIRTY TWO AND. THIRTY
THREE. THIS IS MISS FRIEDMAN
SAYS FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB
FOURTEEN OH ONE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN OH ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE THIS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. WE HAVE
ALL HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
ON THIS FLOOR THAT
TRANSPORTATION IS THE ONE AREA
IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE GONE IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES IT'S ALSO THE
ONE AREA WHERE WE'VE GOT IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
CONGESTION. WITH AREAS LIKE I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES HAVING SO
MUCH CONGESTION THAT SOMETIMES
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO GET AROUND
AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
WHERE THEY WORK IT BECOMES
EXTREMELY PUNITIVE AN IMPACT ON
THE QUALITY OF LIFE. IT'S ALSO
A REASON PARKING IS ALSO IN
CARS ARE ALSO ONE OF THE
PRIMARY REASONS WHY IT'S
DIFFICULT. TO BUILD HOUSING IN
LOS ANGELES. I KNOW FOR MY
YEARS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT
WHEN YOU GO TO BILL HOUSING
REALLY OF ANY SCALE. THE FIRST
THING PEOPLE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SAY IS. WE DON'T
WANT THIS HOUSING PROJECT
BECAUSE OF THE- CONGESTION
BECAUSE OF THE PARKING IMPACTS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ONE OF OUR
GOALS TO SOLVE ALL OF THIS HAS
BEEN TO TRY TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. AND YET WE
CONTINUE. CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE. PARKING IN CARS
EVEN AT THE EXPENSE OF HUMAN
BEINGS. IN THE UNITED STATES WE
DEDICATE APPROXIMATELY A
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF LAND
FOR EVERY CAR THAT WE HAVE IN
THE COUNTRY. AT THE SAME TIME
WE DEDICATE ONLY EIGHT HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET OF HOUSING FOR
EVERY PERSON WE HAVE IN THE
COUNTRY. THERE ARE SOME REALLY
ASTOUNDING FACTS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PARKING MANDATES HAVE
LED TO AN ASTONISHING TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES JUST OF
PARKING. THAT'S FOUR TIMES AS
MUCH LAND AS THE ENTIRE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. L. A. COUNTY HAS
EIGHTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
PARKING SPACES. AT THE SAME
TIME WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
PARKING SPACES THAT ARE NOT
USED TO MY IN MY OWN DISTRICT
OFFICE IN BURBANK. I HAVE A
PARKING LOT THAT IS USED FOR MY
BUILDING THAT EVEN BEFORE COVE
IT WAS MAYBE MAYBE A TEN FILLED
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. OF THAT
CITY STORE REQUIRES ANY NEW
HOUSING UNIT TO ROUTE TO
PROVIDE AT LEAST TWO PARKING
SPACES. EVEN THOUGH THERE'S
EMPTY PARKING LOTS ALL AROUND
THEIR DOWNTOWN AREA. FORTINO
ONE IS A COMMON SENSE BILL TO
ALLOW THE BUILDERS OF NEW
PROJECTS TO ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO
RIGHT SIZE THE PARKING FOR
THEIR PARTICULAR DEVELOPMENT.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO LOOK AT WHO
THEIR CUSTOMER IS GOING TO BE
OR THEIR TENANT IS GOING TO BE.
AND DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES HOW
MUCH PARKING THE NEED THE BILL
DOES NOT DO THIS STATE WIDE IT
DOESN'T NEAR OUR HIGHEST
QUALITY TRANSIT PLACES WERE WE
ARE ALREADY ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO WALK AND BIKE AND USE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
DOES NOT WORK IN SPRAWLING
COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE HAVE
AN ABUNDANCE OF CARS AND
ABUNDANCE OF PARKING SPACES. IN
ADDITION EVERY PARKING SPACE
THE DEVELOPER BUILD ONTO A
UNIT. ONTO THEIR PROJECT COSTS
ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT UP TO
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
UNIT DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
CONSTRUCTION. THIS IS THE
REASON WHY MANY HOUSING UNITS
SIMPLY DO NOT CANCEL AND WHILE
MANY OF OUR AREAS DEVELOPERS
WALK AWAY. FROM BUILDING
HOUSING. FORTINO ONE IS
SPONSORED BY CALIFORNIA YIMBY
SPUR ABUNDANT HOUSING LA IN THE
COUNCIL FOR INFILL BUILDERS. IT
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP. BAY AREA COUNSEL CAL
ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND TRANSFORM. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
FRIEDMAN. MR BLOOM. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- I'M VOTING FOR
THIS BILL TODAY- BUT I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WHEN THE BILL
WAS FIRST HEARD AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE I WAS
UNCLEAR THAT ALTHOUGH I SUPPORT
THE GOAL OF REMOVING EXCESSIVE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS I FELT THE
BILL STILL NEEDED MORE WORK
AND- UNFORTUNATELY I BELIEVE IT
STILL DOES- I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT. EQUITY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUPS HAVE EXPRESSED
VERY WHAT I THINK ARE VERY
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
WAY IN WHICH AB FOURTEEN NO
ONE. HAS APPROACHED THE REMOVAL
OF PARKING REQUIREMENTS BUT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR I FULLY
SUPPORT REMOVING PARKING
MINIMUMS. BUT I ALSO SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT MAXIMIZE DENSITY
AROUND TRANSIT AND THAT
MAXIMIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION THESE ARE BOTH VERY
VERY WORTHY GOALS THAT WE
SHOULD ALL. SUPPORT AND THE
KIND OF POLICIES THAT WE NEED
TO INCREASE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
REDUCE AUTO DEPENDENCE AND
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS BUT
DE LINKING PARKING REDUCTIONS.
FROM THE DENSITY BONUS
FRAMEWORK WHICH THIS BILL DOES
MEANS THAT WE FAIL TO CAPTURE.
THE VALUE OF ANY BENEFIT THAT'S
CONVEYED WE MISS OUT ON THE
PRODUCTION OF NEW AFFORDABLE
UNITS AND FOREGO THE
POSSIBILITY TO GET MORE DENSITY
NEAR TRANSIT. AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
IT'S ALSO. TO THE DETRIMENT OF
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM SUCH
AS L. A. X. TRANSIT ORIENTED
COMMUNITY PROGRAM. WHICH IS
DELIVERED THOUSANDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS NEAR
TRANSIT IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AS A TRADE OFF FOR LESS
PARKING. SUPPORTING EQUITY AND
INCLUSION WHILE REDUCING
PARKING MINIMUMS WOULD BE A WIN
FOR HOUSING AND THE ENVIRONMENT
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK WE
SHOULD SEEK WITH THIS BILL. AND
LEAVING THOSE BENEFITS BEHIND.
UNDERMINE SOME OF THE VERY
GOALS OF THE BILL. SO I AM BUT
I VOTING FOR THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I WANT TO ALLOW TIME
FOR CRITICAL CONVERSATIONS TO
TAKE PLACE THE AUTHOR VERY
GRACIOUSLY HAS SAID THAT- SHE
WILL ENTERTAIN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL SUPPORT REDUCE PARKING AS
I DO. AND I BELIEVE THAT WITH
SOME AMENDMENTS BOTH GOALS CAN
BE ACHIEVED AND I HOPE TO SEE
AN IMPROVED BILL OF- RETURNED
AFTER IT'S BEEN AMENDED. I
THINK IT IS FOR THE MISTER
MURATSUCHI. YOU RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE FOR NOT
TO. TRYING TO. ASK THESE
QUESTIONS MORE DIRECTLY AND SO
I JUST WANT TO RAISE MY
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
PERHAPS WE CAN- CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION AS A SUSPECT
SUSPECT THIS BILL MAY BE MOVING
ON. ALL WHEN I WAS ON THE
TORRANCE PLANNING COMMISSION I
KNOW THAT WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME. YOU KNOW TRYING TO STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN YOU
KNOW HOW MANY PARKING UNITS
WERE PROVIDED IN A IN A
DEVELOPMENT- WITH THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT. YOU KNOW
TRYING TO AVOID SITUATIONS
WHERE WE HAVE SAID TO MANY CARS
PARKED ON THE STREETS PART I.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD. AND. AND
SO IT IT'S A- MAKES ME VERY
CONCERNED THAT WERE BASICALLY
PROHIBITING WHERE WE'RE TAKING
AWAY LOCAL CONTROL FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FROM PLANNING
RESPONSIBLY PLANNING FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS THEIR COMMUNITIES
ARE. YOU KNOW AS SOMEONE WHO.
YOU KNOW IS COMMITTED TO
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE AND I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE PUBLIC
TRANSIT JUST AS MUCH AS ANYONE.
BUT YOU KNOW TO. IMPOSE A
STATEWIDE PROHIBITION ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO
RESPONSIBLE PLAN FOR THEIR
PARKING NEEDS FOR DEVELOPMENT
I'M CONCERNED THAT GOES TOO FAR.
MR WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND
ALL THE SPONSORS FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FOR ALL WITH AB
FORTINO ONE WE'RE WOULD
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO REFLECT
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE ALREADY
DONE IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WHEN I WAS ON COUNCIL IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. WE
ACTUALLY PASSED DESPITE MANY OF
THE SAME CONVERSATIONS AND
OBJECTIONS A VERY STRONG
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR PARKING MINIMUMS
WHAT THAT WAS FOUNDED ON WITH A
COUPLE OF PRINCIPLES ONE
PARKING IS EXPENSIVE AND IT
ADDS ACOSTA DIRECTLY IS BEING
PASSED ON TO CONSUMERS AND THE
RENTERS. TO PARKING IS
SURPRISINGLY OVER ABUNDANT WHAT
WE SAW IN THE DOWNTOWN SAN
DIEGO PLANNING AREA WAS THAT
UPON A RESIDENTIAL PARKING
SURVEY 30% OF THE UNDERGROUND
PARKING TIED TO THE UNITS ABOVE
GROUND WITH UNUSED UNUSED AND
WHAT TWENTY THOUSAND PROBABLY
CLOSER TO SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THOSE KINDS OF
PARKING CONSTRUCTION COSTS.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT EXPENSE
PASSED ON TO THE- RESPECTIVE
OWNER PASSED ON TO THE RENTER
SO WHAT WE CAN DO IS MAKE SURE
THROUGH THIS BILL THE
RETREATING PARKING WHAT IT WHAT
IS WHICH IS A COMMODITY WHICH
IS AMENITY WHICH IS A TWICE AND
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE ARTIFICIAL
MINIMUMS PLACED INTO ANY CODES
RIGHT NOW. THAT ARE PUSHING
SOME OF THE CHOICES BECAUSE
SOME OF THOSE DON'T NEED TO BE
USE THOSE COSTS DON'T NEED TO
BE PASSED ON TO THE RENTERS IF
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALLOWING THE FLEXIBILITY WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND IS THAT
THE DEVELOPERS ARE GOING TO
ACTUALLY DECIDE MAYBE I DO WANT
ONE UNIT PER BEDROOM MAYBE I
WANT TO ACTUALLY REDUCE IT TO
YOU KNOW ZERO FOUR POINT FIVE.
BECAUSE THE CHOICE IS GOING TO
COME DOWN TO THE RENTER OR THE
CONSUMER AND THEY'RE GOING TO
CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT
THAT UNIT BECAUSE IT MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE PARKING AND THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT WANT TO ASSUME SOME
OF THAT EXPENSE AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THAT AND THE CUMULATIVE
EFFECT OVER ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING SUPPLY.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO MITIGATE
AND POSSIBLY EVEN REDUCE SOME
OF THE HOUSING COSTS. IT'S SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE PRESSURED
WITH AND ALL CLOSE BUDGET
SAYING THAT WE SAW. AFTER THAT
LOCALLY INTO THE- EIGHTEEN. IS
NEW CAN. GOING ON TO THE- FOR
OUR MERGING- I WORK. COME OUT.
NEW CAN. IN DOWNTOWN DIEGO. FOR
SIXTEEN HUNDRED. A MONTH RENT.
AND THAT WITH UNACHIEVABLE FOR
SO MANY OTHER LIKE HOUSING
TYPES IN THE SAME PLANNING AREA
BEFORE THAT SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU
MISTER WARD MISTER KALRA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IS
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING. THAT IS A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION THAT'S
LONG OVERDUE- AND I ALSO
SERVED. ON THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
PLANNING COMMISSION AND THE
CITY COUNCIL. AND THE REALITY
IS THAT WE HAVE. TO GET. LAST
AND PUT IN THE PAST OUR-
ADDITION TO PARKING. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT WHEN AND SALAS IS
ACTUALLY COULD EXAMPLE OF NOT
ONLY HELP THINGS WENT HORRIBLY
WRONG BUT HOW THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIX IT. OVER THE LAST DECADE OR
TWO- OF YOU KNOW OVER THE
COURSE OF THREE TO FOUR DECADES
CALIFORNIA WENT FROM
ESSENTIALLY A FARMING COMMUNITY
TO THE THIRD LARGEST CITY IN
THE STATE AND NOW THE TENTH
LARGEST IN THE NATION. AND A
LOT OF MISTAKES WERE MADE ALONG
THE WAY AND MORE RECENTLY-
WE'RE TRYING TO REVERSE
ENGINEER THOSE MISTAKES.
BUILDING HIGHER DENSITY ALONG
TRANSIT IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT. NOT JUST FOR
INCREASING ACCESS AND USAGE OF
TRANSIT. NOT ONLY FOR CREATING
HIGHER DENSITY HOUSING WHICH WE
ALL KNOW WE NEED EVERY CORNER
OF THE STATE. OF IT ALSO
ENVIRONMENTALLY IN SAN JOSE
BEEN ABLE TO PROTECT SAUDI
VALLEY BY BUILDING MORE DENSELY
ALONG TRANSIT CORRIDORS. IN OUR
URBAN CORE AND EVEN THROUGH
WHAT WAS FORMERLY ALL SINGLE
FAMILY. NAKED SPRAWLED OUT
NEIGHBORHOODS WERE ACTUALLY
BUILDING. MORE DENSELY ALONG
THE TRANSIT QUARTERS BECAUSE-
IT'S QUITE SIMPLY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AND THE OTHER DAY
I WAS DRIVING ALONG- FIVE
EIGHTY. PASSING ALL OVER A LOT
OF THESE DIFFERENT TOWNS THAT
HAD. AND PUSH FOR LOBBIED FOR
THESE WONDERFUL BART STATIONS.
AROUND THE BAR STATIONS. THERE
ARE NO HOUSING. A THIS COMPUTER
A LAW TRANS LINES THROUGH
CALIFORNIA BUS ONE. THROW CAL.
SO I ALWAYS HAVING FROM SO
COUNCIL LOCAL CONTROL. BUT I'LL
TELL YOU TRANSIT ORDERS ARE NOT
A LOCAL ASSET THE REGIONAL- AND
ONLY BUILD TRANSIT AND WE BUILT
TO. DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
THERE'S A RESPONSIBILITY ON
EVERY COMMUNITY BUT ALONG THOSE
TRANSIT LINES TO DO THEIR PART.
TO RELIEVE THE PRESSURE ON
HOUSING IN OUR STATE AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THAT REASON
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANKS KALRA MISSED
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I VERY MUCH RESPECT
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND I
FEEL LIKE NINETY. OVER 95% OF
THE TIME WE'RE VERY MUCH IN
SYNC AND ALIGNED. AND THE VERY
ARGUMENTS THAT WERE STATED
RIGHT NOW BY COLLEAGUES FROM
SAN JOSE OR SAN DIEGO OR OF LOS
ANGELES AS WELL. I AGREE WITH.
BUT IT'S VERY INTERESTING THAT
THAT WE COME TO A DIFFERENT
CONCLUSION. I DO NOT I I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS BILL TO
SEE HOW THIS WOULD INCENTIVIZE.
MORE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY HOUSING. FOR
CONSTITUENTS WHEN YOU ALLOW A
DEVELOPER TO DO WHATEVER IT IS
THAT THEY'REGONNA DO THEY WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT BECAUSE
THAT IS HOW. THEY WILL PROCEED
WITH THEIR WORK. AT IT WE HAVE
PLACED REGULATIONS FOR REASONS
AND SO IF WE WANT TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THE WAY OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING WE NEED TO
LOOK AT INCENTIVES I WOULD HAVE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL. OR I WOULD
HAVE BEEN GREATLY COMFORTABLE
WITH IT IF THERE WAS A FORMULA
INCENTIVE ATTACHED TO CITIES TO
ACCEPT THIS TO THEN GET CERTAIN
TYPE FUNDING FOR MORE TRANSIT
FOR MORE DEVELOPMENT OF TRANSIT
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION IS
COMPLETELY. INTERTWINED IN
ORDER TO GET BETTER HOUSING
ADOPTED WE NEED TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE TRANSIT AND RAIL
INVESTMENTS IN OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND TO BE QUITE
FRANK I WANT ONE ONE OF THE
COMMENTS I DIDN'T COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH. CHANGES IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR SAN DIEGO CANNOT
BE APPLIED TO PLACES LIKE LOS
ANGELES. IT IS THE THESE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT AREAS WITH
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES AND
DIFFERENT ISSUES- SO I
RESPECTFULLY WILL BE LAYING OFF
OF THIS BILL TODAY I HOPE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OUR COLLEAGUES TO BE
ABLE TO COME TO A PLACE WHERE I
CAN SUPPORT. BUT I JUST SEE TOO
MANY CONCERNS WITH THIS AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I HAVEN'T
SEEN THIS IN ANY OF THE
ANALYSIS BUT THE REALITY FOLKS
IS MOST AMERICANS RELY ON THEIR-
ON THEIR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
TO BE THEIR MAIN INVESTMENT
OVER 70% OF AMERICANS TREAT
THEIR HOMES AS THEIR PRIMARY
SOURCE OF INVESTMENT. WHEN WE
MAKE TOO MANY CHANGES LIKE THIS
IT WILL EVENTUALLY START
ERODING. THAT INVESTMENT I AM
USING THIS ONLY AS A LAST
ARGUMENT BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
THE DATE ON THIS TO FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT TO SPEAK OF THIS BUT
BUT AFTER YEARS OF LOOKING AT
HOW THINGS WORK I AM CAN THAT
THIS WILL AN EVENTUAL WEAR AND
TEAR ON PEOPLE SINGLE FAMILY
INVESTMENTS AND THAT CONCERNS
ME. THANK YOU. THE TECHNICIAN
IS THERE AND SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE BILL MS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED I APPRECIATE
THE ROBUST DEBATE I DID WANT TO
JUST MAYBE ANSWER A FEW OF THE
CONCERNS FIRST OF ALL. IN TERMS
OF TRANSIT INVESTMENTS LET'S
ALSO KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS
BILL ONLY AFFECTS AREAS WHERE
WE HAVE ALREADY MADE. AS A
STATE NOT THE REGION MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND IN THESE HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT AREAS. THE BILL
DOES NOT TAKE EFFECT IN AN AREA
WHERE WE THINK WE MIGHT ONE DAY
HAVE HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT TAKES
AFFECTED AREAS THAT RIGHT NOW.
A VERY HIGH LEVEL HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
ATTRACT PEOPLE WHO WANT THE
KIND OF LIFESTYLE WHERE MAYBE.
THEY DON'T OWN THEIR OWN CAR OR
MAYBE THEIR FAMILY OWNS ONE
CAR. AND YET MOST LOCALITIES
STILL REQUIRE DEVELOPERS
REQUIRED THEM TO ADD MORE
PARKING THE MOST DEVELOPERS
OFTEN- THEY THEY NEED. LEADING
TO. DEVELOPMENTS THAT HAVE.
HALF EMPTY QUARTER EMPTY
PARKING LOTS OFTEN RIGHT
ADJACENT TO COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS THAT MIGHT HAVE A
PARKING USED DURING THE DAY BUT
EMPTY AT NIGHT. COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE HAD PROBLEMS WITH
SPILLOVER PARKING WITH AREAS
THAT ARE OLDER MAYBE THAT DON'T
HAVE AS MANY PARKING LOTS HAVE
SOLD THOSE THEY'VE SOLVE THEM
WITH BETTER PARKING MANAGEMENT.
THEY'VE SOLVE THEM WITH BETTER
TRANSIT. BUT AREAS THAT HAVEN'T
HAD THE PUSH TO DO THAT. HAVE
GOT US WHERE WE ARE TODAY WHICH
IS AN UNSUSTAINABLE SYSTEM WE
HAVE GROWING TRAFFIC CONGESTION
GROWING POLLUTION BAD AIR
QUALITY TERRIBLE LAND USE
PATTERNS WE HAVE TWO LITTLE
GREEN SPACE TOO LITTLE HOUSING
BECAUSE WE DEVOTE SO MUCH OF
OUR LAND SO MUCH OF A REAL
ESTATE. TO AUTOMOBILES RIGHT
NEAR WHERE WE HAVE MADE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NOW. THIS IS NOT
A RADICAL IDEA THIS IDEA OF NOT
REQUIRING THESE PARKING
MINIMUMS HAS BEEN DONE IT'S
BEEN DONE IN SAN DIEGO IT'S
BEEN DONE IN SAN FRANCISCO WAS
RECENTLY DONE BERKELEY IT WAS
DONE IN BUFFALO NEW YORK ALMOST
TEN YEARS AGO. AND WHAT
HAPPENED WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
THEY DID THIS GRAND EXPERIMENT.
MOST DEVELOPERS MANY DEVELOPERS
STILL BUILT PARKING PEOPLE WHO
ARE BUILDING MARKET RATE
HOUSING OFTEN STILL BUILT THE
SAME AMOUNT OF PARKING. BUT
WHERE DID IT MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BUILDING FOR THAT MISSING
MIDDLE PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO
BUILD THE STUDENT HOUSING
PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO BUILD THE
SMALLER STARTER APARTMENTS.
THEY REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
PARKING. AND WERE ABLE TO RENT
THOSE UNITS FOR LESS.
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPERS STARTED
TO GET CREATIVE AND WORK
TOGETHER SHARE PARKING LOTS
THEY STARTED SEEING A LOT OF
THAT IN BUFFALO WE'RE TO
DEVELOPERS WOULD SAY. WE HAVE
TO LOCK WITH BILL ONE LOCKED
TOGETHER FOR PARKING. AND BUILD
MIXED USE WITH HOUSING. NOW IN
TERMS OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ARGUMENT. THE REASON THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO GIVE DENSITY
BONUSES TO DEVELOPERS IN
EXCHANGE FOR THEM BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS THAT BY
GIVING THEM HIGHER DENSITY
WE'RE ADDING VALUE TO THOSE
LOTS. WHEN THEY BUILD MORE
UNITS THEY FOREVER HAVE A
HIGHER RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT THEY CAN RENT THOSE
APARTMENTS OVER TIME. WHEN WE
GIVE THEM PARKING REDUCTIONS WE
HAVE NOT ADDED THE VALUE YES
WE'VE REDUCED MARGINALLY THE
COST OF BUILDING THOSE UNITS.
BUT THEY KNOW. WHAT MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS KNOW WHICH IS THAT
THOSE UNITS WILL RENT FOR LESS
MONEY IF THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE
TWO PARKING SPACES AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT. SO OFFERING THEM
JUST A PARKING REDUCTION HAS
NEVER RESULTED AS FAR AS I
COULD SEE IN ONE UNIT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THEY ARE
TAKING A DENSITY BONUS FOR
THOSE EXTRA UNITS THE PARKING
REDUCTION IS OFFERED TO THEM TO
SERVICE THAT HIGHER DENSITY
ONLY. I ASK THE ADVOCATES SHOW
ME A UNITS ONLY A PERKY A
BUILDING. WHERE DEVELOPER ONLY
TOOK THAT PARKING REDUCTION IN
EXCHANGE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THEY COULDN'T SHOW ME ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT BECAUSE THE
PARKING REDUCTION IS NOT THE
PRIZE THE PRIZE IS THE EXTRA
DENSITY. AND WE STILL ALLOW
THAT UNDER THIS BILL THOSE
DENSITY BONUSES STILL EXIST AND
WHAT SAN DIEGO SHOWED THAT THEY
STILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
AND BUILT BUILT THEIR EVEN MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS. IN ADDITION.
MANY OF THE SAME AREAS THAT
HAVE HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT
ALREADY HAVE INCLUSIONARY.
ZONING ORDINANCES THAT REQUIRE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN NEW UNITS
IN NEW BUILDINGS. SO BY
ALLOWING THE DEVELOPER TO
REDUCE SOME OF THEIR COSTS BY
REDUCING SOME OF THE PARKING.
WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO GET
MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS BECAUSE
THEY ALREADY HAVE INCLUSIONARY
ZONING REQUIREMENTS FOR INCLUDE
FOR AFFORDABLE UNITS. I THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT POLICY I
THINK THIS SHOWS OUR VALUE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO PRIORITIZE
PEOPLE OVER CARS AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL BILL IS ABOUT.
THE BILL ABOUT USING LAND
BETTER NOT DEVOTING SO MANY
OCEANS OF CONCRETE TO THE
AUTOMOBILE IT'S ABOUT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE INVESTMENTS
WE'VE ALREADY MADE IN HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT AND GIVING
PEOPLE A CHANCE. TO SWITCH TO
THAT AS OPPOSED TO ALWAYS HAVE
A BELIEVING THAT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON WHO LIVES IN OUR
COMMUNITY WILL SHOW UP WITH
THEIR OWN A CAR AND USE THAT AS
THEIR PRIMARY WAY OF GETTING
AROUND TOWN. MEMBERS WITH THAT
I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH THAT CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. HE'S A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MISS
FRIEDMAN MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
IN OUR. PASS A RETAINER FILE
ITEM. THIRTY SIX. PREVIOUS SET
OF FIVE THIRTY FIVE THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE A. B. FOR
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHER AN ACCOLADE INFORMATICA.
DR RABIA EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
RACISM IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WE PAINFULLY
WITNESSED WHAT HAPPENS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO OUR
IMMIGRANT BROTHERS AND SISTERS
WHO BORE THE BRUNT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WHILE WE CONTINUE TO
WAIT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S TO PASS
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM WHICH HAS TAKEN TOO LONG
AND PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC RACISM
WE MUST ACT WITH URGENCY NOW.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LEGACY OF
LEADING BY EXPANDING HEALTH
COVERAGE TO THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE EXPANDED HEALTH COVERAGE TO
ALL CHILDREN IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE EXPANDED IT TO YOUNG ADULTS.
AND NOW AB FOUR WILL CONTINUE
IN THIS VEIN BY EXPANDING
MEDICAID I'LL TO INCOME
ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS.
SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL ENDS THE
EXCLUSION TO HEALTH CARE ACCESS
DUE TO IMMIGRATION STATUS. BY
REMOVING IMMIGRATION STATUS AS
AN ELIGIBILITY BARRIER TO
MEDICO CALIFORNIA CAN BUILD A
MORE UNIVERSAL EQUITABLE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM FOR ALL WHO CALL
THIS STATE HOME. NOW IS THE
TIME FOR US TO BE ANTI RACIST
TO BE INTENTIONAL AND TO INVEST
IN ALL CALIFORNIANS THE CENTRAL
NEEDS TO ACHIEVE EQUITY AND
HEALTH CARE ACCESS. AFTER
BATTLING THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
OF THE CENTURY WE MUST PROVIDE
THESE TAX PAYING CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO OUR
ECONOMY AND SOCIAL FABRIC FOR
DECADES WITH THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO BE SAFE AND HEALTHY.
FELLOW MEMBERS WE INVEST IN THE
HEALTH OF OUR STATE NGUYEN WHEN
WE INVEST IN HEALTH COVERAGE
FOR LOW INCOME UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS WHO ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
WORK FORCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR RAMYA MISTER DAVID CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER LET ME START
FIRST BY THANKING OUR PHYSICIAN
CALLING FROM FRESNO. FOR HIS
DOG LEADERSHIP ON THIS TOPIC
AND I'VE BEEN A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL IN EVERY
GENERATION SINCE HE'S
INTRODUCED AT. TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THE VERY FIRST
LAWSUIT I'VE EVER WORKED ON WAS
A CHALLENGE TO PROPOSITION ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. ONE AT THAT TIME
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE AT
LEAST A MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
THOUGHT THAT IT MADE SENSE TO
DENY HEALTH CARE TO FOLKS WHO
BECAUSE OF THE VAGARIES AND THE
UNFAIRNESS OF OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM- TO DENY THEM HEALTH
CARE. AND I WOULD SUGGEST TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS LATER. THINGS
HAVE CHANGED SUBSTANTIALLY NOT
JUST BECAUSE WE'RE IN THIS
MOMENT A PANDEMIC IN RECESSION
WE'RE WE ARE SEEN THE IMPACT OF
A BROKEN HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ON
MANY OF OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE. BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT IF YOU LACK.
DOCUMENTATION AND YOUR
UNINSURED YOU ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO FALL ILL MORE OFTEN.
TO DIE YOUNGER TO BE ONE
EMERGENCY AWAY FROM FINANCIAL
RUIN. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
FOLKS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROVIDING HEALTH CARE. IN THIS
CONTEXT MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE AND
LOCAL REVENUES. PAYING OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
TAXES. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING ACCESS
TO OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ACTUALLY PAID
INTO THAT SYSTEM AND SO. I ASK
YOU I ASK ALL OF US TO STAND UP
FOR THE IDEA THAT IF WE REMOVE.
IMMIGRATION STATUS AS AN
ELIGIBILITY BARRIER TO MEDIC
CAL NOT ONLY ARE WE BUILDING A
FAIR SYSTEM. FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD RECEIVE
HEALTH CARE BUT WERE ACTUALLY
ENSURING THAT ALL OF US ARE
SAFE FOR ALL OF US ARE
HEALTHIER PARTICULAR DURING
THIS TIME OF PANDEMIC WITH
THAT. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ALSO TO WANT TO
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
AND ALL WHO HAVE ADVOCATED OVER
THE YEARS. THE BRING FINALLY
DIGNITY AND HEALTH CARE FOR A
POPULATION THAT HAS WORKED
EXTREMELY HARD EXTREMELY HARD
TO MANY MANY OF OUR STORIES
AND- OF US WHO ARE IN THE
LEGISLATURE OR- WHO HAVE BEEN
RAISED HERE WHO CAME FROM
IMMIGRANT PARENTS WILL TELL
YOU. THE LONG HOURS OF WAITING
WITHOUT HEALTH CARE THE AMOUNT
OF PAIN AND SUFFERING. WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO GET ANY ANY CARE
LET ALONE QUALITY OF CARE
MEDICINE OR OR BASIC STUFF THAT
MOST PEOPLE TAKE FOR GRANTED.
SO I'M NOT GONNA GO TOO LONG ON
THIS OTHER THAN THIS OTHER THAN
TO SAY THAT DOESN'T MEAN. THIS
IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
MEANINGFUL THINGS THAT WILL
VOTE ON THE LEGISLATURE. HI
THIS YEAR AND I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUES AND ALL WHO VOTE YES
AND URGED FOR STRONG YES THANKS.
THANK THIAGO. THIS PARA QUE AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR AND I
JUST WANTED TO ADD SO MUCH OF
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
ABOUT THE- THE OUTCOMES THAT
THIS MAKES BETTER IN THE LIVES
THAT ARE IMPROVED IS REALLY
CRITICAL BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT
TO FORGET THE COST SAVINGS THAT
COME WITH THIS MEASURE FR
EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND PROVIDING
PREVENTATIVE CARE WE SAVE FOUR
DOLLARS DOWN THE LINE SO NOT
ONLY IS THIS BETTER FOR
CALIFORNIANS IT'S BETTER FOR A
BOTTOM LINE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AMERICA. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DR RANDALL
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
HEALTHCARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
I HOPE THAT WE CAN TREAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY AND GIVE
THEM THE SAME DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE I
HUMBLY RESPECT AND I VOTE.
QUICKLAW THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I
FIFTY ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. AVERAGE THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. AB
THIRTY FIVE. BY MISTER CHOW
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOW AN
ACCOLADE THE FALSE INFORMATION.
MISTER CHOW YOU MAIL BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THIRTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
TO DISCLOSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE A POLICY TO ADDRESS THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION THAT
COULD ONE LEAD TO PHYSICAL HARM
TO HAS VERIFIABLE IN AUTHENTIC
CONTENT OR THREE DECEPTIVELY
MANIPULATE OR DISRUPT THE
BEHAVIOR OF USERS. SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS FORM AN INTEGRAL PART
OF HOW U. S. ADULTS CONSUME
NEWS ACCORDING TO THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER IN 202053% OF
U. S. ADULTS GOT THEIR NEWS
FROM SOCIAL MEDIA IT WAS
REPORTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT APPROXIMATELY 50% OF
PEOPLE SHARE A NEW STORY ONLY
TO FIND OUT LATER THAT THE NEW
STORY WASFALSE. RECENTLY
RESEARCHERS AT UC SAN FRANCISCO
FOUND THAT AFTER THE TERM
CHINESE VIRUS WE USED. WAS USED
WHEN TALKING ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN THE NUMBER OF CORONA
VIRUS RELATED TWEAKS WITHIN
ANTI ASIAN PASSED TAX ROSE BY
8000310051% MAYBE REPEAT
8000310051% ACCORDING TO THE
STOP API HE COALITION BETWEEN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE HAVE
BEEN. OVER SIX THOUSAND HATE
INCIDENTS NATIONWIDE TARGETING
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER INDIVIDUALS WITH 40%
OF THOSE INCIDENTS TAKING PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA SO THE NEXUS
BETWEEN SOCIAL MEDIA AND
MISINFORMATION IT'S QUITE
EVIDENT. SOME MAJOR PLATFORMS
HAVE MADE A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
IN COMMUNICATING WITH THEIR
USERS AND THE PUBLIC ON THEIR
EFFORTS IN COMBATING THE SPREAD
OF MISINFORMATION HOWEVER NOT
ALL PLATFORMS ARE DOING THIS AB
THIRTY FIVE REQUIRES SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO MAKE THOSE
DISCLOSURES TO THEIR CONSUMERS.
THE BILL DOES NOT DIRECT HALL
PLATFORM SHOULD CURATE THE
CONTENT IT ONLY REQUIRES
PLATFORMS TO GIVE A DISCLOSURE
AND MAKE IT EASILY ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC AB THIRTY FIVE IS
NOT AN ONEROUS. REQUIREMENT ON
PLATFORMS BUT IT IS THEY STEP
THE RIGHT THE- IN. THE SPREAD
OF MISS. WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
MICHELLE. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB
LAUREL ALL MEMBERS. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIED UP I FORTY
FOUR. KNOWS ELEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT AB FORTY SIX
CORKERY ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN TWO
YEARS. MISERY THIS MY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
EXCITED TO PRESENT AB FORTY SIX
A CRITICAL YOUTH LED MEASURE
SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT STATE
LAWMAKERS HEAR THE VOICES OF
CALIFORNIA'S USE. BY
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT COMMISSION
THE COMMISSION WILL BE
COMPRISED SOLELY OF YOUTH AND
ADVISE THE STATE GOVERNMENT ON
POLICY ISSUES THAT IMPACT YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RIVAS SENIOR
DISCUSSION AVAILABLE YET
KRIKALEV THE ROLE. DESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. RESERVE VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
ICE FIFTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS ITEM
THIRTY NINE FORTY EIGHT
COOPERATE. SO BILL FORTY EIGHT
US MILLER GOODS AND OTHERS ACT
RELATING LONG FOR. AS GOOD AS I
YOU MAIL IN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
FORTY SEC MINUTE STANDARD ON
LAUNCH USE OF SO CALLED LESS
LETHAL WEAPONS LIKE RUBBER
BULLETS AND TEAR GAS. INTO
PROTESTERS LAST SUMMER OVER A
HUNDRED PROTESTERS BYSTANDERS
AND JOURNALISTS SUSTAINED
SERIOUS INJURIES FROM RUBBER
BULLETS AND BEAN BAG ROUNDS AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING SEVEN PEOPLE WHO LOST
AN EYE. IT IS CLEAR THERE'S
NEED TO BE STRICT STRICT
STANDARDS FOR USE OF LESS
LETHAL WEAPONS FOR CROWD
CONTROL AB FORTY CREATE
STANDARDS THAT ONLY ALLOW
TRAINED OFFICERS TO USE THESE
TOOLS IF THEY ARE A THREAT TO
SERIOUS INJURY TO INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING OFFICERS. OFFICERS BE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES ONE THE
CROWD TO GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE SCENE
THEY CAN ONLY USE THESE WEAPONS
IN A MANNER PROPORTIONAL TO THE
THREAT AND NOT INDISCRIMINATELY
AGAINST A CROWD OR TARGETED AT
THE HEAD OR NECK. THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IS
SUPPORTED BY A WIDE VARIETY OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS THE
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION COALITION UNIONS
AND COMMUNITY ADVOCATES I ALSO
WANT TO THANK PORAC IN THE
POLICE CHIEFS WHOM I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CLOSELY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK I'M THROUGH THE PROCESS
WITH A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THEY WAS CONTROLS
MISTER LUCKY YOUR RECORD. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL OF BE VERY CLEAR
ON THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ONLY USES THESE
TOOLS WHEN THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
AN ATTACK OR THE RIGHT. THIS IS
NOT JUST A DEMONSTRATION THIS
IS NOT JUST TO PROTEST. AND I
CAN TELL YOU IS. POSSIBLY ONE
OF THE ONLY ONES IN THIS GROUP
THAT ACTUALLY. FACED A SURGING
GROUP OF PEOPLE THROWING
OBJECTS AND ITEMS ASKED YOU TO
CREATE A WHOLE DIFFERENT
DYNAMIC THAN WHAT YOU HAVE
SEEN. IN MANY OF THESE
DEMONSTRATIONS THESE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF RIOTOUS
BEHAVIOR AND ASSAULTIVE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THE OFFICERS
WHO HAVE BEEN CALLED TO THE
SCENE TO PRESERVE THE PEACE.
AND I CAN I CAN TAKE THEIR
NUMBER THINGS ARE VERY VERY.
UNFAIR IN THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE-
CHECKLIST ITEMS THAT YOU
COMPLY WITH THERE MUST BE
REPEATED ANNOUNCEMENTS ALONG
FORSMAN INTENDS TO USE KINETIC
ENERGY PROJECTILES OR CHEMICAL
AGENTS IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
NO I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY HOW YOU
MEET THE CRITERIA AND HOW MANY
LANGUAGES YOU HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH IN ORDER TO MEET THE
STATUTE. BUT I WOULD TELL YOU
THAT- WHEN THESE CROWDS COME
UPON YOU IT HAPPENS VERY VERY
FAST. AND WHILE I WAS IN. THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE I ASKED.
THE AUTHOR IF ROCKS WOULD BE
JUSTIFICATION FOR USING THESE
PRO DID THESE TOLLS AND I GOT
AN UNCLEAR ANSWER I'M TELLING
YOU. WHEN THESE OBJECTS ARE
FLYING OUT TO. IT CREATES A
DYNAMIC THAT YOU'VE NEED
INTERVENTION YOU NEED TOLLS AND
YOU DON'T WANT TO USE WEAPONS.
RIGHT YOU WANT TO USE LESS
LETHAL TOOLS WHICH IS OR WHAT.
OUR QUESTION HERE. WHAT IN THE
WORLD ARE WE DOING TO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF WE PASSED
MEASURES LIKE THIS TO ALLOW
THEM TO PROTECT THIS. THAT'S
WHAT I'M ASKING. I ASK FOR YOUR
A STRONG NO VOTE ON THIS. MR
SAY ARE TOWARD THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTY EIGHT. THIS BILL
ENDANGERS BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE CITIZENS THAT ARE
CHARGED TO PROTECT. WELL SOME
OF THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS ARE
REASONABLE SUCH AS REQUIRING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ISSUE
WARNINGS IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
BEFORE DEPLOYING TEAR GAS. THE
BILL GOES WELL BEYOND
REASONABLE REQUIREMENTS AND HAS
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE OVERLY
DEMANDING AND TIME CONSUMING TO
IMPLEMENT. THIS BILLS MANY
REQUIREMENTS ALL EXCESSIVELY
HINDER LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO VIOLENT
MOB AND PROTECT INNOCENT
CITIZENS. THE SAN DIEGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT RECENTLY ADOPTED ITS
OWN POLICIES AND THIS BILL
EXCEEDS MANY OF THOSE STANDARDS.
WE SHOULD USE SAN DIEGO'S
POLICY AS A CASE STUDY TO SEE
pHOW EFFECTIVE IT IS BEFORE
JUMPING AHEAD IN ADOPTING A
STATE WIDE POLICY. WITH EVEN
STRICTER REQUIREMENTS THAT'LL
HAPPEN HAMPER ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. I HAVE
SEEN SOME OF THESE RIGHTS. FROM
THE BEGINNING AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THEY BE
CONTROLLED FROM THE BEGINNING
AND TAKING AWAY THIS VALUABLE
TOOL FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TRY TO DISPERSE CROWDS THAT
HAVE GONE BEYOND PEACEFUL
PROTESTING AND INTO RIDING. IS
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS. DR WEBER YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I WASN'T PLANNING ON
RISING- FOR THIS BILL- AND-
AUTHOR DID A EXCELLENT JOB IN
PRESENTING THE BILL AND THE
REASONS WHY. THERE WAS A RIOT
IN MY CITY- A YEAR AGO FROM
SUNDAY- SOMETHING HAPPENED
UNFORTUNATELY WAS AROUND THE
SAME TIME AS GEORGE FLOYD. AND
YOU KNOW I COME FROM A VERY
SMALL CITY- LA MESA WITH HIGHER
SELVES JEWEL ON THE HILL WELL
TOWN. I BUT BECAUSE OFFICER
SOMETHING THAT HE SHOULD NOT
HAVE. THE RIGHT WAS A
REGIONALES FOR SAN DIEGO CAME
TO MY CITY. IT WAS HORRIFIC- IT
STARTED OFF AS A VERY PEACEFUL
PROTESTS BUT LATER IN THE
EVENING PEOPLE CAME INTO THE
CITY WITH OTHER OBJECTIVES. AND
IT TURNED INTO A FULL SCALE
RIOTS. I'M HAD THIS BILL BEEN
AND AN AFFECTED PROBABLY WOULD
NOT HAVE IMPACTED THE OUTCOME
BECAUSE OUR POLICE OFFICERS DID
WARN- THE RIOTERS. THAT THEY
WERE TO DISPERSE- AND YET THEY
STAYED IN UNFORTUNATELY THE
ENDED UP BURNING DOWN SOME OF
OUR BUILDINGS. BUT ONE OF
THESE- PROJECTILE. WEAPONS WAS
USED. AND HIT A WOMAN AND I.
AND SHE IS BLIND IN THAT EYE.
SO I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT
THERE ARE FEWTHINGS IN THIS
BILL THAT ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. ONE IS TRAINING. YOU
MUST MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE
TRAINED TO USE THESE WEAPONS.
THE SECOND IS THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT BE INDISCRIMINATELY USING
THESE WEAPONS AND THE CROWDS.
THE THIRD IS TRANSPARENCY IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT IF AN
ACCIDENT OCCURS. THAT THERE IS
A REPORT MADE IMMEDIATELY AND
THAT CITIZENS ARE AWARE. SO I
RISE IN SUPPORT AS SOMEONE WHO
WAS ON CITY COUNCIL WHO HAD TO
DEAL WITH THIS SITUATION A YEAR
AGO FROM SUNDAY. IT'S NOT EASY
DEALING WITH RIOTS ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE COMING
FROM OUTSIDE TO PURPOSELY DO
DAMAGE TO YOUR CITY. I FELT FOR
OUR POLICE OFFICERS THAT DAY
BECAUSE THEY WERE BEING
PLUMMETED FOR HOURS WITH ROCKS
AND BOTTLES. AND SO THIS DOES
NOT TAKE AWAY THEIR ABILITY TO
USE IT IF NECESSARY IT PROVIDES
MORE STANDARDS AND TRAINING AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE END. AND
THAT IS WHY I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. DECADE AFTER WEBER
MR WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANT TO THANK MY NEIGHBORS FROM
SAN DIEGO AND FROM THE MESA FOR
ALSO SPEAK AND MORE ELOQUENTLY
THAN I COULD ON THIS BILL. ON
BECAUSE THE DAY AFTER WE HAD
OUR INCIDENCES IN THE CITY
LIMITS THAT WE HAD IN MY
DISTRICT THE CITY DOWNTOWN SAN
DIEGO ANOTHER DEMONSTRATION
THAT ALSO WAS LARGELY PEACEFUL.
UNTIL THERE WAS AN AFFRONT
UNTIL THERE IS A DECISION TO BE
ABLE TO START ON LEASE. SOME OF
THESE WEAPONS UPON THE CROWN.
AND AS I ENGAGE WITH MY POLICE
DEPARTMENT SINCE IT WAS BROUGHT
UP HERE- BY AN OPPOSING
SPEAKER. I'LL LET YOU KNOW THAT.
THEY WERE FEELING A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY UNDER THE PRESSURES
THAT THEY RUN NO DOUBT. BUT FOR
ME TO ADVOCATE FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO NOT ENGAGE NOT CROSS
THAT LINE CERTAINLY STRUCK A
NERVE FOR THEM AND I ASKED THEM.
HOW MANY CITIZENS HOW MANY
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS. WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE COLLATERAL FOR THE
RISK FOR THE THREAT OR THE
POTENTIAL THAT YOU MIGHT BE
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
OUR HOLD THE LINE. THERE'S NO
GOOD ANSWER FOR THAT. FROM
THEIR PERSPECTIVE BUT I THINK
THERE IS A GOOD ANSWER FOR THAT
BECAUSE WE SHOULD NOT BE.
FORCING SOME OF THESE
CONNECTICUT JACK DIALS THESE
RUBBER BULLETS CAUSING HARM. TO
MOTHERS TO CHILDREN TO MEMBERS
OF THE PRESS THE OTHERS THAT
ARE THERE. PEACEABLE PEACEFULLY
PROTESTING IN BEING A PART OF
THAT MOMENT. AND TEAR GAS.
MEDIAN BY THE GENEVA CONVENTION
IN NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE. IS
WHAT'S ON THE FLOOR APPEAR FOR
DEBATE TODAY. TO WHAT STANDARDS
DO WE HOLD OURSELVES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN WE WANT TO SET
THE STANDARD STATE WINE. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT MUCH OF THIS
WILL BE TALKED ABOUT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IN PARTNERSHIP
TO BE ABLE TO GET THE DETAILS
RIGHT BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THEY HAVE THE TOOLS
AT THEIR DISPOSAL WHEN THE TIME
IS NECESSARY. BUT TO BE ABLE TO
SET THE STANDARD HERE TODAY AND
NOW N WITH A PART
PARTICIPATION OF THE SENATE AS
WELL. TO SAY THESE ARE
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY INTERACTION. WHEN
THESE TENSE SITUATIONS ARISE.
THAT WE WILL NOT MAIENSCHEIN.
THAT WILL NOT CAUSE SIX NATION.
THAT WILL NOT CAUSE ON JUST.
BURDEN OF PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
AS- TO PEACEFULLY EXPRESS THE
RIGHT TO PROTEST. I ASK THAT
YOU GIVE THIS BILL A CHANCE AND
YOU VOTE YES. ON SB FORTY EIGHT
THANK. THANK MISS WARD MR MATH.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
MISS SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D TO WAS
NOT GOING TO SPEAK THIS BILL
LISTENING AS FLOOR DEBATE I
FEEL CAN TO. AS OF THE FEW
THAT'S BEEN TRAINED BY ARM. BY
OUR ARMENIA GUARD ON HOW TO
HANDLE THESE RIGHT TYPE
SITUATIONS. WHO HAS BEEN
TRAINED ON LESS THAN LEE TOLLS.
WHO HIS EXPERIENCE COMBAT. I
THINK THAT. WE NEED TO REFLECT
A LITTLE BIT MEMBERS. I
REMEMBER MANY OF YOU. AFTER THE
RIOTS IN DC AFTER THE STORMING
OF CAPITAL GOING ALL MY GOD HOW
COULD THIS HAPPEN. BUT NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TAKING AWAY
A TOOL. IN OTHER TOOLS OUT OF
THE TOOLBOX. FROM THOSE THAT
PROTECT AND SERVE NOT JUST
PROTECT AND SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES BACK HOME OF
PROTECTING SERVICE HERE. AT THE
STATE CAPITOL. YOU'RE TAKING
AWAY A TOOL. THE TOLD FRANKLY A
LOT OF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE OTTAWA
VALLEY IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THESE THINGS HAPPEN IN SECONDS.
IN SECONDS MEMBERS. HOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE HAD TO MAKE A SPLIT
SECOND DECISION. UNDER THESE
TYPE OF CIRCUMSTANCES. WHAT DO
YOU HAVE A MASSIVE CROWD COMING
AT YOU. ANOTHER POINT. IN IN
FRANKLY I'M SICK AND TIRED OF
HEARING THIS ONE IN AND I'LL
PROBABLY GET HEALTH FOR THE
PRESS LATER BUT I DON'T REALLY
CARE. I AM OVER HEARING ABOUT.
THESE POOR PARENTS AND CHILDREN
IN THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THESE RIOTS WHAT YOU DECIDE TO
BECOME A RIGHT YOU BECOME A
COMBATIVE. YOU ARE ACTIVELY. A
GRAPHENE. IN THE AREA. NO
LONGER BEING PEACEFUL THIS
ISN'T A PROTEST THIS IS A
HOLDING THE SIGN UP. THIS ISN'T
MARCHING AROUND. THIS IS THE
ADDRESS OF THE ASSAULTING AN
OBJECTIVE THAT IS WHAT WRITERS
DO. STOP TRYING TO MAKE THEM
SOUND. SITTING IN A SMOKE
CIRCLE BEING PEACEFUL. MEMBERS
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A DUTY. AN
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE TRYING TO TAKE THESE
TOOLS AWAY FROM TAKE AN OATH.
KISS THEIR FAMILIES GOODBYE
EVERY NIGHT. EVERY DAY. TO
GOING TO PROTECT YOU. TO
PROTECT YOUR COMMUNITIES TO
PROTECT YOUR FAMILY'S WHILE
YOU'RE UP HERE. AND YOU WANT TO
TAKE AWAY A TOOL FROM THEM.
MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU TO VOTE NO.
I THINK THIS MATHIS MISTER
BRYANT IN THE REAR CHAMBER. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. WHAT A HELL OF A
FIRST BILL TO SPEAK ALL. I WAS
INVOLVED IN A PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATION LAST YEAR.
THIRTEEN FAIRFAX IN LOS
ANGELES. MY PARTNER LAMAR WHO
WALK DOWN THE FINAL OF CENTER
OF THIS ROOM WITH ME JUST LAST
FRIDAY. THAT WAS SWORN IN. THE
PROJECTILES AIMED AT HER AS SHE
WAS PUSHED TO THE GROUND AS
WERE SWALLOWED BY BATONS AND
OTHER THINGS WE WERE NOT
RIOTERS OR LOOTERS BEFORE
PEOPLE FRUSTRATED DISGRUNTLED
LIKE MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE AWAY A
TOOL OUT OF THE TOOL KIT. IT
RAISES THE STANDARD AND WE
SHOULD RAISE THE STANDARD
RESPECTFULLY I DISAGREE. WITH
MY COLLEAGUES SUGGESTING THAT
THIS IS MUCH LIKE A WAR ZONE.
THESE ALL NEIGHBORHOODS THESE
ARE COMMUNITIES THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I THINK WE SHOULD
TAKE IT EVEN FURTHER. BUT I'M
URGING THIS ENTIRE ROOM TO VOTE
YES AND I'M HONORED TO VOTE YES
TODAY HERE MY FIRST DAY. AS A
FULL FLEDGED MEMBER OF THIS
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE I DON'T
KNOW IF I COULD- GIVE MUCH MORE
THAN OUR NEWEST COLLEAGUE HAS
GIVEN IN THAT BRIEF STATEMENT
BUT I JUST WANT TO BE SURE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
VOTING ON NOTHING IN THIS BILL
PROHIBITS THE USE OF LESS THAN
LETHAL FORCE WEAPONS EVEN TEAR
GAS WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO
OUTLAW TO BE HONEST. BUT
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
FACT MY OWN POLICE CHIEF. PORAC
THE UNION THAT REPRESENTS
POLICE OFFICERS WE'VE TRIED TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS DONE IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS PEOPLE AT A
PROTEST. TO SUGGEST THAT YOUR
PROTEST IN BECAUSE OF A
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND SOMEBODY
OVER THERE THERE IS A WATER
BOTTLE NEAR A POLICE OFFICER
THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SHOOT INDISCRIMINATELY RUBBER
BULLETS ALONG THE ENTIRE CROWD
IS RIDICULOUS I HOPE WE ALL
BELIEVE IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AND NOT. TO BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
RIGHT AND SHOULDN'T BE TARGETED
BECAUSE SOMEBODY IN THE CROWD.
HURLED A PLASTIC BOTTLE
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED LAST SUMMER. IT WASN'T
JUST IN SAN DIEGO WE SAW IT
HAPPEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN
LA AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO IS HERE WE SAW A
YOUNG WOMAN LOSE HER EYE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WE SAW
JOURNALISTS GET SHOT IN THE
GROWING QUITE HONESTLY I DON'T
WANT TO KNOW WHAT HE LOST. IN
LONG BEACH. THIS IS SERIOUS.
AND THESE ARE NOT TARGETED AT
INDIVIDUALS WERE NECESSARILY
DOING ANYTHING WRONG. IF IN
FACT SOMEBODY IS DOING
SOMETHING WRONG A POLICE
OFFICERS HAVE THE RIGHT TO USE
THESE LESS THAN LETHAL WEAPONS
AGAINST. THE INDIVIDUAL TO STOP
THE CHARGE TO STOP BEING
TARGETED. BUT THIS IS ABOUT
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED UP TO EXPRESS THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS. AND
CAN'T DO SO BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
FEAR OF THEIR OWN LIFE FROM
SOMETHING THAT QUITE HONESTLY
COULD TAKE THEIR LIFE WE CALL
THEM LESS THAN LETHAL. BUT WE
KNOW THAT THEY'VE ACTUALLY
CAUSED TO DEATH BEFORE. SO I
FEEL LIKE THIS IS A BALANCE
BILL. OBVIOUSLY I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU BELIEVE THAT I I'M CREDIBLE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEIR
NEUTRAL PORAC IN THE POLICE
CHIEFS. BUT IT'S TIME THAT WE
INSURE THE PEOPLE STILL HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SHOW UP AT A
PROTEST IN NOT WORRIED THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE THEIR AYE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY RIGHT.
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE.
WELL CLOSE ROLE.
CALVET EYES FORTY THREE NO
SEVENTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BRIEFLY
BACK TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS. WE
ARE VERY HONORED TO HAVE GUESTS
FROM A DELEGATION FROM PAKISTAN
WITH US TODAY. ON BEHALF OF THE
SPEAKER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS OF THIS
ASSEMBLY. WE WELCOME THE
GOVERNOR OF PUNJAB. CHAUDHARY
MUHAMMAD SARWAR. THE CONSUL
GENERAL TO PAKISTAN IN LOS
ANGELES ABDUL JABBAR NAME ON.
AS WELL AS OTHER DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS IN THE DELEGATION IN OUR
GALLERY PUNJAB IS AN INCREDIBLE
PROVINCE WE THANK YOU FOR
VISITING CALIFORNIA AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN WE MAY
VISIT HER JOB WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS. AND MR CHRIS HOLDEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
GUEST INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I WON'T TAKE BUT
A MOMENT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
DOCTOR ASIF MEHMOOD WHO IS THE
BRIDGE BETWEN POND JOB AND
CALIFORNIA WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR GUIDANCEAND
LEADERSHIP AND WE WANT TO
WELCOME YOU AS OUR- OUR LEADER
HAS INDICATED AND WE ARE
HONORED TO HAVE YOU HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY THERE
ARE NO SHORTAGES OF CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
TOGETHER AND DEALING WITH THOSE
BECOMES ALL OF A COMMUNITY
WORKING TOGETHER IT'S MY HOPE
THAT IN THE COMING MONTHS WE
WILL BRING FORWARD A RESOLUTION
CALLING FOR THE CULTURAL
EXCHANGE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
PUT JOB PAKISTAN. AND AGAIN I
JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES WE
WELCOME YOU HERE TODAY. MEMBERS
BACK IN FILE ORDER. WHERE I'D
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE.
THIS IS MISS GONZALES. FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE. AB. SEVENTY
FOUR. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION. THIS
GONZALEZ THIS IS A BILL TO
REQUIRE EIGHTY TO ALLOW FOR
DIRECT DEPOSIT ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLICK BELOW FOR
THE ROLE MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS
OUT OF THE. WELL CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE OF A I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB ONE OH
FIVE BY MR HOLDEN CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO HUMAN
RESOURCES MR HOLDING EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FIVE A
BILL THAT IDENTIFIESAND
REFORMS PROCESSES THAT HINDER
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR. IN THE CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM AS YOU MAY RECALL LAST
YEAR GOVERNOR NEWSOM TOOK A
BOLD STEP FORWARD BY SIGNING MY
BILL NINE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
REQUIRES EACH PUBLICLY HELD
CORPORATION WHOSE PUBLIC WHOSE
PRINCIPAL EXECUTIVE OFFICES ARE
LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA TO HAVE A
MINIMUM NUMBER OF DIRECTORS
FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ON ITS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WELL THOSE EFFORTS
WERE APPLAUDED BY MANY THE
PUBLIC SECTOR'S AT ANOTHER
PLACE WHERE UPWARD MOBILITY HAS
BEEN HINDERED. THEREFORE AB ONE
OH FIVE CALLS FOR DIVERSITY ON
ALL CALIFORNIA STATE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT HAVE
VOLUNTEERS ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT THE STATE
BOARD PERSONNEL BOARD
ESTABLISHED A PROCESS THAT
IDENTIFIES IT INCLUDES
DIVERSITY AND BEST PRACTICES IN
THE HIRING PROCESS A DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVE ON ALL ASPECTS OF
THE HIRING PROCESS PROVIDES FOR
MORE DIVERSE WORKFORCE AND
BETTER OUTCOMES. AND FINALLY AB
ONE OH FIVE REQUIRES THE CAL HR
SUBMIT WITHIN AN ANNUAL REPORT
FORCE ANALYSIS AND CONSISTENT
CENSUS REPORTS ALL OF THE
ADVERSE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
DEPARTMENTS AGAINST EMPLOYEES.
IT CALLS FOR THE REPORT TO
INCLUDE THE TYPE OF ADVERSE
ACTION ETHNICITY GENDER AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION IF AVAILABLE.
THE GOAL IS TO SEE IF THERE ARE
PATTERNS OF DISCRIMINATION AND
THE DEPARTMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS HOLDEN. C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM QUICKLAW THE ROLE. RESERVE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE.
DECIDABLE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT HIGHS FIFTY TWO KNOWS TEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
I'M GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE. IF MISTER COOPER IS READY.
APOLOGIES HIS BURKE. THIS IS
THE END OF WHICH WE PASS
TEMPORARILY THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE A. B. THREE EIGHTY
SIX. FILE I'M. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY SIX.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC RECORDS MISTER COOPER
THANK MISTER SPEAKER AB THREE
SIX CREATED PUBLIC RECORDS
DISCLOSURE WITH A HIGH LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY STRUCTURE FOR
CALPERS TO BRING PRIVATE DEBT
INVESTMENTS IN HOUSE A PRIVATE
DEBT INVESTMENT INVOLVED DIRECT
LOANS TO COMPANIES SEEKING
FUNDS FOR OPERATIONS OR GROWTH
FOR CALPERS IS NOT PERTINENT TO
MEET ITS ACTUARIAL TARGETS
WHILE MANAGING RISK THE GETS
LOST. CURRENTLY ALMOST ALL
PENSION SYSTEM INVESTMENTS IN
THIS AREA ARE MADE BY HANDLING
FEES ME HANDING EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTORS TO
OUTSIDE FIRMS TO MANAGE THIS
CLUB RETIREES IT'S AN
UNNECESSARY EXPENSE TO THE
PENSION SYSTEM THE FEE
REQUIREMENTS FOR EVERYONE
BILLION MANAGED BY OUTSIDE
PRIVATE DEBT FIRM AT UP TO ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER FIVE
YEARS. THAT'S ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION FOR THE NAY FIVE YEARS
THANK BE SAY BY BROUGH THE MAN
THESE INVESTMENTS AND HOW AB
THREE SIX BY THE FOR. DEPEND ON
PINCH FOR THE RICH AND THEIR
FAMILIES SECURITY WILL BE
RETIREMENT CARRY ALL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ARE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER. ST
DISCUSSION ABOUT. ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS WILL
DECIDE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
FIVE NO SEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL. ON MS FREEDMAN'S
ITEM FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB
FOURTEEN OH ONE IN THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
WHICH TO THEM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. AND THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY FIVE KNOWS
FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
BACK IN FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB ONE OH
SEVEN MY MISTER SALAS CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
LICENSURE AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION- FOR MISTER
SALAS. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OF SEVEN WHICH EXPANDS
AND IMPROVES THE TEMPORARY
LICENSURE PROGRAM FOR SPOUSES
OF ACTIVE ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THEY WERE SALAS YES MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I
AUTHORED A SIMILAR MEASURE LAST
YEAR. AND CAN OF CO AUTHOR IN
THE PAST- BUT THIS THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR. MILITARY SPOUSES
LIKE THOSE OF MY DISTRICT A
BILL AIRFORCE BASE. WHO
OFTENTIMES ARE COMING IN AND
OUT OF COMMUNITIES IN AND OUT
OF STATES. THEY RECEIVED THEIR
LICENSURE THEY NEED TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BETTER. CONTINUE
THEIR CAREERS. AS THEY MOVE IN
AND OUT OF CALIFORNIA SO THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS HIS
GREAT WORK ON THIS I KNOW HE
HAS THE SAME. CONSTITUENTS IN
HIS DISTRICT BUT THEY'RE YOU
KNOW THESE ARE OUR MILITARY
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO NEED THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS GALLAGHER SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION
MISTER SOSSAMON CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'LL USE MY COLLEAGUES
STATEMENT AS A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. BURKE
LIBERAL. MEMBERS WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE REQUESTED-
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SAID
KNOWS THAT MEASURE PAY FILE I
FORTY FOUR IS AB ONE KERR. WAS
BILL ONE BY SOME MEMBER P. AND
OTHERS AN ACTUAL TO UNDER
INSURANCE IN THE CLEARING YOUR
TO QUICKLY LEE. SB MALE. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST YEAR WE ALL
WITH. ARKANSAS HAVE WATCHED
WITH SHOCK AND OUTRAGE THE
MYRIAD WAYS IN WHICH
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT HAS
FAILED CALIFORNIANS- THIS
DEPARTMENT HAS SQUANDERED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND COST
HARD TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. ONE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLE OF THIS
FAILURE HAS BEEN THE NEARLY
BILLION DOLLARS IT AND PAID OUT
IN FRAUDULENT CLAIMS TO YOU IN
THE NAME OF INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS. I AB ONE TEN IS A
SIMPLE COMMONSENSE STEPS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS KIND OF FRAUD
DOES NOT CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
IMPLEMENTED ELEMENT DEPARTMENT
TO CROSS CHECK CLAIMS AGAINST
CDCR INCARCERATION RECORDS. UP
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT BUT- THANK YOU MISS
PETERS. SEEING NOTICED OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CORPORAL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES PAST
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS FORTY FIVE
THROUGH FORTY SEVEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TWO
TWO ONE. ACCORDING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND OTHERS
INOCULATING THE FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
ZERO TAKE FOR ME MR SANTIAGO I
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
TWO ONE WOULD PROVIDE A SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS OF EMERGENCY
FOOD ASSISTANCE FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS REGARDS LEGAL
STATUS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. FAVOR SANTIAGO SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE I'M SORRY
MR GIPSON. MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT AS A JOINT PROUD
AUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL- TWO TO
ONE THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD MANY
OF YOU KNOW I REPRESENT THE SIX
POOREST DISTRICT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE SECOND
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
SINCE THIS PANDEMIC. PEOPLE ARE
HURTING AND THEY'RE HUNGRY
INDIVIDUALS IN NEED THE HELP
AND WHAT BETTER PLACE TO
RECEIVE THAT HOPE IS FROM ITS
GOVERNMENT. INDIVIDUALS MAY
HAVE YOU ON THE FLOOR HAVE
PROVIDED FREE LUNCH PROGRAMS
AND DELIVER BOXES TO NEEDY
FAMILIES. WELL MAKES NO
DIFFERENCE ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT. ARE YOU LIVE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITY OR NOT PEOPLE ARE
HURTING THIS IS THIS BILL
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ABSOLUTELY NEED IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IF YOU HERE WITH.
UNDOCUMENTED OR NOT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR NOT
PEOPLE ARE HURT WE CANNOT HAVE
TO CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GREAT WEALTH AND ALSO
GREAT DISPARITIES YOU CAN FEED
PEOPLE ONE TIME. BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT HUNGRY ONE TIME ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY ONE PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT AND NEED THAT
PEOPLE NEED WE CAN STAND UP OF
CALIFORNIA LEAD THE WAY. THIS
IS A ONE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I STRONGLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TO
ONE I THANK THE AUTHOR FROM LOS
THEIR DISAGREEING IS GOOD SENSE
MEASURE BEFORE TODAY. THANK
MISS GIPSON. SEE NOTE. I SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE MR
SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH MY COLLEAGUE DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB AND ALL USE HIS
STATEMENT OF MY CLOSING.
CORPORAL. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY HI SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM FORTY NINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY AB TWO
TWO SIX BY MISTER RAMOS
COOKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AN ACT RELATING TO CARE
FACILITIES MISTER ROSS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB TWO TWO SIX WOULD CLARIFY
LICENSING ISSUES AND ENSURE
MUCH NEEDED FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS. CURRENTLY AN
ESTIMATED THREE OUT OF EVERY
FOUR CHILDREN IN THE U. S. WHO
NEED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DO
NOT RECEIVE THEM. SUICIDE IS
NOW THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH AMONG ADOLESCENTS. IN
ADDITION FORTY SEVEN OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE NO
CHILD SITE YET PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL INPATIENT BEDS FOR
CHILDREN UNDER TWELVE YEARS OF
AGE. THE NEED FOR OUR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES COULD NOT
BE MORE URGENT. AB TWO TWO SIX
WOULD CLARIFY THAT PROGRAMS THE
PLAN TO PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES TO
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE. SHALL BE
DESIGNATED AS A PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE LICENSING
CATEGORY ESTABLISHED THE
STATEMENT COUNTIES WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE CONTINUE ON A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SERVICES
UNDER MEDICARE OUT EARLY AND
PERIODIC SCREENING DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE IN SUPPORTING THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR YOUTH HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS MR
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
REALLY DO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. FOR
AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE THIS HAS BEEN ONE
OF MY PRIME COMPLAINTS THAT WE
HAVE NOT HAD. AN ADEQUATE CHILD
PEDIATRIC CRISIS CRISIS- CENTER
IN MOST OF THE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ESPECIALLY IN MY
DISTRICT AND SOLANO. THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO PROVIDING OF THAT
SERVICE. ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS
NOW. THEIR CHILDREN ARE TAKEN
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
DETERMINE IF THEY'RE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY OR NOT. IF THEY ARE THERE
ON A HOLD FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS
AND IF THERE IS NO OTHER
SERVICES OF ALL AVAILABLE.
THERE TAKEN TO JUVENILE HALL
ARE PLACED IN A PRIVATE CARE
FACILITY LIKE MUCH LIKE A
FOSTER HOME. BUT THEY DO NOT
GET THE ADEQUATE. EARLY
INTERVENTION THAT THEY NEED
WILL PROFESSIONALLY UNTRAINED
INDIVIDUALS TO HELP THAT. CHILD
RIGHT ABSOLUTELY URGENT AYE
VOTE ON THIS AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM MYSTERONS EVEN CLOSE
IF YOU WISH THANK YOU I THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ACROSS THE
OVER THERE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE FLOOR HERE TODAY WHEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE- FOR FORTY SEVEN. OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES DO NOT
HAVE NO SERVICES FOR OUR USE
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BRINGING THIS
BILL UP AB TWO TWO SIX AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU RESTAURANTS. CARCLUB RURAL.
ESERVER ALL PERSONAL DESIRE TO
VOTE. YEAH. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE- CLARK WELL. THOSE
ARE ALL TIME BUT I TWO KNOWS.
THAT MEASURE PASS MEMBERS
WITHOUT A WE ARE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM SEVEN. SINCE FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB TWO Y. FIVE
BY CHIU PARK. ASSUME BILL TWO
BIAS MEMBER AND I RELATING TO.
MISTER CHIP. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWO FIFTY ONE OVER
FOR SO WERE PLAN. IS UNDER TO
THE RE AND HOUSING ELEMENT
PROCESS IN THE COMING YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE CITIES WHOSE HOUSING
PRODUCTION IS UNDER THE
REGIONAL AVERAGE WOULD HAVE A
MID CYCLE CONSULTATION WITH
EACH CITY. CITIES HIS
PRODUCTION HAS BEEN BELOW
SUBSTANTIALLY THE REGIONAL
AVERAGE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
ADOPT LOCAL POLICIES TO ACHIEVE
OUR STATES PER HOUSING
DESIGNATION THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BY WIDE COALITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADVOCATES AND HOUSING
PRODUCTION STAKEHOLDERS ALL
WORKING TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS AND WITH THAT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU. SAYING
NOTIFICATION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. DESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS SO DESIRABLE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I FIFTY
TWO KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS FIFTY ONE
THROUGH FIFTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR. AB TWO EIGHTY FOUR BY
MISTER RIVAS CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO READY FOR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
ANOTHER SNACK LATE IN THE
GREENHOUSE GASES MYSTERY OF US
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- THIS
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHT FOUR THE PROPOSES TO
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD TO SET AN OVERALL CLIMATE
GOAL FOR OUR STATE'S NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS. AS PART OF
NEXT YEAR'S SCOPING PLAN
PROCESS NOW EVEN IF CARBON
EMISSIONS STOPPED RIGHT THIS
MINUTE WE ALREADY HAVE MORE
CARBON IN OUR ATMOSPHERE THAN
SCIENTISTS SAY IS SAFE. AND AS
WE ALL KNOW WE'RE NOT GONNA
STOP EMITTING CARBON. RIGHT
THIS SECOND AND SO YOU KNOW THE
SEQUESTER ASIAN OF CARBON IN
SOILS AND FORESTS AND WETLANDS
AND OTHER NATURAL WORKING
LANDSCAPES IS CURRENTLY ONLY
PROVEN WAY TO REMOVE CARBON.
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE AT A LARGE
SCALE I AM SO IN FACT IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT SEQUESTRATION
ALONE COULD BRING US IN TO
COULD COULD BRING US NEARLY 20%
OF THE WAY TO MEETING OUR
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS. AND TO
BE CLEAR A. ARBY'S SCOPING PLAN
IS NON BINDING. IS NON
REGULATORY IN NATURE IT IS%
SIMPLY A PLANNING EXERCISE
DESIGNED TO SET GOALS AND
PROVIDE POLICY OPTIONS. THANK
YOU RESPECT THAT'S WHAT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS MR
FRAZIER YOUR YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING THIS
FOR WEEKS I HAD A SIMILAR BILL.
TO CREATE A SCOPING PLAN THAT
INCLUDED. INSTEAD OF MAD MAIN
IMAGE MAN MADE ADMISSIONS.
SENATE ACTUALLY INCLUDE ALL OF
THE WILDFIRES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN THE SCOPING PLAN
TO DETERMINE. THE NECESSITY FOR
A HOLISTIC APPROACH TOWARDS
THIS REDUCTION OF GHG AND IN
CARBON APPRECIATE. THIS IS
ANOTHER FACET THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. BUT UNTIL WE ADDRESS
EVERY ASPECT OF IT IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE SCOPING PLAN THAT
WILL BE IN PLACE I REQUEST
RIVAL. ENGLISH FRAZIER SAYING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISS REAVIS YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH MISTER
SPEAKER JUST RESPECT LASSEN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. CRACKLE OF THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU
ABOUT IS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP HIS
POWER K. HANDS ITEMS. BEGINNING
WITH FILE ITEM CHIU FORTY SEVEN
THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWO FORTY
SEVEN A. B. TWELVE FORTY TWO
AND A COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BARRICADE HAND AND
OTHERS AN ALKYLATING ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES THIS PARA QUE THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ON A. B.
TWELVE FORTY TWO A BILL THAT
ALLOWS LICENSE RESTAURANTS TO
CONTINUE SELLING MIXED
ALCOHOLIC DRINKS TO GO THE
COMBINED EFFECTS OF NECESSARY
LOCKDOWNS IN THE DOWNTURN DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC HAD DEVASTATED
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL TO
SUPPORT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
ARE STRICTLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS BACKING. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLUB THE. DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT A
VOTE. CLERK WILL. THOSE ARE ALL
TIDE ABOUT ICE EVERYONE KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
NEXT MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A FALL OUT OF ONE THIRTY
FOUR. AB FIFTEEN TWELVE FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN AN
ACCOLADE IN THE PARKS PARKS AND
RECREATION MISS BARAKAT THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENTED AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE A DISTRICT BILL THAT
WILL PRESERVE A CRITICAL PIECE
OF LAND KNOWN AS THE ALAMEDA
TUSSLE EXPANSION AREA OR TEST
THE PARK. THIS IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF LAND WITH A VERY
ECOLOGICAL VALUE CONTAINS
HIGHLY SENSITIVE NATIVE
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND IS A
CRITICAL HABITAT CORRIDOR. IT
ALSO HOLDS IMPORTANT CULTURE
RESOURCES LIKE THE HISTORIC
CATHOLIC TOWN AND MINE COMPLEX
AND SITES IMPORTANT TO NATIVE
CALIFORNIANS. THE COMMUNITY HAS
LONG FOUGHT FOR THIS PIECE OF
LAND AND RECENTLY A SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
RULE THAT THE ERROR WAS INVALID
AS IT IMPROPERLY CONSTRAIN THE
PROJECT'S OBJECTIVES. THE COURT
THAT THE LAND WOULD BE BEST
CAPTAIN PRESERVATION FOR
PERPETUITY. THIS BILL SIMPLY
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT PARTS TO
PRESERVE THE LAND THEY
CURRENTLY OWN IN PERPETUITY
ONCE NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING IS RECEIVED. INTO THE
GENERAL FUND OR INTO THE
OFFERED VEHICLE BUT BY DOING SO
WE WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE GOALS
OF AN EXECUTIVE ORDER SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR. TO RESERVE 30% OF
LAND IN COASTAL WATERS BY
TWENTY THIRTY RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE SUPPORT THIS LAND
PRESERVATION EFFORTS. THANK YOU
IS BACKING HIM. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- THANK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE CHINA AS FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS EIGHTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM. FIFTY FIVE. FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE IS AB TWO NINE TWO
BY MR STONE. AND A CORPORATION
SOME PEOPLE TO NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE ACCOLADE
IN THE CORRECTIONS. MR STONE
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBER FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED ACCESS TO
PROGRAMMING IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE REDUCING RECIDIVISM
AND MAKE THEM PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY WHEN
THEY COME OUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS. AND FORTUNATELY
CURRENTLY THE WAY A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMMING WORKS IS WHAT IT IS
THERE A LOT OF INTERFERENCES
WITHIN THE PRISONS AND WHEN
PEOPLE GET. TRANSFERRED FROM
PRISON TO PRISON THAT
PROGRAMMING CAN GET INTERRUPTED
WHAT AB TWO NINETY TWO IS
DESIGNED TO DO IS ENSURE
CONTINUITY ACROSS THE
PROGRAMMING INSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING. SO THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE INSIDE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY NEED
FOR PROGRAMMING FOR
REHABILITATION AND REDUCTION OF
RECIDIVISM I ASK FOR YOUR ITEMS.
THANK IMAGE DOWN. SEEING YES MR
ONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO NINE TWO
THIS BILL WILL RELEASE EVEN
MORE VIOLENT VAL FELONS INTO
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD AND
COMMUNITIES AND MAKING. MAKE
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND SAFE
THAN IT IS CURRENTLY PROP FIFTY
SEVEN FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
INCREASE GOOD CONDUCT CREDITS
FOR INMATES 220% AB TWO NINE TO
WIN CREWS THAT EVEN FURTHER
250% MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT PROP
FIFTY SEVEN. THESE ARE VIOLENT
FELONS CONVICTED OF RAPE.
MURDER ROBBERY AND KIDNAPPING
AND AMONG OTHERS MANY MORE OUR
GOVERNOR HAS READY MADE THE EXT
EXECUTIVE DECISION. RECENTLY TO
RELEASE SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
INMATES INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THIS BILL WILL FOR THAT.
CAMPAIGN I REPRESENT ONE OF MY
CITY IS A CITY OF GARDEN GROVE.
IT HAS SEEN VIOLENT CRIME RISE
BY ALMOST 50% IN PROPERTY CRIME
IS UP 35% AND THAT'S JUST IN
ONE CITY. WE HAVE SEEN PRUDENT
CRIME RISE ALL ACROSS OUR STATE.
OUR FAMILY SCHOOLS AND
BUSINESSES NEED TO FEEL SAFE WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO SUBJECT THEM
TO CRIME WE HAVE NO ANSWERS TO
STOPPING. THEM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I'M ASKING US TO
STOP RELEASING VIOLENT
CRIMINALS LET'S WORK TOGETHER
TO MAKE OUR STATE SAFER TO
PROTECT OUR FAMILY AND
CHILDREN. SO I STRONGLY URGE IN
NOVO ON A. B. TWO NINE TWO.
THANK YOU. SAY NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON THE
ITEM. MR STONE YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LET ME
CORRECT THE RECORD FOR VIOLENT.
OFFENDERS THIS DOES NOT PROVIDE
EARLY RELEASE WHAT IT PROVIDES
IS POTENTIALLY AN EARLY
OPPORTUNITY AND THAT'S THE
INCENTIVE TO GET BEFORE A
PAROLE HEARING. BUT NOT AND-
UNDERSCORE NOT AN EARLY RELEASE
SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
BUT THEY'RE INCORRECT I ASK FOR
YOUR I. THE- WITH THAT CAR CLUB
IN THE ROLE. ESERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF.
FISHED ALMOST CALL.
THIS IS FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX AB THREE SIXTEEN.
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER IMMACULATE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. MISTER COOPER EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THREE SIXTEEN WILL
HELP CLOSE THE GENDER AND
ETHNICITY PAY GAP AND UNDER
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES IN STATE CIVIL
SERVICE CLASSIFICATIONS AB
STATE AGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO
PASS A DETAILED REPORT ON
GENDER AND ETHNIC WAGE
DISPARITY AND THE UNDER
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES. THEY PLAN TO
ACHIEVE PAY EQUITY THIS BILL
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES IN
OPPOSITION ARE STRICTLY ASPEN I
VOTE. THANKS COOPER C.
NOTIFICATION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WELL. CLOTHES
ARE ALL TIED OUT I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE FORTY NINE BY MR
HOLDING CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN ACCOLADE
IN SMALL BUSINESSES MR HOLDING
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT A. B. THREE FORTY NINE
TODAY EVERYTHING FORTY NINE
REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS TO EXPAND OUT REACH
TO SMALL BUSINESSES
PARTICULARLY THOSE OWNED BY
PEOPLE THAT IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ
RACIAL MINORITIES. OR WOMEN.
AND CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
ACCOUNT FOR THREE POINT NINE
MILLION OR NINETY NINE POINT 8%
OF ALL CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.
OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES ONE
POINT SIX MILLION ARE MINORITY
OWNED. SMALL BUSINESSES NOT
ONLY CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY
TO THE ECONOMY BUT ALSO ACCOUNT
FOR SEVEN MILLION EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE. GIVEN THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON SMALL BUSINESSES
THE STATE NEEDS TO BE PROACTIVE
IN REVITALIZING COMMUNITIES AND
SUPPORTING SMALL BUSINESSES NOW
MORE THAN EVER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANKS
HOLDEN SAYING. NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE KRIKALEV THE ROLE. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
SIXTY PASS RETAIN. WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE THIS IS
MISTER SALAS. AB FOUR OH FOR
HER CAREER. SOME PEOPLE FOUR
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALICIN
ACTIVATING THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION. MISTER CELIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OH FOUR
WHICH WILL HELP ENSURE TIMELY
ACCESS TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS FOR INJURED WORKERS.
FOR TRACKING A RETAINING AN
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF QUALIFIED
MEDICAL EVALUATORS RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I FOCUS SPEAKER. THANK
YOU ES CELLS SENIOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK
LIBERAL. IS OUT VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TYLER I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS AND RETAIN
OF OUT OF SIXTY TWO. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE BEFORE
SIXTY ONE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BE APPROVED BY AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
COLLEGE THIS SHOULD BE APPROVED
BY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS FOR SIXTY ONE. WILL
RECALCULATE HOW CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS RECEIVE CREDIT FOR
THEIR SELF EMPLOYMENT TO
SATISFY REQUIRED WORK ACTIVITY
TODAY CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS TO CHOOSE FROM
TO SATISFY REQUIRED WORK
ACTIVITY WHICH INCLUDES SELF
EMPLOYMENT. HOWEVER IF THE
RECIPIENT WANTS TO UTILIZE THIS
OPTION THEY MUST SHOW THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO YIELD AT
LEAST A MINIMUM WAGE FOR THE
HOURS THAT THEY HAVE. SPENT
WORKING. THIS REQUIREMENT IS A
BURDEN AND LIMITS CAL WORST
RECIPIENTS FROM TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL AND ACHIEVE THEIR
DREAMS OF BECOMING THE
ENTREPRENEUR. AND A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. AT THE STATE IT
BEGINS RECOVER FROM PEDANTIC
WHICH WE DO EVERY DAY WITHIN
THE OUR POWER TO FOSTER
ENTREPRENEUR SPIRITS. THAT WE
SAW COME OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FROM PROVISIONS RECESSION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTIVELY OSCAR AND IVA.
THANK YOU MAY BE ABLE TO US
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE BILL THE CLUB THERE ARE.
MEMBERS RESERVA ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. TO DECIDE ABOUT. CLARK
WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED TO
VOTE. I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
AT FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
THREE SIXTY SIX THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB FIVE ELEVEN
CORKERY. SOME PEOPLE FIVE
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AND
ACCOLADES CARRIES MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU I'M
PRESENTING AB FIVE ONE ONE THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
EQUITY CROWDFUNDING ACT WE KNOW
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES OFTEN
LACK ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND RELY
HEAVILY ON FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
CREDIT CARD DEBT HOME EQUITY
ANOTHER LIMITED PERSONAL ASSETS
FOR FINANCING THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW STATES START UP SMALL
BUSINESSES TO FIND INVESTORS IT
CAN PROVIDE CAPITAL TO HELP
THEM GROW AND CREATE JOBS WHAT
THE SAME TIME. PROVIDE GREATER
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THE
CALIFORNIA BUSTERS
PARTICIPATING IN EQUITY
CROWDFUNDING THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED SPONSORED BY THE
SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTED BY THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES BUT NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WELL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE OUR
CLUB NARAL. THE SENATE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF OUT.
CLERK WILL THOSE ARE ALL TIED
UP I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. IS FILE
ITEM. SIXTY NINE. THAT. FILE
ITEM SIX NINETY FIVE FOR A
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL AND OTHERS AN OUTLET
IN THE SCHOOL FACILITIES MISTER
O'DONNELL MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE FOUR FOUR
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO REPORT INFORMATION
ABOUT EACH SCHOOL FACILITY
OWNED OR LEASED BY THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THIS INFORMATION WILL
ENSURE THE CD THAT CITY WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE BASIC FACILITY
INFORMATION TO EITHER LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
ASSIST WITH EMERGENCY
RESPONSES. THE PRIMARY NEED FOR
THIS INFORMATION IS TO ENSURE
STUDENT SAFETY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER AGENCIES
LOOK TO SCHOOL LEADERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT EACH STUDENT
AND SCHOOL PERSONNEL LOCATION
DURING AN EVACUATION DUE TO AN
EMERGENCY SUCH AS A AS SUCH AS
A WILDFIRE OR OTHER NATURAL OR
UNNATURAL EVENT. I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
O'DONNELL SAYING. NO DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM. COCOA OF THE ROLE.
IS THAT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB
FIVE FORTY FIVE BY DR KHOR
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTIVATING THE
TAXATION DR COURT EMAIL THANK
YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS SOME OF
THE MAJOR TAX EXPENDITURES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE REDIRECTED
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FUNDING. FROM EDUCATION
OTHER VITAL SERVICES FOR YEARS
WITHOUT ANY REVIEW TO CONFIRM
THEIR ACTUALLY ACHIEVING THEIR
GOALS. ADDITIONALLY A TWENTY
SIXTEEN STATE AUDIT FOUND THAT
THE LACK OF OVERSIGHT AND
EVALUATION HAS MADE IT
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE IF SOME
TAX CREDITS OR EXEMPTIONS WERE
FOR FAILING THEIR PURPOSE. TO
ADDRESS THIS LACK OF OVERSIGHT
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE INITIATE TWO
ONE TIME COMPREHENSIVE PEER
REVIEW ASSESSMENT. BY A
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH CENTER TO EVALUATE THE
MOST COSTLY TAX EXPENDITURE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE ACCUMULATED.
IN MORE THAN IN MORE. THE RICH.
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE
AFFORDABLE AND REVENUE OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS. AB FIVE FORTY
FIVE ALASKA YOU SEE RICHARD'S
RESEARCH CENTER TO ANALYZE THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
THE MAJOR TAX EXPENDITURES HAVE
IN THE STATE. AND VERIFY ANY
DEFINITE BENEFITS THE STATE
GETS FROM THESE PROGRAMS. THEY
WILL ALSO BE TERMINATED OPTIONS
FOR IMPROVING THE PROGRAM TO
REDUCE THEIR IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL FUND. AB FIVE FORTY
FIVE PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT TOOL
FOR INFORMING OUR FUTURE POLICY
DECISIONS AND INSURES THE BEST
USE OF LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS.
I ASK THE ARRIVAL OF. DATACORE
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CARCLUB RURAL. DESERT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF. IS OUT OF
OUT. CLARK WELL. CLOTHES ARE
ALL TIED OUT EYES FORTY FIVE
KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PAST RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO. AB FIVE FIVE SEVEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO HATE CRIMES MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND I ARE PRESENTING AB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN A BILL TO ESTABLISH
A STATEWIDE TOLL FREE HATE
CRIMES HOTLINE AS WELL AS AN
ONLINE REPORTING PORTAL. AS WE
ALL KNOW WE'VE SEEN A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE PANDEMIC
OF STARTED. THIS IS BEEN
PARTICULARLY TRUE IN THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM MONTEREY PARK
INDICATED EARLIER OVER SIX
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED INCIDENTS
HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED SINCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT ISOLATED
TO THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT RECENT
INCREASE AND JEWISH HATE
CRIMES. WE HAVE SEEN PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC WE SAW DRAMATIC
INCREASES IN HATE CRIMES
AGAINST LATINOS AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND OF
COURSE OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN A HIGH LEVEL OF HATE
CRIMES AGAINST THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. WHAT MAKES THIS
WORSE IS THAT WE HAVE A CHRONIC
PROBLEM OF UNDER REPORTING OF
HATE CRIMES. THIS BILL PROVIDES
A SOLUTION TO MAKE IT AS EASY
AND SAFE AS POSSIBLE TO REPORT
HATE CRIMES AS WELL AS HATE
INCIDENTS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE.
DATA DRIVEN PUBLIC SFETY
RESPONSES THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND IS
SUPPORTED BY QUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND IS AN AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS. IS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WITH NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MISTER GILL WHO ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEGE FOUR YEARS AGO I
INTRODUCED THIS VERY BILL.
DURING THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
LAST PRESIDENTIAL MINISTRATION
WHEN WE HAD STARTED TO SEE A
SPIKE. IN HATE INCIDENTS NOT
NECESSARILY DIRECTED AT OUR
COMMUNITY BUT IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. IN OUR JEWISH AND
MUSLIM COMMUNITIES IN OUR LOT
NEXT COMMUNITY. I WANT TO THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE FOR
SUGGESTING THAT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THIS YEAR WE SHOULD MOVE IT
FORWARD AGAIN- AND I VERY MUCH
HOPE YOU CAN SUPPORT IT. AT
LEAST GIVEN THE BASIS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WHEN IT COMES TO THE
UNPRECEDENTED SPIKE OF ANTI
ASIAN HATE. WHAT WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO SET UP A MECHANISM TO
TRACK HE CRIMES AGAINST ANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THE FACT
THAT WE KNOW IS A HE COMMITTED
AGAINST ANYONE IS A HATE CRIME
THAT'S COMMITTED AGAINST ALL OF
US AND WITH THAT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MESSAGE TO. MR GABRIEL HE ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I- TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE WANT
TO COMPLIMENT A COLLEAGUE FROM
POINTS FOR BEING AFFORD IN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
FOR HIS ROLE IN BRINGING THIS
FOR TO THIS BODY. JUST WANT TO
SHOW I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS BODY CONGRESSMAN TED LIEU.
A FEW DAYS AGO WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE SPIKE IN HATE CRIMES.
AGAINST OUR API COMMUNITY
AGAINST THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND SO MANY OTHERS. I ASKED HIM
WHAT WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT WE COULD DO HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AMONG
pWAS TO PASS THIS BILL. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE. THEY HAVE RECENTLY
PASSED THE LEGISLATION IN
WASHINGTON DC. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN HEAR DO
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO PROTECT ALL OF
OUR ONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB FIVE FIVE SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL. MISS
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD BUT IT'S GREAT IF
THE HOTLINE WE CALL IN NOTE WE
KNOW ALREADY FOR THE ONLY
MEMBERS CRIMES AGAINST LGBTQ
COMMUNITY UP TO MEDICALLY. OUR
JEWISH COMMUNITY UP
DRAMATICALLY. OUR MUSLIM
COMMUNITY UP DRAMATICALLY ALL
ACROSS THE BOARD HATE CRIMES
ARE UP WE KNOW THAT- BACK IN
THE CITY PASSED A LAW A BILL.
FOR A HOTLINE HOTLINES ARE
GREAT HALL AND DO NOTHING ABOUT
IT IN THE FRUSTRATING PART IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU CAN BE THE
FATHER HEY CAN YOU BRING A
PLACE TO WORSHIP DOWN A MOSQUE
OR SYNAGOGUE. IT'S NOT A THIRD
OF WHAT A CRIME. YOU BEAT
SOMEBODY UP AND CALLS GREAT
BODILY INJURY TO THEM. BECAUSE
OF THEIR RACE IT'S NOT ABOUT
HATE CRIMES TO GET WHAT GUESS
WHAT. YOU GET AN EARLY RELEASE.
THAT'S BE S. AND THAT'S MOST
FRUSTRATING PART ABOUT THIS.
THAT AND THIS HOUSE WE CAN'T
CHANGE THAT LAW. WE'RE TALKING
VIOLENT FELONY HATE CRIMES. A
LIKE I SAID. REPORTING IS GREAT
RENTALS BUT WE KNOW ALREADY.
THERE UP DRAMATICALLY. BUT WHAT
WE CAN DO ABOUT HOW WE GONNA
SOLVE IT. TO MAKE FOLKS NOT DO
THIS. YOU GOT TO PUNISH PEOPLE.
SO IF THAT PERSON WANTS TO BURN
DOWN A CHURCH OR A MOSQUE. OR
SYNAGOGUE YOU SHOULD DO YOUR
TIME. I WANT TO BE SOMEBODY UP
BECAUSE YOU'RE ASIAN. BECAUSE
THEY'RE TRANSGENDER WAS THE I
THINK A 142% THEN DO THAT.
WHAT'S IRONIC IS. SOME OF THE
FOLKS IN HERE THAT PURPORT TO
DEFEND THESE PEOPLE. OR SIGN ON
IT. AND THAT'S THAT SOME OF
THIS BILL FIGURING AFFORD. I
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEE
RECOGNITION ON THE BILL. THIS
MURATSUCHI YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. LAST FOUR OF A LOCAL OF
THE ROLE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLITORAL
TIE THAT I SUCCEED NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
RETAIN ABOUT SEVENTY THREE
THROUGH SEVENTY FIVE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX FORTY. CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. COLLEAGUES ARE VERY
PLEASED TO BRING BEFORE YOU AB
SIX FORTY THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT WILL ALLOW OUR CALIFORNIA
AND OUR ORDER FOR US TO DRAW
DOWN MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR
pFEDERAL FOSTERING CONNECTIONS
TO SUCCESS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT GAVE THE STATES THE
OPTION OF EXTENDING FOSTER CARE
TO AGE TWENTY ONE. CALIFORNIA
IMPLEMENTED THIS FOR THE BILL
AB TWELVE IN TWENTY TEN- BUT WE
DID NOT PROVIDE THE AUTHORITY
FOR RECALCULATING BENEFITS AND
NOT OVER TRIAL. THIS METHOD
ACTUALLY A CHILD WHO'S HAD
THEIR RIGHT TO BENEFITS
CAMPAIGN IS YOUNGER PERSON WITH
A FAMILY. HAS TO CAP THE FAMILY
ASSETS TO DETERMINE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR FEDERAL
BENEFITS. OF THAT NUMBER
SHRINKS WHEN THEY GO EXTENDED
AND ARE INDEPENDENT BUT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN UPDATED THE
CALCULATION THIS IS IMPAIR
THEIR ABILITY ACCESS HE'S
FEDERAL BENEFITS. THIS MEASURE
WILL ALLOW FOR THE
RECALCULATION. IT PROVIDES MORE
SUPPORT FOR OUR YOUTH AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND
ACTUALLY BY VIRTUE THIS
CALCULATION. DRAWING DOWN
FEDERAL DOLLARS IT FREES UP
OTHER DOLLARS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL THAT MIGHT GO TO HELP
THESE YOU. SO IT LETS US GET
MORE BANG FOR OUR BUCK QUITE
LITERALLY I REQUEST AND I WILL.
THANKS COOLEY. SHE NOTICED CASH
OR DEBATE COURT THEY'RE ALL.
RESERVE A ON THE VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
PRESERVER. CLARK. BECAUSE TELL
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THROUGH SEVENTY NINE.
HAS RETAIN. CORRECTION WE ARE
GOING TO CHECK A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN IS A V. SIX FIFTY
SEVEN CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AND
ACTIVATING THE STATE EMPLOYMENT
MISTER COOPER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE STATE CIVIL SERVICE
ACT ESTABLISHES STANDARDS FOR
THE USE OF PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS BY STATE AGENCIES WAS
PRESCRIBED CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THE USE OF PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS SHOULD BE USED
SPARINGLY WHEN THEY'RE FUNDED
FULL TIME POSITIONS NOT BEING
FILLED THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
FOR THOSE VACANCIES ARE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS SUCH AS
PHYSICIANS SURGEONS
PSYCHOLOGIST AND DENTIST. SB
SIX FIVE SEVEN PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS AND TRANSPARENCY
THE STATE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND PROFESSIONALS THE FINEST
PHYSICIANS SURGEONS AND
PSYCHOLOGIST. A. B. C. FIVE
SEVEN PROHIBIT A STATE AGENCY
FROM ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT
WITH A HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL
WHO IS NOT A PERMANENT EMPLOYEE
FOR A PERIOD OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE CONSECUTIVE
DAYS OR FOR A PERIOD OF THREE
TO SIXTY FIVE. NONCONSECUTIVE
DAYS IN THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH
PERIOD RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK SAYING
NOTICE. ON THE ADAM. THE CLUB.
IT IS ADAMANT VOTERS AND ABOUT.
ALL OF. IT IS. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE I FORTY FIVE NORTH ELEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY. THIS IS ABC ONE
SEVEN BY MR STONE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME BILL SEVENTY
BIASA MEMBER STE AND I IN THE-
THIS STOP THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS IS A- NEXT STEP IN THE
CAN DEEP THE- WE'VE INTO LAW
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO BUT ON.
ONLY 30% CURRENTLY OF PEOPLE
RELIEVING INCARCERATION END UP
WITH A CALIFORNIA ID OR A
DRIVER'S LICENSE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CDC ARE AND OTHERS
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN INCREASE
THOSE NUMBERS WE KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
INCARCERATION GET SERVICES. AND
AVANADE RECIDIVISM IF THEY HAVE
A VALID ID THAT THEY CAN THEN
GO USE FOR JOB SEARCHES GETTING
INTO SCHOOLS AND DOING THE
KINDS OF THINGS WE NEED FOR
THEM TO INTEGRATE INTO. THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO THIS WOULD
FACILITATE GETTING PEOPLE A
CALIFORNIA ID IF THEY MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS. TO GET A
REPLACEMENT DRIVERS LICENSE OR
GET A RENEWAL AGAIN IF THEY
QUALIFY IT AND IF THEY DON'T
NEED TO TAKE A DRIVING TEST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THIS REPORT ONE. THANK
YOU I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVEN FOUR SEVEN ONE SEVEN.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN I
WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR I.
HEARD THE SHERIFF SICK AS SANTA
CRUZ SPEAK ABOUT WHAT HE WAS
DOING AT HIS. IN HIS JAIL AND
YOU REALIZE THAT. A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT WERE INCARCERATED
WHEN THEY GET RELEASE- DON'T
HAVE AN ID DHARMA DRIVER'S
LICENSE THOUGH SO IT'S ALWAYS
AN ISSUE. ABOUT WHEN THEY GET
RELEASED HAVE WHY HAVEN'T. YOU
GOT A JOB WHY DID YOU CREATE
COMMITTED A CRIME- A LOT OF
FOLKS WILL YOU KNOW IT JUST I
DON'T NO IDEA COULDN'T UP. I
GOT DENIED. HE IS A BILL THAT.
WILL HELP. SIR AND WHEN GET OUT.
IT COVERS THAT BEAR ANOTHER. SO
I COMMEND THE AUTHOR- FOR THIS
AND I YOU GUYS SUPPORT THIS.
ALL RIGHT BEYOND NIGHT BUT.
NAME IS FOR PUT TO A- MS. CLARK
SO. YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE SOME
OF AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN MEMBERS I
HAD FOUR YEARS AGO I RAN A BILL
THAT WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
TO OFFER A FEE WAIVER IN AN ID
TO THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS NOW THIS IS
DIFFERENT BUT IT'S ALSO SIMILAR
IN THE SENSE THAT WE KNOW
PEOPLE CANNOT PUT THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER WITHOUT A BASIC
ID THEY CANNOT APPLY FOR A JOB
THEY CANNOT APPLY FOR
ASSISTANCE. AND THEY CANNOT
TAKE THE VERY FIRST STEP TO
GETTING BACK INTO OUR SOCIETY
AND BECOME RESPONSIBLE WORKING
INDIVIDUALS SO I SUPPORT THIS
AND I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT A. B.
SEVEN ONE SEVEN. THANK YOU OF
COURSE- MR GRAYSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR ON A. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
HIS STEADFAST LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. MEMBERS IF WE TRULY
ARE COMMITTED TO REDUCING
RECIDIVISM THEN THERE SHOULD BE
AN EASY AYE VOTE TODAY PEOPLE
BEING RELEASED FROM PRISON NEED
ACCESS TO HOUSING EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES TO SUCCESSFULLY
RE ENTER SOCIETY BUT THEY NEED
THEIR VITAL RECORDS TO GAIN
ACCESS TO ANY OF THESE
SERVICES. AND WE SHOULD NOT
ALLOW IMPEDIMENTS OF NOT HAVING
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS AN ID
STOP PEOPLE FROM RE INTEGRATING
INTO OUR SOCIETY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I. THANK MISS GRAYSON.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM MISTER STONE YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE. RESERVE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP
I FIFTY THREE KNOWS OF. THAT
MAY PASSES. PASS RETAIN ABOUT
ITEM EIGHTY. THIS IS FILE
EIGHTY TWO AB SEVEN SIX TWO
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY RULE SO SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY AND OTHERS AND
IN THIS SITES MISTER LIAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT AB SEVEN TWO
NO MA'AM I HAVE NO CHILL. BUT
IF I WERE DROP THEM OFF AT
SCHOOL THE FUTURE I WOULDN'T
WANT TO WORRY THEY WERE BE
EXPOSED TO HARM TALKS ARE.
EIGHTY SEVEN SIX TWO DOES
EXACTLY THAT NO MATTER WHAT
SCHOOL YOUR CHILD GOES TO A
PRIVATE CHARTER OR PUBLIC
SCHOOL THEY SHOULD NOT BE
EXPOSED TO IT THIS SIMPLY SAYS
THAT FUTURE CITING FUTURE
CREATION CONSTRUCTION OF. OF
SCHOOLS SHOULD NOT BE PUT ON A
HAZARDOUS HAZARDOUS SITES AND
THIS IS THE SAME KIND OF
REQUIREMENT WE WANT TO HAVE FOR
ALL OUR CHILDREN BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
EDUCATORS OF OUR OF OUR
STUDENTS AND CERTAINLY OF OUR
SCHOOLS OF WHEN THEY GO TO
SCHOOL AND DROP THEM OFF I
THANK THE AGASSI OF PARENTS IN
MY DISTRICT. BECAUSE THERE WAS
A PRIVATE SCHOOL DOES BILL
NEXUS CEMENT FACTORY WHERE.
CONSTANTLY EARNS OR WORRY ABOUT
THE SAY OF THEIR CHILDREN YOU
WHEN THEY GOT PLAY AND PLAY. SO
HOW. REQUEST YOUR- ON THIS.
THANK YOU. SAYING YES MS GARCIA
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR THANK
YOU MEMBERS ARE OF TO ON ON
THIS BILL AVERAGE LEAD SISTER
IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE DAY
CITIES BELGARD A LIVING AND IN
THE- AND ALL WE CAN HAVE LEFT
TO BE STUFF IS BROWN. AND I
HAVE A OF TEARS THAT HAVE COME
IN HARD TO BE ON THE BROWNFIELD
AND I CLEAN UP THE LEVEL
ANALYTICS TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS
SAFE TO YOU BY SAID SAFE
HIMSELF THIS AMERICAN SENSE I
WAS THE ASK FOR ABLE. THANK
GARCIA. I SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION QUICKLY RURAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF
THE- DESERVE. KWEKWE. CLOSER
ROLE TYLER WHAT I'S FIFTY KNOWS
THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN
A BALANCE EIGHTY THREE AND
EIGHTY FOUR THIS IS FILE I'M
EIGHTY FIVE AB EIGHT NINETY SIX
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND OTHERS ARE TO OIL
AND GAS WELLS. MISTER BENNETT
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX IT PROVIDES CAL JAM-
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE A
LAYING. ON WELL OPERATORS TO
RECOVER STATE COST. CALIFORNIA
HAS ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE OPERATORS THAT
HAVE FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR IDLE WELLS THAT
HAVE NOT PAID THEIR IDOL WELL
FEES. THEY'RE NOT IN A WELL
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND THEY
POTENTIAL LIABILITY A SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS- TO
THE STATE. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SEEKS TO PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
ANOTHER FORTUNATE MECHANISM
AGAINST BAD ACTORS THAT CAN
PREVENT ORPHANED WELLS OR AND
GIVES THE STATE AWAY TO
RECUPERATE COSTA FOR WELL DOES
BECOME MOREFROM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IT.
ALL MY THIRTY TODAY BETTER.
CLERK WILL THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE HI FIFTY KNOWS TEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WHATEVER.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THERE
IS A LIST OF ELEVEN BILLS ON
THIRD READING TODAY THAT A HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF BOTH CAUCUSES
AND WE'VE AGREED TO TAKE THEM
UP IN ONE BATCH AND THEN APPLY
THE FIRST ROLL CALL VOTE TO
THESE BILLS I WOULD ASK THE
CLERK TO READ THE BILLS ON THIS
BATCH LIST AND THEN OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE FIRST BILL. MEMBERS
PLEASE PAY CLOSE ATTENTION AS
THE CLERK READ THE LIST OF
BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
HE PASSED AS A BACK. AGAIN
THESE HAVE BILLS HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF BOTH CAUCUSES. AND
YOU WILL NOT NEED TO PRESENT ON
THESE ITEMS THE CLERK WILL READ.
I AM WANTING TO ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN THIRTEEN MEDINA ITEM ONE
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
RIGHT THREE. I ONE OF THIS BILL
LIVE THIRTY TWO. I DON'T WANT
TO SAY IS A BILL EVANS SIX
HOLDEN ITEM TWELVE. BILL OH
EIGHT. ITEM FIFTY ASSEMBLY BILL
TOOL FOR SIXTY. ITEM ONE
NINETEEN S. BILL TWO FIFTY SO
PATTERSON. HI ONE TWENTY TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIX
AROUND. ITEM ONE TWENTY SO
ASSEMBLY THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
LOSE WE- I DON'T THIRTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL. OR ONE OF THE-
AND I DON'T WANT. SOME BILL.
FIFTY SIXTY. WITHOUT THE CLERK
WILL NARROW THE FIRST BILL AND
WE WILL OPEN ROLE. ASSEMBLY
DELIVERED BY SOME MEDINA OTHER
AND I REALLY THE PUBLIC
SECONDARY EDUCATION. THE CLERK
WILL- OPEN THE ROLE THIS. ALL
VOTE VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AYE OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
AYE VOTED. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALENTED I NINE KNOWS.
MEASURE PASSES THE CLERK WILL
NOW RE THE REMAINING. SOME OF
ELEVEN TO THREE WITH URGENCY. I.
FIFTY NINE OH ZERO. I'M HERE TO
SEE SIXTY A NINE NEWS ON THE
MEASURE. ASSEMBLY RELIVE THIRTY
TWO I FIFTY NINE IS THERE ARE
SOME ROLE OF. FIFTY SIX SIXTY
NINE ZERO BUILD. I SIXTY NINE
ZERO BILL THIRTY. SIXTEEN AS A
SUM. TWELVE SEVEN SIXTY NINE A
SYMBOL FOR TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN
AS A SUM GO. FOR THE EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE TWENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY IN THE PUBLIC ALSO
CREATE POST EDUCATION THIRTY NO
YOU ARE UPON THE MATTER. MANY
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM TO IN.
AB NOW TWENTY. A PRACTICAL
SOLUTION TO ELIMINATING THE
SKILLS GAP AND THEN ENABLING
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS TO
COMPETE. IN CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT AND FUTURE ECONOMY. AB
NINE TWENTY SEVEN WILL EXTEND
THE OPERATION OF THE STATE WIDE
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PILOT
PROGRAM INDEFINITELY. THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE OF
UNMET WORKFORCE NEEDS NOT
DUPLICATING THOSE OF CSU AND
UC. THIS WILL ALLOW UP TO
THIRTY PROGRAMS A YEAR. FOR
STUDENTS TO COMPETE IN TODAY'S
ECONOMY IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
SEIZE ON THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AND EXPAND THE
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAM.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR MEDINA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO THE- ALL MY VOTED THIRD OF A.
BURKE WILL CLOSER IN TWO THE I
THINK SIX ZERO THAT MEASURE
WITH PASS RETAIN A FILING
EIGHTY NINE AND NINETY FILE
NINE ONE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY LUIS ALSO
OTHERS TO ACCOLADES. THIS IF
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- INTO
THE THIRTEEN. S. B. DOSE ALL.
THE DMV. TO CREATE A PIE
PROGRAM FOR RICH. ALTERNATE AND
WE'RE TO THE LAW. ON THE
RESULTS THE PILOT PROGRAM. THE
PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWED SPECIALTY
PLATE OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION ELECTRONICALLY.
THROUGH DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES
PROVIDERS AND ALLOWED
INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS THE
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE LICENSE PLATE. AB
ESTABLISHED BY THE LICENSE
PLATES PROVIDER. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM FOUND THAT THESE
ALTERNATIVE REGISTRATION-
METHODS IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AT
THE DMV. BY ALLOWING SPECIALTY
PLATE OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION VIA MOBILE APP. AB
NINE EIGHTY FOUR WILL IMPLEMENT
THE FINDINGS FOR THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION PILOT PROGRAM BY
AUTHORIZING THE DMV IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHP TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION CARDS.
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES AND
LICENSE PLATE WRAPS. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION I'VE TAKEN A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE. I REMAIN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITION
AN INTAKE AND INTEND TO TAKE
FURTHER AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THERE ARE MAY FOURTEENTH
LETTER- SO IN ALL I WILL HAVE
ACCEPTED SIX OF THE SEVEN
AMENDMENTS REQUESTED BY THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MYSTERIOUS
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I'M GONNA HOLD OFF MY
VOTE TODAY- HOPE WITH AUTHORS
THE MORE WORK DO- I KNOW SEE
PEACE NOT LOSE THE OF THIS. AND
WE'RE BIGGEST USES THE VENDOR-
WANTS TO SELL. SPACE
ADVERTISEMENT PLAY. INITIALLY I
HAD A RULE THAT IT IS HE'S P.
COMMISSIONER. IN THE HEAD OF
THE ON THE VARIOUS. AND THIS
DOUBT WHETHER THE HEAD A DMV.
THEY GOT INTO THE- OF THE PLAY
IF. IT WAS EMAILED BY THE TODAY
AND THEY ME UP THE PHONE. AND I
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH AND I'LL BE
THAT PLACE OF SCHOOL LEFT THE
BE. BUT THE BIG THING ON PLAYED-
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PLACE RIGHT
THEY HAVE THERE IS TO MODE.
IT'S JUST WILL BE THE OBVIOUS
BLESSED NUMBER MONTH IN
REGISTRY. THEY HAVE ADVERT. I
SEE MULTIPLE ADVERTISE CHANNELS.
AND THAT'S NOT PER MO YOU WITH
THE B. AND C. H. P. SOUL IT WAS
A SOLD. FOR AND FOR THE DONE
THING THAT THEY REALLY SHOULD
BE DOING I MEAN. ARE REGULAR
PLATES WITH A FIRST OBVIOUSLY.
PLACE BUT- THEY WANNA SELL
SPACE ROBERT. IN A TOUGH
IMAGINE BE A VICTIM TO A CRIME.
YOU TRY TO DOT LICENSE PLATE
NUMBER. BILLS PLACE A VERY HIGH
FOR ME TO ON THE FREE IN THE
DATA. SO EXPRESSED THAT TO H.
P. DMV SO THERE ARE SOME.
ISSUES GOING ON WITH THE WITH
THE M. THAT NEED TO GET. OUT SO-
GONNA HOLD MY VOTE STATE
HOPEFULLY CAN ON THAT THERE'S
MORE WORK TO DO A THAT- JUST
I'M TO WORK WITH YOU TO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MYSTERY THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- THANK YOU- FOR
EXPRESSING YOUR I WANTED CLEAR
C. H. P. NOT UP ON BILL- AND WE
ARE MEETING WITH THE TO. ON
THIS AND SO WE ARE INTO WITH
HAS HAS NO PRESS AS OF TODAY ON
THE BILL SO I RESPECTFULLY FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR. ALL MEMBERS WHO TO THEIR
TO THE. ALL SAID OF A- HER WILL
THOROUGHLY CALENDAR I FORTY
NINE NEWS TO THE MEASURE. PATH
TO RETAIN AND FOR ITEMS NOW TWO
THROUGH. NINE FOUR. I'M HERE.
VIOLATED NINETY FIVE AB TEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO TWENTY BY SOME MEMBER FREE
AND OTHERS AND HEALTHCARE
FRIEDMAN ARE A THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBER THIS BILL IS SO
ENSURE THAT HOW OFFER THE
CHAIRED CARE TO WHICH THEY ARE
AND HOW BY LAW- WE DURING THE
LAST FEW YEARS I THOUGH P. ARE
SO TO BE CHARITY CARE HOSPITALS
WERE NEGLECTING DO THAT INSTEAD.
BASICALLY RUINING PEOPLE'S
SOMETIME RUINING THEIR TO OF
THEM BY SENDING THEIR COLOR ALL
THE DECK. WHEN THEY REALLY
SHOULD BEEN OFFERED OF PLAN OR
MANY CASES I CHAIR CARE WE
WORKING VERY CLOSE WITH ALL OF
THE STATE AND THE HOUSE WHO
RIGHT NOW ARE NOT OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THAT RECOGNIZES A
PROBLEM I'M WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS BEING ARE POOR AND
SICK AT RESIDENTS WITH THAT I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS. VOTE ALL
MY VOTED TO THEIR IT. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLAND TALLY THE
VOTE I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS TO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. LIVING
FILE ITEM NINE SIX SIX A TEN
THIRTY THE CLERK. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY GIPSON
AND ACT IN THE FALL HEALTH. MR
GIVING YOU ARE. THANK YOU VERY
MATTER MA'AM THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME PRESENT US ONLY
BILL TEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
SEEKS TO CREATE CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM FUND TO
REDUCE THE UNJUST IMPACT ON
COVERT NINETEEN. AND INTO INTO
THE FUTURE THIS BILL HAS- AND
ENJOY A UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR BOTH THE HELP THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THANK. THOSE MEMBERS THERE UP
EVEN BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC DATA
SHOWS THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
EXPERIENCE AND HIGHER RATES OF
ILLNESS AND PREMATURE DEATH
ACROSS A WIDE RANGE OF HEALTH
CONDITIONS. THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALSO
PLAGUED WITH ISSUES THAT
INCLUDES HEALTH- FUSE ME
HOUSING FOOD INSECURITY
EMPLOYMENT INSTABILITIES UNDER
RESOURCE SCHOOLS AND CHILDCARE
IN COMMUNITIES. THE VIOLENCE
HEY CRIMES AND JUST WE NEED TO
ADD THE DETERMINANTS TO BUILD A
HEALTHY SOCIETY. FOR EVERYONE
THAT BILL CAN BE RESERVE. TO
WEATHER THE STORM FOR FUTURE
DISASTERS THIS BILL WOULD
SUPPORT ON PARTNERSHIPS AMONG
COULD BASED OR- COMMUNITY
CLINICS STRIVE ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THAT SERVED UNDER COMMUTE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT I VOTE
ON ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
COLOR WILL THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A- ALL MEMBER
VOTED A. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I
SIXTIES WHO KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE.
MY NAME IS CONSENT
WERE TO FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO HOW.
IF YOU GAVE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PLEASE
TODAY PERCENT AB NINE EIGHT
NINE WHICH WOULD CREATE A
SPECIALIZED APPEAL PANEL. TO
ADDRESS SITUATIONS WHERE LOCAL
OFFICIALS SEEK TO PREVENT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING VIOLATION OF STATE LAW.
THIS BILL IS MODELED OFTEN. TO
BEEN IN IN OTHER STATES AND
IT'S HELPED RESOLVE DISPUTES
AROUND. UNLAWFUL DENIALS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. NO MORE
EXPEDITED LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
CONFRONTATIONAL AND MORE
CONSISTENT MANNER. TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES A NEW
PROCEDURAL REMEDY TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES. IT DOES NOT BOB DON'T
CHANGE ANY LOCAL ZONING OR LAND
USE POLICIES OR OTHERWISE
CHANGED. SOMETHING OF STATE LAW
AROUND HOUSING. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE FALL STATE
LONG GOOD FAITH ARE HIGHLY
UNLIKELY TO HAVE ANY.
INTERACTION WITH THE PANEL.
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY AND WILLFULLY
VIOLATING THE LAW WILL BE
ENCOURAGED TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. THERE'S LESS
ADVERSARIAL AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACH HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO ENCOURAGE
NEGOTIATIONS AND SETTLEMENT.
AND SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GROUPS ADVOCATES AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS. THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I VOTE ON
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE. THANK
YOU MR GABRIEL. C. STRONG YOU
ARE. I THANK YOU VERY SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS A CO OF A NINETY
NINE AYE RICE URGED YOUR
SUPPORT THIS IS ABOUT
ENCOURAGING EFFICIENCY AND
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS TO
INCREASE HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
OUR STATE. WE HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND HIGHEST MEDIAN SINGLE
FAMILY HOME PRICE LOW INCOME
AND MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES CAN
NO LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE IN OUR
STATE THIS BILL HELPS EXPEDITE
DISPUTES AND CREATES A FASTER
MORE CONSISTENT FORM TO HIS
RESOLVE CONCERNS THUS ALLOWING
FOR MORE BUILDING OF NEEDED
HOUSING AND WHILE STILL
PRESERVING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LAND USE AUTHORITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I ABOUT
THANK YOU MR FONG. IT'S JUST
AFTER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MY CONCERNS OF THIS BILL
ARE THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
FOR- RECOGNIZED ME. MY FOR THIS
BILL IS THAT- IN A LOT OF THE
BILL RELATE TO HOUSE. IS
THERE'S SOME HOW THE BLAME ON
CITY FOR NOT PROCESS OR- THAT'S
NOT THE WITH HOUSE. I LIVED IN
ONE OF THE CITIES THAT TO HAVE
THE FASTEST GROWING CITY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DURING THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS. I'VE ALSO- I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AGAIN
THIS LAST FOUR YEARS. FOUR
YEARS AGO THERE'S A AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT THAT WAS GOING
THROUGH. BASICALLY THEY'RE
BEING BOGGED DOWN BY THE
PROCESS OF THE PROCESS THAT IN
BUILDING THAT HAS BEEN CREATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. THESE TYPES
OF IT IN IN FACT A LOT OF THE-
OKAY PROJECTS WERE NOT
DISAPPROVED OF IT'S JUST IT'S
TAKING THEM FIVE YEARS TO GET
THROUGH A PROCESS THAT WE
CREATED. SO BLAMING CITIES AND
TELLING THE CITIES THAT HEY YOU
KNOW YOU GUYS ARE NOT NOT
APPROVING PROJECTS AND
THEREFORE. WE NEED TO WE NEED
TO TAKE IT OUT OF YOUR HANDS.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HELP THE
PROCESS THAT'S NOT GOING TO
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THERE
IS NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE LAWS THAT
WE HAVE CREATED. SO UNTIL WE
ATTACK THAT PROBLEM. THINGS
LIKE THIS ARE JUST TAKING
MATTERS OUT OF THE CITY'S
HANDS. AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS BOTTOM
LINE IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK. SO
I- I'M GOING TO BE OPPOSING
THIS AND I ASK YOU TO OPPOSE IT
ALSO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTRESS ERIKA. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MR GABRIEL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS
A FEW POINTS MADE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM YOUR YEAH. THE
TIME FOR THIS BILL IS THAT
DISAPPEAR COURT. IN THE FACT
THAT. IT IS EXTREMELY. AND
EXPENSE AND TIME. TO IN WOULD
IN SOME COURT. I THINK IF YOU
ASKED ANYBODY PRACTICE LAW THE
TELL YOU THAT. DESCRIPTION ALL
PERSON ROBERT. INCLUDES FOR
LOCAL GO. ALLOWS US GET A TO
TERMINATE IN A LAW AB. MORE AND
MORE COST EFFECTIVE. INTO THE
ABOUT THIS NOT. I WOULD.
SUGGEST THIS APPROACH HAS BEEN
TO. A DAY BY MY- ALL STATES.
THERE HAS BEEN EVAN BASED
RESEARCH LOOKING AT THE END. OF
THIS. I MIGHT DID A- STE ABOUT
HOW THIS. IN MASSIVE. THEY
FOUND THAT IN A PROBLEM EIGHTY
PER OF THE CASE IT PRINT IT WAS.
IN SETTLEMENT. NOT A PROTRACTED
LITIGATION NOT INCONSISTENT
FIGHTING BETWEEN CITIES AND
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND EVERYBODY ELSE. BUT IN A
QUICK EFFICIENT RESOLUTION OF
THIS. SO THIS HAS BEEN ADOPTED
IN OTHER STATES IT HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO WORK AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR-
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO THE.
ALL MY VOTED THIRD OF A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
VOTE ICE FIFTY THREE NEWS EIGHT
THAT MEASURE PASSES. TURNING TO
FILE ORDER WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT AB TENTATIVE FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ. SIMPLY TEN
EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
OTHER AND ACT THE CIVIL RIGHTS
HELLO YOU ARE A- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BYE SECURE COLLEAGUES
FIRST OFF HAPPY PRIDE THIS IS
THE GENDER NEW READ. BILL WHICH
HELPS TO THE WE REMOVE MUCH AS-
WE'VE WILL BE ADDRESSING OTHER
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS TO NARAL IN
TAYLOR THAT BILL TO THE SO. TO
HELP INSURE THAT WE ARE INCLUDE
AS POSSIBLE AS YOU KNOW MANY
OTHER STATES ARE LOOKING TO
EXCLUDE MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY AND WE OF COURSE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
INCLUSIVE I ALSO WANT TO THANK
MY JOIN AUTHOR. THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S CAUCUS
FROM BELL GARDENS FOR ALSO HER
SUPPORT IN THIS. ENDEAVOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER LOOMIS SEA ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YES THANK YOU
EVER AND- AFTER. DURING AUTHORS
BILL- AS A MATTER RIGHT THERE
YEARS I SAW. FIRST HAND HOW
PLATE. A OUR TO OUR SPATIAL.
AND HOW THAT'S WHY. FOR AL
THERE. ON SO I THINK THIS IS A
CALL SENSE BILL AS WE PUSH TO
MORE WILL INTO- THERE INTO. AND
MATHIS FORTH. WHAT WE PAY FOR
THOSE EARLY BLACK ARE REALLY A-
AND ALL SURE A STORY. OF MYSELF
LINK A LOG FOR A BIG THING
BEFORE. WHEN I WAS UP IN THAT.
WANTED TO PLAY WITH THE LINK
ALONG WITH THEIR- THE TOY. IN
SO I WASN'T ALLOW TO PLAY WITH
THE LINCOLN LOGS IN I WAS TOLD
GO PLAY THE DOLL IN THE K. AND
I DID OUR OUT THERE. BUT I HAD
A GREAT ONLY LOGS SINCE I WITH
THOSE. DAHLE AND I FIGURE OUT
OF TO CREE. PARTS I COULD BILL
THINGS ALONG THE WAY. AND SOME
PEOPLE AT IS FUNNY RIGHT IT'S
NOT FUNNY THE IN THIS THAT. I
AT LEAST AT THE RESULTS WERE
THIS TO GET A LITTLE PRE. THE
WAY MY MOM THOUGHT I. WE'RE AND
I WAS THE- THIS IS MY ME. THE
LINCOLN. THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
BE WEIRD OUT. THERE NOT OKAY
HAVE EVERY. WILL NOW. I DON'T.
ARE GOING TO. I LOVE MATH AND-
ANGELES. AND I'M TO DO THIS FOR
MYSELF. WELL SCRIPTED NOT. DO
THAT. ON AND SO WE ARE. THE
ABILITY TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES
WERE LIMITING THEIR- TO. AND
REALLY WERE LIMIT. THEIR BILL.
TO BE CAN DELETE. THAT WE NEED
TO BE DONE THE ROAD I. INSTEAD
INTO THE- AND SO. AND SO.
RESPECT ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA. C. AND
HEARING. NO FOR. YEAH THIS
REBEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. BACK
THANK YOU MATT SPEAKER IN
TALLER SO. HERE'S MY OBJECT TO
THE BILL. AND THESE ARE ALL MY
GOOD FOR SO JUST SO YOU KNOW.
TO ME. I'M OKAY WITH THE CHEN
STUFF EVERYTHING FINE NOPE. BUT
TELL A NUMBER CHIN HOW DID THIS.
THEIR PRODUCTS. THAT'S MICHAEL
THAT IS JUST GETTING TOO MUCH
INTO THE WEEDS SO THAT'S MY
MAIN OBJECTION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MR APPEL SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER WILLIAM THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MINUTES
REGARD WANT TO SHARE JUST THAT
I DO INSIDE ON THANK YOU MUCH
TO HOW AND FOR THE IN THIS MESS.
BUT IMAGINE THAT YOU'RE A CHILD.
TO BECOME A- WHY IS IT THAT THE
PERIODIC TABLE WITH ADONIS IS
IN THE BOYS SECTION. WHY IS IT
THAT YOU MIGHT FEEL A SENSE OF
STIGMA IF YOU LIKE TO PLAY WITH
GLITTER. AND YOU ARE A BOY. OR
PERHAPS YOU DON'T KNOW. YET AND
REVOLVING. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IN FAIRLY
NARROWLY TAILORED TO COMPANIES
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR MORE
AND IN FACT WE MIGHT THINK THAT
THIS IS. A HISTORICAL NATURE
WHEN IN FACT MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES INCLUDES TARGETED
THIS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN SO WE'RE JUST SIMPLY
CATCHING UP WITH THE TIMES TO
HELP CELEBRATE AND BE INCLUSIVE
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR LOW CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I FORTY FOUR NEWS
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM NINETY NINE AB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE A QUICK RATIO
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE
BY SOME BIGELOW AND ACTUALLY
THE FAX. HELLO YOU ARE A- THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH ADDRESSES
AN ERROR THAT OCCURRED
REGARDING ALLOCATION OF THE IN
LIEU VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BIGELOW SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN ARMS
VOTE WHO DESERVE. A ALL MY
VOTED. A ALL MEMBERS VOTED
ALREADY VOTED. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE TALITHA I SIXTY NEWS
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE PAST
RETAINER FILER WANNA AND ON ONE
MOVING FILE ITEM WANTED TO AB
ELEVEN THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME OF LEVIN THIRTEEN BY
MEMBER MEDINA OTHERS MEDICALLY
PUBLIC FOR SECONDARY EDUCATION.
HELLO I. IT LOOKS LIKE. FILE
ITEM. TO MAY HAVE BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. WE DISPENSED
FILA ONE OF THREE WILL PASS
REGION OF ITEMS ONE OF FOUR WE
JUST WITH FILE ITEM ONE OF.
PASS A RETAINER BILINGUAL OF
SIX WE HAVE JUST WITH FILE ITEM
WHEN I WAS. WE WILL PAY. AND
RETAIN A- ITEM ONE AWAIT
THROUGH ONE. WE ARE. WITH ITEM
ONE ALLOW. AND. ONE WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ONE AND
ONE FOURTEEN WITH THIS WITH
ITEM FIFTY. WILL PASS AND
RETAIN AND BY ITEMS WERE
SIXTEEN OR ONE EIGHTH WE ARE TO
WITH ITEM NINETY. FILE ITEM
WANT. AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX POINT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHER GENETICALLY SINGLE USE
FOR CENTURIES IT'S CAREER YOUR-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I'M
SO PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TALK SEVENTY A MEASURE
THAT WILL BUILD ON CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING EFFORTS TO COMBAT
WASTE FROM SINGLE USE ITEMS
WHICH HAS BEEN EXASPERATED BY
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND REDUCE UNNECESSARY COSTS
FOR BUSINESS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE FOOD
ACCESSORIES INCLUDING UTENSILS
NAPKINS CONDIMENTS PACKAGES
CLOG OUR LANDFILLS COMPLICATE
RECYCLING AND POLLUTES STREETS
AND WATERWAYS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE PANDEMIC HAS
INCREASED THEIR RELIANCE ON
TAKE OUT AND FOOD DELIVERY WITH
TRUST RESTAURANTS HAVE RELIED
UPON TO STAY AFLOAT. AS SUCH
THE USE A SINGLE FOOD SINGLE
USE WITH ACCESSORIES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED AND 523100%
INCREASE IN SINGLE USE PLASTICS
AND A. 30% INCREASE IN WASTE.
READ UNDER. SINGLE USE PLASTICS
IS A SIMPLE SOLUTION AND A WIN
WIN FOR REDUCING WASTE IN THE
FIRST PLACE SAVING BUSINESSES.
MONEY AND RELIEVING RECYCLERS
COMPOSTERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE
COMPLICATIONS AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. THIS BILL
ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM BUSINESS
HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES
AS WELL AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS VERY VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS TWELVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES PATH TO RETAIN A FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY TWO PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY THREE
THROUGH ONE TWENTY FIVE WOULD
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX. PASS AND RETAIN AND
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY SEVEN ONE
TWENTY EIGHT MOVING A FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE AB FOUR FORTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME FORTY
FORTY FOR BY SUMMER MCCARTY AN
APTLY IN MENTAL HEALTH. WITH
REGARD TO YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER WITH ALL THE
DID MARK ABOUT POLICE FOR.
WE'VE SEEN COMMUNITIES TALK
MORE AND MORE ABOUT EXPANDING
COMMUNITY POLICING. RELATE TO
MENTAL HEALTH CALLS. TO ALLOW
LINE FOR. TO FOCUS ON. TRUE
TRUE CRISIS IS IN OUR QUEUE.
AND ALLOW. PER TO. RESPOND TO
THE SCENE AND LEAD TO BETTER
CONSEQUENCES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES- THESE ALTERNATIVES
DO EXIST THEY JUST TAKE A LOT
MORE EFFORTS FOR MARK
JURISDICTIONS. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE A LOCAL COUNTY TO
DEVELOP TRAINING AND WRITTEN.
MATERIALS ALLOWING MOBILE
CRISIS TEAMS AND OR THEIR
DESIGNEES TO WRITE AND RE.
WRITE REPORTS AND TRANSPORT
PEOPLE. PURSUANT TO THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS FIFTY ONE FIFTY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO LAST YEAR LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT RECEIVED
NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND CALLS.
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH CRISES
AND FIFTY ONE FIFTIES. THIS%
BILL WOULD ALLOW CITIES LIKE
OURS HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO
DEVELOP NON POLICE APPROACHES
TO MENTAL HEALTH CRISES. AND
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES I MOVE
FORWARD. ASKEY RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY. HEARING
NO FOR DEBATE THE MATTER CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THOSE VERITABLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIGN A. OUR MEMBERS
THIRTY A- CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT I THINK FIVE
NEWS HERE THE PASSED. PASS
ENTERED ON FILE ITEMS ONE
THIRTY THROUGH ONE THIRTY THREE
WE DISPENSED WITH VIOLATE ONE
THIRTY FOR MOVING. TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRD FIVE EIGHT FIFTY
FIFTEEN THE CLERK OVER. SOME
PEOPLE FIFTEEN FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ADEQUATE THE
TAX. THIS IS ON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK IMMENSELY
EIGHTY FIFTH FIFTY WITH CREE
THE CAL C. OUT REACH FREE TO
ASSIST GRANDPA. THE PROVIDED
OUR OF REACH UP OKAY SERVICE.
FOR MILLIONS OF APPLY FOR TACK
CREDITS I JUST ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MAY SIGNED THING
HEARING NO FURTHER DELAY ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL. OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS KNOW EITHER
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRD OF. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ANTI THAT ICE FIFTY KNOWS
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'VE JUST
WITH BY ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX
MOON IF ONE SEVEN AB FIFTY
THIRTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEENTH
THREE BY THE COMEDIAN DECEMBER
FOR AND HEALING ARTS HELLO YOU
ARE A. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT
I THAN COLLEAGUES I RESPECT ASK
FOR. SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON MATTER THE WILL. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESERVE A- ALL
MEMBER VOTED IT. PALMER THIRTY
DESERVE A THE CLEAR WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND THAT I SIXTY FIVE
KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN A FIVE ITEMS WERE
THIRTY AND ONE NINE WE DISPENSE
WITH FIVE ITEM ONE FOR. WE WILL
PASS IT RETAIN A FILE ITEM. ONE
ONE. MEDINA FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
TWO AB FOR. SEVENTY THREE THE
WILL READ. SOME OF THE OFFICE
SOME THREE THE COMMITTEE ON JOB
AND- FOR A ANY ECONOMY. AND
EXCELLING SMALL BUSINESS.%
CERVANTES ARE HAPPY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN AB FIFTEEN.
THREE IN THIS JOHN COMMITTEE
BILL WHICH IT'S WAS SHE A
SEPARATE GRANT PROGRAM FOR THE
PER. OF SO. THE SMALL FOR
PROGRAMS ON A DAY TODAY MATCH
BASIS IT WILL HAVE LOCAL GUY.
ARE TO OF COMMERCE. DEVELOPMENT
PROFESSIONAL. AS WELL AS- AS
STATED LOCAL. YOU CAN SIX.
BUSINESS RETENTION PROGRAM.
WILL ALSO AND THE COULD. OF THE
STATE RIGHT NOT. OF SMALL
BUSINESS TECH ASSIST CENTER I.
ASK FOR I ABOUT. THANK YOU
AROUND HIS HEARING FURTHER TO
ON THE MATTER OF A CAR WILL THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THIRD OF
A- HOME VOTE TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS AYE OF. CLERK FLOWS
THROUGH AND YOU THAT I THINK
SEVEN ZERO MEASURE PASS. MOVING
THE FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BROTHER
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ACALANES
GOVERNMENT. IT'S JUST DOWN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THIS IS ARE A TO. SO
CO BILL NINE CONTRA ITEMS NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR STERN SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE COURT WILL THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIGN OF A- ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A. HER WILL WHO SEVERAL
INTELLIA I THINK FOUR NO WHEN
THEM PASSED. FILE ITEM ONE FOR
FOUR EIGHTY THIRD THE COURT
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FOR BY
ASSEMBLY CHAO ACKLEY ON A BILL
DECISIONS. FOR JANUARY OPEN AND
I THANK YOU MADAM IS AND EIGHT
THIRTY WHAT IS THAT CRY TO FOR
STATE AGENTS PROBE OF HIGHER
AUTOMATE THIS IS SYSTEM ARE E.
IS TO MINIMIZE THE OF A IN
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACTS
RESULTING FROM THEIR DESIGN AND
APPLICATION THE USE OF AUGER
THAN DRIVEN EDS IS CAN ASSIST
WITH CREDIT DECISIONS
EMPLOYMENT SCREENING INSURANCE
ELIGIBILITY MARKETING AND
DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT SERVICES
JUST TO NAME A FEW. HOWEVER
PULLEY DESIGN EDS IS CAN ALSO
CREATE UNFAIR BIASED AND
INACCURATE RESULTS CAUSING
DISPROPORTIONATE HARM TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WHILE UNDERMINING
TRUST IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR FOR
EXAMPLE IN MICHIGAN AND
UNEMPLOYMENT AUGUR THEM
WRONGFULLY ACCUSED FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE OF FRAUD.
FORCING MANY OF THEM TO PAY
HEAVY FINES DECLARE BANKRUPTCY
OR HAVE THEIR HOMES FORECLOSED
UPON IN ARKANSAS MEDICAID
RECIPIENTS LOST ACCESS TO HOME
CARE NURSING VISITS AND MEDICAL
TREATMENTS DUE TO INACCURACIES
IN IT AUGUR THEM IN DETROIT AND
MARKET ANALYSIS THEM USED TO
ALLOCATE PUBLIC HOUSING
SUBSIDIES TAX BREAKS IN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT RE DIRECTED
CRITICAL FUNDING AWAY FROM THE
CITY'S POOREST IN PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS. WHEN
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES PURCHASE
MACHINE LEARNING ATS SYSTEMS
INSTEAD OF MERELY FOCUSING ON A
PRICE BIDDING PROCESS
INNOVATION AND COMPETITION THEY
MUST ALSO EXAMINE THE GOALS
VALUES AND RISK INVOLVED
OTHERWISE GOVERNMENT MAY FAIL
IN MEETING PUBLIC EXPECTATIONS
OF OVERSIGHT OF THE SYSTEMS
WHICH MAY INADVERTENTLY CREATE
NEW RISK OR HARMS SO IT IS
IMPORTANT TO SET UP CLEAR
GUIDELINES. ON HOW TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
ALSO EXPLAINED ABILITY OF THESE
SYSTEMS THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
A GOVERNMENT CONTRACTOR TO
SUBMIT AN EDS IMPACT ASSESSMENT
REPORT TO THE AGENCY. TO
EVALUATE THE PRIVACY AND THE
REST POSED TO PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAT MAY IN. IN OR
DISCO. IMPACTS INTO. WITH A
REQUIRE THE STATE TO PRODUCE AN
ACCOUNT REPORT INCLUDING A
MITIGATION PLAN FOR IDENTIFYING
AND MINIMIZING THE POTENTIAL
FOR ANY DISPARATE. IMPACTS
FINALLY DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WOULD MAKE BOTH
REPORTS AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
ONLINE. THE WORLD ECONOMIC
FORUM STATED THAT GOVERNMENTS
DONOT HAVE THE LATITUDE TO USE
BLACK BOX ALGORITHMS THAT
INCREASINGLY CHARACTERIZED.
MARGARET AND DEPLOY IN THE
MARKETPLACE GOVERNMENT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO READ ENSURE
THAT THESE SYSTEMS DO NOT
CREATE ANY NEW HARMS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY POSE A
SIGNIFICANT RISK TO THE LEGAL
RIGHTS HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
INDIVIDUALS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOW C.
HEARING NO FOR DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE EITHER
OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERA. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THERE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE ICE FORTY
SEVEN NEWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THE PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FIVE WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SIX THE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT AB THIRTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS
IN EQUITY IN THIS HOUSEHOLD IF
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THE MATTER. MADAM
SPEAKER. IT TOOK A PANDEMIC TO
REALIZE WE NEEDED TO FIND
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE WAYS TO
ENSURE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. BY
ALLOWING MORE FLEXIBILITY
PATIENTS COULD CONTINUE TO SEE
THE PROVIDERS CREATING A BRIDGE
TO EXPAND ACCESS IN MORE NORMAL
TIMES. AB THIRTY TWO MIXES
FLEXIBILITY MORE PERMANENT SO
THAT ACCESS DOESN'T GO AWAY
WITH THE PANDEMIC. WELL THE
WHILE THE PANDEMIC HAS LED TO
DISRUPTIONS IN PATIENT CARE
ACCESS TO CARE TELEHEALTH
SPECIFICALLY TELEPHONIC HERE
HAS ALLOWED PROVIDERS TO
PROVOKE BRING CARE TO THEIR
PATIENTS. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM AB THIRTY TWO
WILL INCREASE HEALTH CARE
ACCESS WHILE DECREASING
DISPARITIES CREATED BY INCOME
RACE AND ETHNICITY. LACK OF
MOBILITY A SHORTAGE OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS OR TECHNOLOGY
BASED BARRIERS. THIS POLICY IS
SUPPORTED BY SAFETY NET CLINICS
CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS
HOSPITALS PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU HAVE AGUIAR-CURRY MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MEANT TO BE HERE THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL
USED TO BE A TIME WHEN WE MAKE
THEM LOOK AT TELEHEALTH AND
TAKE A LOOK AT RULE AREAS AND
THOUGHT THAT THESE WERE SOME
YEARS AGO BENEFIT- FROM
TELEHEALTH AND CERTAINLY THEY
ARE BELIEVE ME TELL YOU ABOUT
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE. THAT
DURING A PANDEMIC FOUND OUT
IMMEDIATELY HOW IMPORTANT A
TELEHEALTH WAS WHEN DURING A
EIGHTY EIGHT PANDEMIC LIKE WE
JUST EXPERIENCED FOLKS COULDN'T
GET ON THE BUS. COULDN'T GET TO
COULDN'T GET TO A CLINIC OR
HOSPITALUNLESS THEY PUT
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY IN THE
ABILITY TO JUST THE BILL
PRESCRIPTION DRUG THE ABILITY
TO GET A HEALTH CHECK UP THE
ABILITY TO CHECK HIS BASIC
QUALITY OF CHARACTER CARE
ISSUES. ARE DONE BY TELEHEALTH
HAD A HUGE IMPACT WE'VE NOT TO
SURVIVE IN CERTAIN AREAS WE
WERE NOT JUST BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF BASIC HEALTHCARE NEEDS
VISITS. TELEHEALTH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT RULERS
LIMITS HOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
ALSO IS FOR NOW URBAN AREAS AND
I HOPE IT'S HERE TO STAY
BECAUSE IN A LOT OF CASES THE
ABILITY TO TAKE A DAY OFF WORK
A FEW HOURS TRAVEL SOMETIMES
WITH. KIDS JUST TO GET HEALTH
CARE. NOW KNOW THAT WE CAN DO
IT WOULD BETTER WITH. ON FOUR
DON'T HAVE. THIS INCOME
GET BAY. BASIC TELL- THIS WAY
IT SAID RIGHT ON PHONE BUT
BASIC HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
WITHOUT LEAVING THEIR HOME THIS
IS. THIS IS A GAME CHANGER WHEN
IT COMES TO PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE FOR SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE- WHEN
YOU'RE WORKING A NINE TO FIVE
OR YOU CAN'T GET TIME OFF FOR
YOU HAVE A WORK SCHEDULE THAT
IS NOT- THAT IS NOT THE SAME
EVERY SINGLE DAY. SO I URGE.
YOU IT I URGE OUR COLLEAGUES
FOR YES VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEASURE YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
LEGISLATION THAT HAS BEEN
CHAMPIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM WINTERS AND HOLLISTER OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. NOW
WILL IT MORE THAN EVER THE
AFFECTS OF HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES ON LOW INCOME AND
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
DEMONSTRATE THE IMMEDIATE NEED
FOR CHANGES. TO THE WAY
HEALTHCARE IS DELIVERED TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THE PAST YEAR
HAS. NOT ONLY. HAS SHOW NOT
ONLY THE POSSIBILITY OF USING
TELEHEALTH BUT ALSO THE
EFFECTIVENESS. AB THIRTY TWO
INSURERS THAT WE INVEST IN THE
CONTINUE AND CONTINUE TO USE
PROVEN TOOLS. THAT INCREASE
ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE
ACROSS THE STATE. I AM BLESSED
TO COME FROM L. A. COUNTY-
WHERE WE HAVE ARE PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING- AT OUR AVAILABILITY
UNFORTUNATELY THE REST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS NOT THAT
WAY. AND TELEHEALTH IS NOT JUST
A PHONE CALL. OR AS SOON AS IT
IS PROVIDING SERVICE TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR MAYOR DR
EMILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND EMBER. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO AND WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR WINTERS FOR
CARRYING IT CHAMPIONING IT AND
BEING PERSISTENT. AB THIRTY TWO
WILL ALLOW FOR EVERY POSSIBLE
METHOD OF ACCESSING A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL I EAT TELEHEALTH.
WHICH WAS PROVEN DURING THIS
PANDEMIC TO HELP TO INCREASE
EQUITY AND ACCESS. I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THEY YOU SEE AND HEARING
NO FOR DEBATE ON THE MATTER
FACT WE ARE. WOULD DO I TO
CLOSE. THIS IS A BIG PART OF.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE LIVE IN SO
ARE REAL AND DID HAVE A TO
HEALTH CARE. THAT A PHONE CALL
OR IS IN CALL COULD. YOUR LIFE
MAKE HIM HELP FROM YOU WITH A
HEALTHIER OUTLOOK I LIFE.
THEY'VE BEEN SELLING ME THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTH PERCENT OF
OUR BEEN. HEALTH CALL HAVE.
HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY ATTEND THE
BRING HEALTH. APPOINTMENTS.
MIDDLE IS ON THE TOP ON THE
RISE EVERYTHING DAY BUT FOR
SOME TO BE ABLE TO PICK UP A
PHONE AND BE ABLE TO GET. AS
WELL WORTH. ALL THE TIME AND
EFFORT. FOR US TO MAKE SURE GET
THE THAT ACCESS TO THE PEOPLE.
I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU FOR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THANK BAKER
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON THOSE
WHO DESIRED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLE IN HOW IT I
SEVENTY NEWS ZERO THEM PASSED.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY NINE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY AB FORTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOMMERDORF
FIVE BY MEMBER EVERY CURRY AND
NOT TO A- HOPE AND COMMUNITY IS
TO FOR ME. AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM. AB
FORTY CREATES A- FRAMEWORK FOR
INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTS. IN
CALIFORNIA. IN BILL THE
PERSONAL CARE. IT LIMITS HEMP.
TO CONTAINING NO MORE THAN
THREE TENTHS OF A PERCENT OF
THC. REQUIRES THAT HIM
PRODUCERS BE SUBJECT TO TESTING
AND LABELING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THEIR PRODUCTS. MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN PURCHASING HEMP CBD
PRODUCTS AT THE LOCAL NATURAL
FOOD SHOPS FITNESS CENTERS THAT
EVEN HIGH END DEPARTMENT STORES
FOR QUITE SOME TIME. IN FACT
SENIORS ARE SIGNIFICANT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
PEOPLE CHOOSING TO USE HEMP CBD
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT WANT TO
VISIT A MARIJUANA DISPENSARY.
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF CBD
DERIVED FROM HEMP IS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY. SHOULD THE STATE
CHOOSE NOT TO CLARIFY THE HIM
PROXY PRODUCTS- LEGAL FOR SALE
AND CONSUMPTION. BUSINESSES AND
THEIR TAX REVENUES ARE LOST.
MORE OVER THE MANY CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS THE CURRENTLY
PURCHASE AND RELY ON HIM CBD
PROJECTS WILL FACE A NEW
BARRIER A- WHAT THEY NEED. THIS
MEANS DRIVING CONSUMERS TO OUT
OF STATE ONLINE MARKETS OR THE
MARIJUANA DISPENSARIES WORST
THE CBD HAS NOT BEEN TESTED FOR
CONTAMINANTS OR POKE POTENCY.
AB FORTY FIVE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO ACCESS NON IN TALKS
INDICATING ALTERNATIVE PRODUCT
THEY WANT FOR FARMERS TO
ESTABLISH THEMSELVES IN THIS
FAST GROWING INDUSTRY. I'VE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO PERMIT A
MEASURE OF UNCERTAINTY.
UNCERTAINTY TO ADDRESS FROM THE
FARM HEROES CONCERNS AND I
RESPECT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SEEING AND HEARING FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WILL- THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THE-
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO IT. CLERK
WILL- THE ROLE AND TALLY THAT
ICE FIFTY NINE KNOWS NINE ON
THE URGENCY IS FIFTY NINE KNOWS
NINE ON THE THAT MEASURE HOW.
MEMBERS OF ANNOUNCEMENTS YOU ON
TO THE NEXT BILL WE BE TAKING
ASIAN BREAK IT THIRTY FOR
DINNER. IT WILL NOT BE SERVED
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS LOBBY
LEAVING WILL BE COMING BACK AT
SIX THIRTY TO CONTINUE THEIR
FAMILY'S BUSINESS. MOVING TO
THE NEXT FILE ITEM FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY ONE EIGHTY FORTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MARIA'S INACCURATE IN HUMAN
SERVICES ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT TO
YOU AB FORTY SEVEN. WHICH WOULD
CREATE A COORDINATED APPROACH
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AFFECTED BY BORDER
SEPARATION. THIS BILL WORKS
THREE CHRISTIAN LEE CONNECT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES SO THAT THEY
MAY NEED TO THEIR NEEDS. WE
MUST FIND INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
SUPPORT OUR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
AND BUILD UPON PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND NONPROFITS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MISS WRATH
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS FOR
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS RESERVE A-
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY ONE
KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
BUT WILL NEED TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY TWO A. B. FIFTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND OTHERS NOT LAW FOR SOME IF
YOU GAVE YOU ARE A- THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I. TODAY PRESENT
ITS GO FOR SAID CONTINUE ON THE
SUB. OF CRIMES WHICH WE JUST
EARLY TODAY. THIS BILL WOULD
IMPLEMENT SPUR. RECOMMEND FROM
THE CALIFORNIA'S AUDITOR THERE
IS AN AUDIT DONE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT FOUND
SERIOUS DEFICIENCIES IN A WAY
THAT CALIFORNIA DOCUMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO HATE CRIMES. WILL
HELP TO IMPROVE THE TRAINING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
IMPROVE COORDINATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
GROUPS. AND ADVOCATES ACROSS
THE STATE AND IS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I VOTE
WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER GOVERNMENT TO
YOUR A- THANK YOU I'M GOING TO
JUST BE VERY PER BUT AS A
PROSECUTOR. I CAN SHARE THAT
OFTENTIMES. HATE CRIMES AND
HATE INCIDENTS ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO INVESTIGATE- IN
PART BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
PERSONNEL HAVEN'T HAD THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING SO I'M
PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHORS
THIS BILL VERY MUCHHOPE WE CAN
MOVE IT FOR WITH THE STRONG
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU MR CHIU
SEEN HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER MISTER GET REAL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH I
JUST WANT TO THANK GOD MY TRAIN
OFTEN SANTA FOR THE HIS FIRST
INTO RESPECT REQUEST AND I'VE.
CORRECT OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER. A ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE ARE. TO CLERK
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THAT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE. MOVING FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX ONE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILLS ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GAVE AND OTHER
AND THAT IN THE BIZ PAN TO
RELIEF MR GABRIEL YOU ARE AGAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY A B. C. ONE THIS IS A IT
THIS A BILL TO HELP OUR
STRUGGLING SMALL PARTICULARLY
IN THE STATE CALIFORNIA I KNOW
THAT IN MY COMMUNITY INCLUDING
MINE ARE SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND SO MANY OF
THEM ARE BARELY HANGING ON BY A
THREAD RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF OUR
CALVET PANDEMIC THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE THEM WITH REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY TO INCREASE OUTDOOR
DINING TO INCREASE TAKE OUT AND
DELIVERY OPTIONS I KNOW THAT
FOR MYSELF AND MY WIFE WE ARE
VACCINATED BUT OUR KIDS ARE
NOT. AND SO WE ARE INTERESTED
IN THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE FOR
CONTINUING TO BE ABLE TO DINE
OUTDOORS IF THERE WAS EVER A
MOMENT TO SUPPORT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY
THIS IS THAT MOMENT AND SO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING HEARING FURTHER DEBATE
ON MEDICAL WILL THE ROLE ALL
MEMBER MOVED TO THAT OF A- ON
MEMBERS VOTED FOR OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VERY. BURKE WELL THE
ROLE AND TALITHA I SEE SIX ZERO
THE PASSED MEMBERS WE MOVING IN
ORDER TO FILE ITEM FORTIES. AB
TWENTY THE CLERK WILL. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND ACCOLADES PEACE ALL.
IF YOU'RE HOLD YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MANAGED MEMBERS TO I.
PRESENTING A SIM BILL TWENTY
SIX WOULD BE THAT SEEKS TO
PROVIDE UNIVERSE MEASURE. THAT
A STAB TO. ONE WHAT IT MEANS
PEACE TO INTERVENE WHEN WITH A
YOU OF FORCE. BY ANOTHER PIECE%
OFFICER AND TWO SIR OUTCOME FOR
PHIL TO INTERVENE. AND WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT PORAC
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DEPUTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS HAVE REMOVED HAVE MOVED
TO A NEUTRAL POSITION. I LIKE
TO THINK THE CHEER PUBLIC
SAFETY AND MY GOOD FRIEND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALMDALE FOR
THEIR- INTERVENING. AND HELPING
AND GIVING SOME DIRECTION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN MR
LACKEY ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE-
THE GREAT WORK IN THE OUTRAGE.
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA
FOR WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND TRYING TO
IMPROVE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
I'M NOT IN A POSITION TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT I MEAN
EXPLAIN YOU WHY. THE COUNTERS
THAT INVOLVE THE USE OF FORCE
FOR COMPLEX DYNAMIC. AND OFTEN
VERY VERY TRAGIC. FOR THAT
REASON EXISTING LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES. DUTY TO INTERCEDE.
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WHO ARE IN THE PRESENCE OF A
USE OF FORCE BY REQUIRING AN
OFFICER WHO FAILS TO INTERCEDE
TO RECEIVE THE SAME PUNISHMENT
AS AN OFFICER WHO USES THE
EXCESSIVE FORCES AND FLEXIBLE
AND ALSO MAY BE VERY UNFAIR.
THE USE OF FORCE THAT COUNTERS
ARE CHAOTIC CONFUSING. AND VERY
DYNAMIC THEY HAPPEN VERY VERY
FAST WHEN MULTIPLE AGENCIES ARE
INVOLVED WHEN OTHER OFFICERS
ARRIVED LATE AT THE SCENE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO GATHER THE
SAME INFORMATION. I SUPPORT
DISCIPLINE OF OFFICERS FOR
MISCONDUCT. INCLUDING THE
CREATION OF A SYSTEM THAT
INCLUDES THE POTENTIAL FOR
DECERTIFICATION FOR NON
CRIMINAL LACKS BUT I ALSO FOR A
SUPPORT. ALLOWING A MEASURE OF
DISCRETION THE TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE OFFICER'S RECORD.
AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THE
ALLEGED VIOLATION. THE
REQUIREMENT THAT AN OFFICER WHO
FAILS TO INTERCEDE RECEIVED THE
SAME PENALTY BECAUSE THE
OFFICER WHO USES EXCESSIVE
FORCE IS TO INFLEXIBLE. INSTEAD
WE SHOULD ALLOW POLICE OFFICERS.
EMPLOY TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
FACTIONS. OF THE FAILURE TO
INTERCEDE ON THE OFFICER'S
PRIOR RECORD. AT OBJECTIVELY
DETERMINE WHETHER DISCIPLINE IS
REQUIRED. AND WHAT THE PROPER
PENALTY SHOULD BE ALSO NOTHING
IN THE BILL PROHIBITS US
REQUIREMENT FOR THE SAME
PENALTY FROM BEING ENFORCED
RETROACTIVELY. TO EXCESSIVE
FORCE OF FAIR TO INTERVENE IN
SITUATIONS THAT OCCURRED PRIOR
TO JANUARY FIRST I BELIEVE
THAT'S VERY UNFAIR AND I URGE
YOUR- NON SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LACK SEEING NO FOR
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER WHO
WOULD YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
SPEAKER. HI I'M A LITTLE BIT.
THE BY THE- PRESENTATION
BECAUSE IT WAS IN PUBLIC SAFETY
THAT WE REMOVED ACCESSORY TO A
CRIME. I WAS VERY CLEAR AT THAT
POINT THAT THERE WAS AN ELEMENT
OF THE BILL THAT WAS COMING OUT.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL CREATES.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. TRANSPARENCY
THIS CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND AND
ALSO FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
UNDERSTAND. THE PROCESS AND THE
THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY IN
TERMS OF TRAINING THEY COULD BE
CLEAR FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND AS WELL. SO EASY TO
SAY THAT EXISTS. BUT IT'S NOT
IN STATUTES. I THINK IT'S ALSO
SAFE TO SAY THAT. WE HAD A
DECERTIFICATION ELEMENT IN THIS
BILL THAT WAS REMOVED. AND
APPROPRIATIONS BECAUSE THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL. DEALING WITH THE
CERTIFICATION WHICH THIS IS
LIKELY TO BE ADDED BACK INTO.
SO I CAN SAY TO THE THINGS THAT
WERE JUST PRESENTED BY MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM PALMDALE. ARE NOT
CORRECT. I WENT THE EXTRA MILE.
AND I REMOVE A VERY CRITICAL
PIECES OF THIS BILL THERE WERE
CENTRAL. TO MEET IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND ALSO ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HAVING AN ELEMENT OF THE BILL
THAT WAS EVEN PUT IN BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THERE'S NO
RETALIATION. AGAINST AN OFFICER.
THAT CAME FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT MADE ITS WAY INTO THE BILL.
SO I THINK WE WENT. THE EXTRA
MILE. AND THEN SOME. TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WAS FAIR. BALANCED
AND CREATED THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY THE PUBLIC IS
LOOKING FOR- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
THE. ALL MEMBERS RESERVE A.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING ABOUT HIGHS FORTY SIX
NO SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
LIVING BACK IN FILE ORDERED
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR AB
SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY RULES SIX BY SOME
BERNARD AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE
COSTA RESOURCE. FOR HER BACK
ARE RECOGNIZED YES MA'AM
REMEMBER AB SIX WILL PROVIDE
SCRIPT INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY WITH FUNDING UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONDUCT RESEARCH
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF A BLUFF
COLLAPSE EARLY WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM TO IMPROVE
BEACH SAFETY IMPROVE PREVENT
FUTURE FOR CHARITIES. IN
ADDITION TO PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS ERODING CLIFF THREATEN
EXTENSIVE CLIFFTOP DEVELOPMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
HIGHWAYS REAL WASTE WASTE WATER
OIL NATURAL GAS AND NUCLEAR
FACILITIES UNIVERSITIES SEVERAL
CRITICAL MILITARY BASES THE
NUMEROUS THE BEACHES AND PARKS.
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS THAT
DRIVES CLIFF FAILURES
TRIGGERING MECHANISMS MAGNITUDE
OF EROSION IN TIMING OF CLASS
IS ESSENTIAL FOR COASTAL MAY.
AND BUILDING RESILIENT AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY I
FOR YOUR ON. THANK YOU MISS
BURNHAM SEEING AND HEARING NO
MISS WALDRON ARE RECOGNIZED BY
PAULA. I JUST WANT TO RISE IN
SOME OF THIS. HAVE SERVED ON
THE NORTH CAN TRANS JUST FOR A
YEARS WHERE THE TRACK A LITTLE
RIDE ON THE COLLAPSE IN A VERY.
KILL PEOPLE ON THEM OR ON THE
BEACH. THESE BLOOD A VERY ON
THE STATE. IT'S BEEN DE. AND DE.
AND THE- WHERE WE KNOW THAT
THESE PEOPLE OFFS ARE ON. AND
ARE CUT AND BASICALLY A- BEFORE
EYES. AND WE NEED THE FUNDING
WE NEED THIS. WE NEED THE IN
ORDER TO STABILIZE THEM. BOTH
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT OF THE
COASTAL REGION BUT AS WELL AS
THE EFFICIENCY OF. WHAT WE
GONNA DO WITH THE TRAIN TRACKS
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH THE
NEIGHBORING HOMES AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THERE SO I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON. SEEING NO FURTHER ON
THE MATTER BOERNER HORVATH
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED EITHER.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESERTED THE.
ALL MEMBERS VISIONARY VOTE.
CLERK WILL FLOWS THROUGH ROLAND
TALIBAN I SEE FOUR ZERO MEASURE.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO CLERK WILL READ.
SOME BILL SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY
SALAS OTHERS I REALLY GENES IN.
THIS IS ALICE YOU ARE. THANK
YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SAID WHICH WILL
ADDRESS ME BIO SECURITY- WITHIN
THE AND THE INTO. MEMBERS YOU
MIGHT NOT BE AWARE OF THIS.
RIGHT NOW THROUGH THE MAIL YOU
CAN ACTUALLY ORDER THE PARTS
THE DNA. A COUPLE. TO CREATE.
LIKE KOBE NINE. LIKE EBOLA THIS
MEASURE WILL PUT IN SAFEGUARDS
AND GUIDELINES FOR US TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS TO PROTECT
THE COUNTRY IN THE WORLD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING
AND HEARING FURTHER ON THEM THE-
WILL OPEN ROLE. ALL MY VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS HE
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
A. WHERE WILL. CLOSE THE IN
TELLING EYES SIXTY FOR KNOWS
ONE THAT MIGHT PASSES. WE WILL
PASS AND REYES ON FILE ITEM ONE
SIX MOVING TO AN ONE FIFTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THREE OF HER
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THREE BY SOME MEMBER
ROB RIVAS OTHER. HE'S BEEN A
PART OF LIFE HERE AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT DOESN'T TAKE
MUCH TO REMEMBER THE WILD FIRES
FROM FROM LAST YEAR FROM PRIOR
YEARS WHEN OUR SKIES ORANGE THE
AIR WAS FILLED WITH- WITH TOXIC
LEVELS OF SMOKE AND- FOR US
HERE IN THE STATE IS RESIDENTS
WE WERE ALL ADVISED TO STAY
INSIDE TO. AVOID ACTIVITIES
OUTDOORS AND WHILE MANY OF US
HAVE THE LUXURY TO SHELTER
INDOORS FARMING AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS REMAIN OUTDOORS IN
SMOKY FIELDS AND ORCHARDS TO
PICK CROPS THAT FED OUR STATE
THE FED OUR COUNTRY. THIS
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THREE SIX THE BILL ON
CAL OSHA'S STANDARD FOR
PROTECTING FARMING AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE AND
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY- SOME
CONDITIONS. AS THE NUMBER OF
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY DAYS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE ANNUALLY
HERE IN OUR STATE AND IN OUR
FIRST IN THE NATION AG
PRODUCING STATE. WE CANNOT
STAND FOR OUR FOREIGN OUR GOAL
TO WORKERS TO RESTORE HEALTH
AND WELLBEING EVERY TIME THEY
GO INTO THE FIELDS TO HARVEST
THE FOOD THAT WE ALI. THIS BILL
WILL HELP PROTECT LIVES AND
ENSURE A MORE RESILIENT FOOD
SYSTEM WHEN WHAT WENT WHEN
WILDFIRES INEVITABLY STRIKE
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MYSTERY OF
US SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY NO THERE ON THE
MEASURE THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITH UNIFIED ONE FIFTY EIGHTY
B.AB ONE SEVENTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS AND
ACCLIMATED VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION ESTARá BACK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED- GOOD AFTERNOON
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB ONE SEVENTEEN A
BILL TO LUCKY BIKE REBATES TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING UNDER
THE AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM BY INCREASING E. BIKE
ADOPTION WE'RE ABLE TO REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. A
RECENT NOT A STUDY OF NORTH
AMERICAN EVEN ONERS SHOW THAT
NEARLY HALF OR 46% OF EVE I
COMMUTE TRIPS REPLACED SWITCH
SHORT TERM SHORT AREA
AUTOMOBILE COMMUTE TRIPS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS WE MUST WORK TO REDUCE
THESE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND REPLACE THEM WITH CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES IF I COULD OPTION
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE LAST YEAR BUT COST
REMAINS A FACTOR IN
AVAILABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
FOR SO MANY CALIFORNIANS. AB
ONE SEVENTEEN WILL MAKE E.
BIKES MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
CALIFORNIANS ALLOWING MORE
PEOPLE TO ADOPT THIS CLEANER
HEALTHIER FORM OF
TRANSPORTATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
AS FOR ABOUT HIS BENNETT YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED- JUST. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER JUST LIKE THE
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE
SEVEN I THINK THAT- TEN YEARS
FROM NOW WILL REALLY LOOK BACK
AND SAY THIS WAS THE BEGINNING
OF- VERY FUTURE CHANGE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AND CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THE LAST MILE ISSUES
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE
HAVE OUT THERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ENCOURAGE AND I BOTH THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT SEEING. AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER. THEY'RE GONNA FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY NINE AB TWO
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND
ACTIVATING A VITAL RECORDS MR
ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWO ONE
EIGHT ALIGNS THE PROCESS FOR
UPDATING TRANSGENDER MERIT
CERTIFICATES IN THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES OF THEIR CHILDREN
WITH THE PROCESS ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR UPDATING THEIR OWN
BIRTH CERTIFICATE THIS GIVES
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS THE
TOOLS NEEDED TO OBTAIN ACCURATE
IDENTIFICATION DOCUMENTS FOR
THEMSELVES AND THE CHILDREN
PROTECTING THEIR PRIVACY AND
THEIR WELLBEING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU
MISTER WARREN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK ILL OPEN
THEIR ALL. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS WELL THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I MEAN IF ITEM ONE SIXTY AB TWO
TWENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
AND I PLAYED IN THE WILDLIFE.
IF YOU'RE WHERE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWO TO THREE MAKES
IT UNLAWFUL TO TAKE DUDLEYA
FROM ITS NATURAL HABITAT ON
LAND OWNED BY THE GOVERNMENT OR
ON PROPERTY THAT'S NOT ONE'S
OWN. AND ESTABLISHES STRONGER
MINIMUM PENALTIES ALARMINGLY
POACHERS HAVE BEEN HARVESTING
W. BY THE THOUSANDS TARGETING
LARGER MORE MATURE PLANTS ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST. THAN
SHIPPING AND SELLING THEM
ELSEWHERE WHILE THE COURTS HAVE
BEEN CREATED IN PENALIZING
POACHERS THE FINE AMOUNTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY LEVY ARE
MINUSCULE COMPARED TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY POACHERS CAN
MAKE SELLING THE PLANTS ON THE
BLACK MARKET. AB TWO TO THREE
WILL HELP TO DETER W.
APPROACHING AND PROMOTE
EFFECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT I ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER WARD. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
COLUSA ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY ONE MOVIE TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY TWO EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE IN THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY
TWO THIRTY THREE SIXTY ENSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS APPLYING TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HAS A FAIR SHOT. THE MISSION
REGARDLESS OF WEALTH AND FAMILY
CONNECTIONS. WHEN YOU SEE
CAMPUS STAFF WERE IMPLICATED IN
THE FBI'S OPERATION VARSITY
BLUES. COLLEGE ADMISSIONS FRAUD
INVESTIGATION THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
RESPONDED BY APPROVING AN AUDIT
INTO UC ADMISSIONS. PROCESS
THESE THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT SOME UC CAMPUSES STUFF
EXPLOITED LOOPHOLES IN THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS TO ADMIT
UNDER QUALIFIED STUDENTS. AS
FAVORED THE STUDENT SKEWED
WEALTHY AND WHITE. APPLICANTS
CHANCES OF EMISSIONS WERE ALSO
FOR SOUND TO BE DEPENDENT ON
WHICH STAFF REVIEWED
APPLICATIONS. AB TWO THIRTY
THREE IS ALIGNED WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS I
REQUEST THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. TO ESTABLISH
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
IMPLEMENT FAIR AND CONSISTENT
EMISSIONS PROPHECIES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. CODIFYING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS SUGGESTED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS PROVIDE
CONSISTENT EMISSIONS CRITERIA
AND ON EACH CAMPUS. AND REQUIRE
REGULAR INTERNAL AUDITS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY MISSION STUFF
ARE PROPERLY TRAINED. I
RESPECTFULLY OFFER AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THAT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
HEARD OF IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I
SIXTY NINE KNOWS WHEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MOVING A FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE AB TWO
FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN STATE
PRISONS IF YOU'RE JONES ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. GET THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AB TWO FIVE FOUR WHICH REQUIRES
CDCR TO SCREEN EVERY PERSON
INCLUDING EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
PERSONAL PROPERTY PRIOR TO
ENTERING STATE PRISON
FACILITIES THIS BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE CDCR TO PROVIDE
EMMANUEL VALUATION REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ADDRESSING THE
EFFICIENCY OF CONTRABAND IN
PRODUCTION EFFORT AT ITS ADULT
FACILITIES WELL ALL PRISONERS
AT CDC ARE FACILITY A
THOROUGHLY SCREENED THROUGH A
VARIETY OF SEARCH TOOLS UPON
ENTRY CDC OUR EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO UNDER
GROSS DAILY SEARCHES LEAVING A
SIGNIFICANT SECURITY LOOPHOLE.
AMID THE PANDEMIC ALL PHYSICAL
VISITATIONS WERE HALTED AT CDC
ARE FACILITIES SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY DESPITE THIS
DEPARTMENT REPORT RECORDED AN
INCREASE AND OTHER CONTRABAND
AS INSTITUTIONS IT IS CLEAR THE
FLOOR CONTRABAND POSES A THREAT
TO THE SECURITY OF INCARCERATED
PERSONS PRISON STAFF AND THE
PUBLIC AB TWO FIVE FOUR WILL
HELP CREATE A SAFER ENVIRONMENT
FOR THOSE INVOLVED IN
CALIFORNIA'S CORRECTIONS SYSTEM
BY CLOSING THIS EXISTING
SECURITY LOOPHOLE. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF A. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELEVOTE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FOUR EIGHTY TO FIFTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
pMEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS AND
ACTIVATING THE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. OUR YOU ARE
ECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS LAST YEAR THIS
BODY TO THE PROFOUND STEP
FORWARD IN THE DRESSING
INSTITUTIONALIZED AND IMPLICIT
RACIAL BIAS IN OUR CRIMINAL
COURTS BY EMPOWERING DEFENDANTS
TO OBJECTIVE CHARGES
CONVICTIONS OR PUNISHMENTS
BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN BY CAST. BY
PASSING. THE CALIFORNIA RACIAL
JUSTICE ACT AB TWO FIFTY SIX IS
THE NEXT STEP TOWARDS EQUAL
JUSTICE ALLOWING THOSE TO PASS
JUDGMENTS RENDERED PRIOR TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ABILITY TO USE THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE ACT TO
PETITION THE COURT TO SEEK A
POTENTIAL REMEDY INVOLVING A
RACIAL BIAS IN THEIR CASE.
MAKING THE ACT AVAILABLE TO ALL
IS NOT ONLY THE MORAL THING TO
DO. BUT IT IS ALSO ROOTED IN
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
SEEN SOME OF THE WORST RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN TERMS OF
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS AND
SENTENCES IN THE COUNTRY. IN
FACT JUST LAST WEEK THE
COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE RECOMMENDED
RETROACTIVE APPLICATION OF THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT. AB TWO
FIFTY SIX IS THE RACIAL JUSTICE
OUT FOR ALL THAT PROVIDES THAT
MECHANISM FOR A COURSE TO
RECKON WITH PAST INJUSTICES FOR
THOSE THAT CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
RACISM PAINTED THEIR TRIAL.
THOSE WITH PRIOR RACIALLY
BIASED CONVICTIONS AND
SENTENCES DESERVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW AND THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE RECOGNITION OF HOW
UNUSUALLY DIFFICULT IT'S BEEN
FOR CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS. TO
PROVE RACIAL BIAS WAS A FACTOR
IN THEIR CASE. RECENT
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN TO
ADDRESS WORKLOAD CONCERNS FOR
THE COURTS BY SETTING A
DIGESTIVE BASIN FOR THOSE ABLE
TO PETITION THE COURT FOR
RETROACTIVE RELIEF. USING THE
RACIAL JUSTICE ACT. WE'VE ALSO
BEEN WORKING WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL SAYS THE ARTS
IMPLEMENTATION AND MAYBE TWO
FIFTY SIX REFLECTS TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES. ALEX
THE RACIAL JUSTICE ACT FOR ALL
ANSWERS A SIMPLE QUESTION. IF
PROHIBITING RACISM IN OUR
COURTS AND PROVIDING A PERSON A
MEANS TO REMEDY RACIAL BIAS IN
THEIR CASE IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO GOING FORWARD. IT SHOULD-BE THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE
JUDGMENT WAS RENDERED. THANK
YOU INNER OF RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWO FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF THE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLADEGA HIGHS FORTY TWO
KNOWS NINETEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY FIVE EIGHTY THREE OH FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN ACTIVATING
THE VETERANS MAIENSCHEIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MATTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THREE OH FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
THE SPECIFIED STATE AGENCY TO
INCLUDE AFTER NEXT SCHEDULED
UPDATE. QUESTIONS ON ANY INTAKE
FORMER APPLICATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN APPLICANT IS
AFFILIATED WITH UNITED STATES
ARMED FORCES. STATEMENT
NOTIFIED OF ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE AND FEDERAL VETERANS
BENEFITS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR MAIENSCHEIN
SINGH HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. YOU DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY RESERVE A
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE FORTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME WIGGLE
THREE FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG AND OTHERS AND I
PLAYED IN THE PUBLIC RECORDS
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR.
CHICAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF.
UNEVENNESS BIGGER IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT AB THREE
FOR THREE IN OUR CURRENT
PROCESS STATE AGENCIES CAN DENY
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST KNOWING THAT THERE IS
NO APPEALS OTHER THAN TO SUE
THE AGENCY IN COURT WHICH IS
NOT FEASIBLE AND TOO COSTLY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AB THREE
FOUR THREE ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING AN
OMBUDSPERSON WHO CAN REVIEW THE
DENIED PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST AND SERVE AS AN
INDEPENDENT REFEREE TO DECIDE
IF THE STATE AGENCY HAD
LEGITIMATE GROUNDS FOR DENYING
THE REQUEST. STATE AGENCIES
SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO FREELY
DENIED PUBLIC RECORDS REQUESTS
AND ROB THE PUBLIC OF
INFORMATION CRUCIAL TO HOLDING
THEIR GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE AB
THREE FOUR THREE CORRECT SAYS
THE BALL IN THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT PROCESS. GOVERNMENT MUST
WORK FOR THE PEOPLE THIS
MEASURE EMPOWERS THE PUBLIC BY
GIVING THEM ACCESS TO
INFORMATION THEY DESERVE
TRANSPARENCY FAIRNESS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN GOVERNMENT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES THE CHAIR OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIR THE CAN ABILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
FOR CO AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WITH ME ERIC. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU SEEING AND
HEARING THERE FOR THE DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY THREE NOTES
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE ACTION AND EXPUNGE
THE RECORD WERE BY ITEM ONE OH
THREE EIGHTY ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE RODRIGUEZ WAS READ A
THIRD TIME URGENCY CLAUSE
ADOPTED AND PASSED TODAY. AND
WE'RE GONNA ITEM ONE TWELVE AB
TWELVE AWAITING AN ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIXTEEN WERE READ A THIRD TIME
AND PASSED TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. OKAY AB MEMBERS THIS
REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE THIS
RACE NEWS MR GABRIEL SECONDS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DESIRE TO VOTE BOTH MASS
TRANSCANADA ARE ASKING FOR AN
I. RICH BOTH MR S. AND MISTER
FLORA ARE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE THE FIRST TIME THAT'S
HAPPENED BUT I CAN PRESIDING.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESERTED ROAD
AGAIN MISS REYES AND MR FLOOR
ARE BOTH ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE I. SEVENTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THAT MOTION CARRIES.
WE'RE
GONNA FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AN
ACCOLADE IN HOUSING. ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. TODAY I RE RICE IS
PRESENT AB THREE SIXTY TO. A
SHELTER OPERATORS
ACCOUNTABILITY BILL. AB THREE
SIXTY TWO ENSURES A MINIMUM
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS ARE
FOLLOWED BY SHELTER OPERATORS
AND THAT ALL SHELTER RESIDENTS
ARE TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. A YEAR LONG
INVESTIGATION BY THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTARIAN LIBERTIES
UNION OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOUND SEVERE DEFICITS AMONG
VARIOUS EMERGENCY SHELTERS IN
ORANGE COUNTY WITH REPORTS OF
ALLEGED SEXUAL ABUSE
OVERCROWDING UNHEALTHY
CONDITIONS AND NEGLECT OF
RESIDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
MENTAL ILLNESS. THIS
INVESTIGATION ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THE UNSANITARY CONDITIONS IN
THE SHELTERS INCLUDING
WIDESPREAD RODENT DID BED BUG
INVENT INFESTATIONS EXTREME
TEMPERATURES BROKEN SHOWERS AND
TOILETS. THE NEED FOR
ENFORCEABLE HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR HOMELESS SHELTERS
IS URGENT ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE VULNERABILITY
OF HOMELESS SHELTER RESIDENTS
MANY OF WHOM ARE ADULTS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS HEALTH
CONDITIONS. EVEN THOUGH
SHELTERS WERE NEVER INTENDED TO
SERVE AS LONG TERM HOUSING THE
REALITY IS AND TELL THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS ADDRESSED MANY OF THE
SHELTERS WILL SERVE AS THE
PRIMARY RESIDENCE FOR
UNSHELTERED CALIFORNIANS. AS
OUR STATE CONTINUES TO FACE A
GROWING HOMELESS CRISIS THIS
BILL IS THE FIRST STEP IN
CORRECTING SOME OF THE ISSUES
AT THESE SHELTERS THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
CLARK SILVA. SEEING AND HEARING
THERE FOR DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FIVE NO SIXTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS I
AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB TWO
NINETY TO THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERVE A.
YEAH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A THIRD OF A CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY ONE NEWS TWENTY
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES. WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE AROUND IN FILE ORDER
AND JUMP TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
NINE. AND AB FORTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD AND OTHERS AN ACCURATE IN
THE COMMUNICATIONS IF YOU'RE
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SINCE
TAKING OFFICE COMMONSENSE
EXPANSION OF RURAL BROADBAND
ACCESS HAS BEEN A PRIORITY OF
MINE. THE CONCEPT OF DIG ONCE
IS NOT A NEW POLICY AREA FOR ME
I AM BRINGING THIS CONCEPT
BEFORE YOU AGAIN BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION OR STATE AGENCIES
ARE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THESE GOLDEN OPPORTUNITIES.
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THE MAY REVISED
TO MAKE CRITICAL AND VER-
OVERDUE UPGRADES TO OUR STATE'S
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER WOULD.
SEEING HEARING OVER THERE
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. BURKE
TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SIXTY TWO NEW ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL NOW
TAKE AB. THAT OBJECTION THE
BILL'S THE MINORITY LEADERS
BILLS SO MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
FORTY FOUR. AB TWELVE FOURTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AND
OTHERS AN ACCURATE IN AMERICA
IT'S WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWELVE FOURTEEN WILL
MAKE MAKES JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE HEALTH COVERAGE DURING
THE THIRTY DAYS PRIOR TO
RELEASE. FROM A CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY THIS PROVIDES
UNINTERRUPTED HEALTH COVERAGE
TO ENSURE IGH RISK HIGH NEED
JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATIONS
WILL RECEIVE MUCH NEEDED CARE
AS THEY TRANSITION BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES. BUT HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I HEARD AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALENT THAT I SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS
YOU'RE THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO WITH
SIXTY FIVE AB SIX NINETY TO THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON AND OTHERS CONNECT WITH
THE FLOOD MANAGEMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION. FATHER AND YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN
AB SIX NINE TWO SIX TO
REINFORCE THE LABEL FOR DAM
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT WATER
STORAGE FLOOD CONTROL AND
RECREATIONAL FACILITY. THAT A
SERVICE SAN DIEGO COUNTY FOR
GENERATIONS BY PROVIDING A FIVE
YEAR EXTENSION OF THE GRANT
FUND LIQUIDATION DEADLINE. FOR
THE EXPENDITURE OF PROP ONE
EIGHTY FUNDS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW SUFFICIENT TIME FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF A REPLACEMENT
THEM FOR LIKE WILFORD I REGION
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF THE
PARK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK UP TO FILE
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORIDA CLEANING BUSINESS
DISTRICT ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB EIGHT THIRTY SERVES AS THE
BNP- COMMITTEE ON THE MOST BILL
HAS RECEIVED EMAILS AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS BOTH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOWEVER
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES NOW OVER TO FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY AB TEN TWENTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE TEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR AN
ACCOLADE IN THE CONTRACTORS IF
YOU'RE FOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
TWENTY THREE WITHIN THAT THE
PENALTY OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER DAY GIVE THE PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACTOR FAILED TO SUBMIT
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS. THIS BILL SIMPLY
GIVE THE LABOR COMMISSION THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE EXISTING
LAW. WE HAVE RECENTLY TAKEN
MINISTER BY THE FOURTEEN DAY
GRACE PERIOD TO CONTRACTORS TO
ABIDE BY THESE MONTHLY
REQUIREMENTS EXPECTS LAST RIVAL.
THEME HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
A- HOME MEMBERS VOTED EITHER TO
VOTE.ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DIVERTIDA. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
NINE NOTE HERE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING BACK IN FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
ONE EIGHTY THREE SIXTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
THREE SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE IN THE FALL SO
YEARS MAYES RUBIO YOU ARE NOW
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT TODAY ON ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SIXTY SIX AN AXE APART IN
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALFORNIA WHO
ARE EXPECTING. RESEARCH HAS
FOUND THAT SEXUAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES AMONG OUR STATE'S
FOSTER YOUTH IS EXTREMELY
CONCERNING AND WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO SUPPORT THIS
POPULATION. AB THREE SIXTY SIX
WILL HELP PREVENT SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
UNINTENDED PREGNANCY IMPORTANT
PRENATAL AND OTHER HEALTH
OUTCOMES EXPERIENCE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH AND
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS THE BILL
HAS A WIDE COALITION OF SUPPORT
HAS RECEIVED ZERO KNOWN BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO VOTES AND HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A VERITABLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELEVOTE ICE
ANYONE KNOWS HERE THAT MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY TWO AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN THIRTY WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN BILLS ARE
MISTER EQUITY WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON- INSPIRED BY
SCOTLAND THAT MADE ME ACCESS TO
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS ARE RIGHT
AND ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
AVAILABLE AND ALL PUBLIC
SETTINGS. AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT WE HAVE MISTER
PRODUCTS IN BATHROOMS OF UP
KßT TWELVE I'M ORRY SIXTY
FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAL
STATE UNIVERSITIES AND
RECOMMENDS THAT THE UC'S ALSO
DO THE SAME I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER C. S.
SENIOR HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A. ON MEMBERS
VOTED AMERICA. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TELL ME THAT I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
A VIOLATE ONE SEVENTY THREE
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FOUR AB THREE NINETY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE APPROVAL AND
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE IN THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION IF YOU GET
IT WHILE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE
MINUTEMEN SPEAKER AB THREE
NINETY ONE ENHANCES OUR
POLLINATOR HABITATS ON WORKING
LANDS TO HELP SUSTAIN OUR FOOD
SUPPLY AN ECO SYSTEM. RIGHT NOW
OUR STATE POLLINATOR.
POLLINATORS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
BRINGING US ONE OUT OF EVERY
THREE BITES OF FOOD WE EACH
TAKE. THERE VITAL. INTERACTIONS
ALLOWS US TO TRANSFER OUR
GENERIC MATERIALS ESSENTIALS
AND REPRODUCTIONS FOR MANY OF
OUR PLANTS THAT PRODUCE FRUITS
VEGETABLES NUTS AND OILS AND
FIBERS. BUT. WORKING LANDS
OFFERED A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE OUR BIO
DIVERSITY AND CLIMATE GOALS
WELL ENHANCING OUR OUR
AGRICULTURAL OUTPUT I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
VENTURA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS BOTH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL COLUSA ROLAND TALLIED AT
I. SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WIENER FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR OH ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND OTHER
PHONETICALLY THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE HERE TO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
FOUR ONE WOULD ADDRESS LANGUAGE
ACCESS AT EDT. SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS PRIMARILY SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN HIT THE
HARDEST DURING THIS PANDEMIC IN
RECESSION ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO WORK IN SECTORS THAT HAVE
BEEN SHUT DOWN AND DESPERATELY
NEEDED TO WORK. ALL OF OUR
OFFICES KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS WERE
FLUENT IN ENGLISH TO NAVIGATE
ET. BUT IT'S NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT
PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT BY THE
GOVERNOR'S EDT STRIKE FORCE.
THE BRRIERS THAT EDT PRESENTS
FOR LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKERS
WORK QUOTE INSURMOUNTABLE. THIS
BILL WOULD ALLEVIATE THOSE
BURDENS BY PROVIDING EXPANDED
TRANSLATION OF CRITICAL
DOCUMENTS. INCREASING
MULTILINGUAL PHONE LINES.
REQUIRING EDT TO IDENTIFY A
CLAIMANT'S LANGUAGE NEEDS. AND
IDENTIFYING AND ESTABLISHING A
REVIEW PROCESS TO MONITOR
PROGRESS IN THIS AREA. I
APPRECIATE THE TWENTY THREE
BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
CHIU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
TO THIRTY VOTE. BURKE WILL
BOOST THE ROLE AND HOW IT AYE
SEVENTY FIVE NEWS HERE THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE WILL PASS THE
ROUTINE OF FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SIX MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE FOR YOU TEAM BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUT THERE AS AN
ACTIVITY TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
I GUESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT A. B.
FOR EIGHTEEN EARLIER THIS YEAR
I WAS DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAD DE FUNDED AND
IMPORTANT GRANT PROGRAM THAT
HELPS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PREPARE
FOR AND MITIGATE THE IMPACT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
THE VANS AND OTHER EMERGENCY
POWER OUTAGES. IT'S BECAUSE OF
THIS THAT I INTRODUCED ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR ONE EIGHT A MEASURE
THAT WILL FORMALLY CODIFY AND
PROTECT THIS GRANT PROGRAM
ALLOWING CAL- YES TO DISPERSE
FUNDS TO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
PS PS EVENTS. AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES. TODAY THERE CAN BE
NO QUESTION AS TO HOW
DEVASTATING THE LOSS OF POWER
CAN BE TO HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES. NOW MORE THAN EVER
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES RELY ON A
RELIABLE SOURCE OF ENERGY TO
MAKE A LIVING. TO GO TO SCHOOL
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. AND
ACCESS ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
BECAUSE THE STATE FREQUENTLY
EXPERIENCES OVERWHELMING
DISASTERS UNPLANNED EMERGENCY
POWER OUTAGES HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME THE NEW
NORMAL. FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THE MAJORITY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS. AB FOUR EIGHTEEN
IS A NECESSARY STEP AND HELPING
TO ENSURE THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED TO KEEP ESSENTIAL SERVICES
RUNNING DURING POWER OUTAGES
AND PS PS EVENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SEEN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A THIRD OF A. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF A. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT I SEVENTIES YOU KNOW ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT AB FOUR
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BEFORE TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD WARD
INOCULATING THE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SURE WHERE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A BEFORE TWENTY ONE
WITH BETTER EQUALIZE FUNDING
FOR NON CREDIT CAREER
DEVELOPMENT AND CAUGHT COLLEGE
PREPARATION COURSES BY
AUTHORIZING THE ATTENDANCE OF
THOSE COURSES TO BE TAKEN
ACCORDING TO A CENSUS DATE.
RATHER THAN ON POSITIVE
ATTENDANCE THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE COLLEGES WITH A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO DEVELOP
AND OFFER THESE EFFECTIVE SHORT
TERM VOCATIONAL COURSES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND SPELL. THANK YOU
MISTER WARREN THING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES- IN A FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MARIA'S AND OTHERS
AND I BELIEVE IN THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION THREATS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE PRESENT AB
FOUR SIX NINE WHICH REQUIRES
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
ENSURE ALL HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
COMPLETE THE PAST FOUR OR DREAM
ACT UP OCCASION FOR FINANCIAL
AID BEFORE GRADUATING. IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS ALONE HALF A
MILLION HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS IN
CALIFORNIA DID NOT COMPLETE THE
THEFTS ARE OR CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT APPLICATION LEAVING AN
ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
AND FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID ON
THE TABLE. MANY STUDENTS DO NOT
COMPLETE THESE APPLICATIONS
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE
INELIGIBLE OR THEY LACK THE
SUPPORT IN THE PROCESS. AB FOUR
SIX NINE INSURERS ALL STUDENTS
GET THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
SUBMIT CRITICAL FORMS FOR
FINANCIAL AID I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
MISS S. AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY VERY
VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES
WE KNOW FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE CLERK
OVER THE SUMMER BEFORE SEVENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MINUTES
SECURING COLLEAGUES I WANT TO
THANK MY JOIN AUTHOR FROM
GRIFFIN FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS ISSUE AS WELL AS THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
STAFF TO ENSURE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERITIV IS. ALL
MEMBERS THAT HE DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY VERY VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL
YOU THAT I SEVENTY ONE NEWS
HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY ONE WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS
AND I BELIEVE IN THE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN THEIR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS WITH REGARD
TO THE USE OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT. IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S LED THE NATION IN
THE AMOUNT OF WEAPONRY SECURED
BY THE MILITARY FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVING HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THIS
PAST YEAR CALIFORNIANS WERE
SURPRISED TO SEE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT IN ACTION DURING
PEACEFUL PROTESTS TEAR GAS
SPRAYED FOR MILITARY GRENADE
LAUNCHERS RUBBER BULLETS SHOT
FROM ARMORED VEHICLES THIS BILL
CALLS FOR CITIES OR LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS TO WORK WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
ESTABLISH MILITARY EQUIPMENT
POLICIES WHEN IT COMES TO
PROCUREMENT AND USE NOTHING
THIS BILL WOULD RESTRICT ANY
COMMUNITY OR POLICE DEPARTMENT
FROM CARRYING ANY MILITARY
EQUIPMENT THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC KNOWS WHEN
MILITARY EQUIPMENT IS BEING
USED ESPECIALLY WHEN PUBLIC
DOLLARS ARE AT STAKE IN WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU MR CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
OKAY. MISTER SARATOGA. DURING
THE LAST. OKAY HERE TO
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISS BAKER
MEMBERS OF THIS FAMILY I STUNT
FORTUNATELY STAND IN OPPOSITION
TO AB FORTY ONE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT COLLEAGUES IS
SOMETHING THAT COUNTLESS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE USE AN EMPLOYEE. JUST
LAST MONTH I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF BEING SHOWN SOME SURPLUS
EQUIPMENT OVER CAL FIRE THAT
THEY USED TO IMPROVE OUR
AVIATION STRENGTH IN FIGHTING
WIRELESS WILDFIRES. WHICH USED
TO OBTAIN AND USE THESE TOOLS
AND EQUIPMENT FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS BUT PRIMARILY DUE TO
THEIR COSTS COMPARED TO THE
MARKET. AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
FOR SMALLER DEPARTMENTS. AND
ALSO THE PREVAILING TO PARTY
NEEDS FOR A REPAIRS. AS WE KEEP
SHRINKING THE BUDGETS AN
RESOURCES OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT BODIES. WE ASK THEM
TO DO MORE WITH LESS.
DEPARTMENTS OFTEN HAVE MERE
HOURS TO RESPOND TO ITEMS GOING
UP FOR AUCTION OTHERWISE THE
ITEMS GO TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE NATION WHO JUMPED
FASTER. AB FOUR EIGHTY ONE
SIMPLY GOES TOO FAR AND RAISE
THE BAR TOO HIGH FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT BODIES TO
EFFICIENTLY ACQUIRED THESE
RESOURCES LET ALONE CONTINUE
THEIR USE. GOVERNING BODIES ARE
ALREADY HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE METHODS AND OVERALL IMAGE
OF THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTMENTS TO WHICH IS BILL
TRIES TO AMPLIFY. THEY ALSO
PROUDLY DISPLAYED THESE ITEMS
AND MANY OF THEIR COMMUNITY
EVENTS FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE.
SO IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SARATOGA'S THREE WACKY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES. HELLO
IN THIS LATE HOUR NOT REALLY- I
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY
ONE WHICHEVER WAY UNDERCUTS
LOCAL CONTROL. THIS BILL AIMS
TO RESTRICT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM PURCHASING EQUIPMENT THEY
FEEL IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITY. THAT IS THE
JOB OF LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
APPROVE BUDGETS FOR THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS. HOW
THE DEPARTMENT. HEADS SPEND THE
BUDGETED REVENUES ARE BASED ON
THEIR NEEDS TO PROVIDE THE
COMMUNITY WITH THE BEST SERVICE
POSSIBLE. LOCAL CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO
MAYORS VOTERS. RESPECTIVELY AND
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. BUT SHE
CONTINUED TO BE ALLOWED TO MAKE
DECISIONS IN THE BEST INTEREST.
OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
IF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
DISAGREE. WHAT THE WAY THE
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING SERVED
THERE ARE ELECTORAL REMEDIES.
CALIFORNIA IS A HUGE STATE IN A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
OFTEN DOES NOT WORK WHICH IS
WHY THE CONCEPT OF LOCAL
CONTROL IS SPELLED OUT IN THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTION. THIS
PROVISION IS BASED ON THE
PRINCIPLE THAT THE CITY. RATHER
THAN THE STATE. IS IN THE BEST
POSITION TO KNOW WHAT OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND HOW TO
SATISFY THOSE NEEDS TO LAST FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER MACINNES AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED HI DOUG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MAN
SPEAKER. I RISE TONIGHT JUST
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THE SIMILAR
SITUATION IN MY COMMUNITY AND I
SUPPORT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
BILL THEN YOU MIGHT ASK WHAT.
THIS IS DOING SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY IPORTANT THAT MY
COMMUNITIES DIDN'T DO IT ONE
TIME AND I THINK IT REALLY
ADDED SOME- STRESS AND DIGRESS
WITH THE- POLICE FORCE. I THINK
THIS BILL AND I KNOW THIS BILL
TAKES NECESSARY STEPS TO
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY AND
REDUCE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
MILITARIZED FORCES IN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD A MISTER CHUI THINK IF
WE WOULD HAVE THIS TOGETHER A
COUPLE YEARS AGO IT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN SOME OF THE. STRESS OFF
MY COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER
BENNETT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE
AS A FORMER LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
TWENTY YEARS ON THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
AND I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT. THERE WERE TIMES WHEN
I'VE BEEN STUNNED AS I SAW
LOOKED AROUND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT SOME OF THE-
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT WAS
PURCHASED. IN THE FACT THAT
LOCAL ELECTED STOOD NOT AND
WERE NOT AWARE OF WHAT WAS
BEING PURCHASED- IN THEIR
DEPARTMENTS. AND SO I.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR COMING
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL. BECAUSE
IT'S ESSENTIALLY JUST REQUIRES
THAT THE LOCAL OFFICIALS BE
INFORMED AND APPROVE OF- THE
PURCHASE OF THIS MILITARY
EQUIPMENT. IT IS SORT OF THE
EPITOME OF LOCAL CONTROL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER MR
CHIU. CHECK CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AMONG OUR
CALLING SOMEONE ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF POINTS OF AND REYES.
FIRST OF ALL- IT IS TRUE THAT
AN EARLIER VERSION OF THE BILL-
HAD A BIT OF A LONGER APPROVAL
PROCESS BY WHICH WE MOVE FOR.
APPRECIATE THE WORK WE'VE DONE
WITH OUR CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS TO INCLUDE AMENDMENTS TO
STREAMLINE THE OVERSIGHT TO
MAKE THE APPROVAL A ONE TIME
ANNUAL PROCESS SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WORKING WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS CAN ANTICIPATE WHAT
MIGHT COME UP SO THAT WE'RE NOT
STUCK IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT WISHES TO
PROCURE SOMETHING QUICKLY AT
THE LAST MOMENT. SECONDLY THIS
IS A BILL THAT IS ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL THIS IS SAYING THAT. AS
LONG AS A LOCAL JURISDICTION IS
WORKING WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN DETERMINING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH
EQUIPMENT WOULD BE PROCURED OR
USED- ANY. POLICE DEPARTMENT
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH WHATEVER
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SO WE'RE
SIMPLY SAYING THAT AS LONG AS
THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
THE CITY COUNCIL OR LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARD. A POLICE
DEPARTMENT CAN MOVE FORWARD
ULTIMATELY THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
HOW WE REBUILD COMMUNITY TRUST
I KNOW FOR ALL OF US WHO'VE
WORKED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. FOR US. TO
BUILD A COMMUNITY TRUST BETWEEN
OUR- LOCAL ON A- AS WELL AS
WITH OUR CAN. THIS IS ABOUT AND
TRY. AND ACCOUNT. AND A RESPECT
ASK FOR YOUR I. KIRKER OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THIRD OF. ALL
MEMBERS THAT DESERVE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF THE- CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
THE VOTE IS FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE MOVING A
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR. AB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO AEROSPACE.
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS MY
THIRD ATTEMPT I THINK IT'S MY
THIRD MAYBE MY FOURTH ATTEMPT
TO TRY TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE COMMISSION. DID YOU
KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY IS BIGGER
THAN THEIR ENTERTAINMENT AND
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES
COMBINED AS MEASURED BY GDP.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MAJOR
AEROSPACE COMPANIES LIKE SPACEX
BOEING NORTHROP GRUMMAN. AS
WELL AS A VAST NETWORK OF
SMALLER COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
THE INDUSTRY'S SUPPLY CHAIN
HOWEVER OTHER STATES LIKE TEXAS
AND FLORIDA ARE ALWAYS TRYING
TO POACH AND LEARN THE
COMPANIES. AND JOBS TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY WE NEED
THIS CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THEIR VOTE
CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES- IN A
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISRDER
TREATMENT IS RUNNING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEHAVIORAL OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS SMOKE
CIGARETTES AT MORE THAN TWICE
THE RATE OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. NO MORE LIKELY TO
DIE FROM TOBACCO RELATED
ILLNESS THAN FROM THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITION
THAT BRINGS THEM TO TREATMENT.
SMOKING IS ASSOCIATED WITH
GREATER ODDS OF RELAPSE AND THE
CDC RECOMMENDS THE INTEGRATION
OF TOBACCO TREATMENT. AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. SB FIVE
FORTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE ALL
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
ASSESS PATIENTS. SMOKING STATUS
AND OFFER OR REFER A PATIENT TO
TOBACCO TREATMENT. A CRITICAL
STEP TO REDUCING THE SEVERE
DISPARITY OF TOBACCO USE AMONG
THIS POPULATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT YOU DESERVE IT. OF
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
THE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND OTHERS AND I
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SANTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FIVE SEVENTY WOULD
ALLOW ADULTS CHILDREN THE OTHER
DEPENDENT PARENTS AD STEP
PARENTS. PUT IN PLACE SPONSORED
HEALTH PLAN THIS BILL WOULD
SAVE MONEY ON HEALTHCARE COSTS
AND PROVIDE GREAT OPTION FOR
MIX THAT IS FAMILIES. INCLUDING
A DOCUMENTED ALL SORT ELIGIBLE
FOR COVERAGE UNDER KELLER
CALIFORNIA. RECENT
APPROPRIATION AMENDMENTS EVERY
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER OF THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELEVOTE FORTY NINE NEWS
TWELVE. MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY SIX NO MOVIE FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT TO PASS
ORIGINAL FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS INCLUDING THE PEOPLE
HEALTH MISTER DONNA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER EMPLOYEES RESENT EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX TO SUPPORT
SCHOOL BASED. HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. EVEN PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC THE INCIDENCE OF
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WAS
INCREASING AT AN ALARMING RATE
AND THE PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
EXACERBATED THE SITUATION.
SCHOOLS ARE WELL POSITIONED TO
MEET THE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF STUDENTS BUT
THEY LACK THE RESOURCES TO DO
SO EFFECTIVELY. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROJECT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
CHOOSE EXPERT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAMS. WHO WILL
PROVIDE INTENSIVE SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE TO SELECTED LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO DEVELOP
SUCH PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. I S. RIVAL. THANK YOU MR
O'DONNELL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS VERY VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY SIX FOURTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACCLIMATE TO
WILDLIFE HABITAT IF
AGUIAR-CURRY ARE RECOGNIZED
MILA GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. SB
SIX FOURTEEN IS A RESOURCE
GENERATING CONSERVATION MEASURE
THAT WILL COMPLEMENT OUR
STATEWIDE GOALS FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY AND PROTECTION OF OUR
WATER FELL SPECIES THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION AND
ENJOYS WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FROM
A DIVERSE COALITION OF
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS AND
PRIVATE LANDOWNER AGRICULTURAL
REPRESENTATIVES AND SPORTSMEN'S
GROUPS I ASK FOR YOUR IBM THANK
YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IT. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THEIR. BURKE WILL COLUSA ROLAND
TALLY THOSE I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS
TO THE MEASURE PASSES. WHEN A
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY AB SIX
NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AND
OTHERS AND ACT WITHIN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB
SIX ONE NINE WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO CREATE PLANS FOR
MANAGING THE FAX OF WILDFIRE
SMOKE ON VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
OUR STATE CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES WHICH HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE THREAT OF
DANGEROUS AIR QUALITY TELLING
HEALTH. THIS BILL WILL MITIGATE
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRES ON LONG
HEALTH THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND RESERVE HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALITHA I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY ONE WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM. ONE
NINETY TWO MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY THREE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY PER GIPSON AND
ACCORDING TO CEMETERIES I
FORGET CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL- SIX
FIFTY ONE WHICH SEEKS TO CREATE
A PROCESS TO ENSURE. THAT
CEMETERY TAKE OVERS LAST
OWNERSHIP- CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR NEGLECT
ABANDONMENT AND FINANCIAL
MISCONDUCT MIGHT FEEL IS
CENTERED AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN AN EFFORT TO PREVENT
CEMETERIES FROM FALLING INTO
DISREPAIR ONE SUCH CEMETERY OF
FACES INSOLVENCY THAT
CEMETERIES WOODLAWN MEMORIAL-
CEMETERY IN THE CITY OF COMPTON
WHICH I PROBABLY REPRESENT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A TAKE A TOOK
CARE TAKER WHO CHOOSES TO
SURRENDER. THEIR LICENSE ALSO
REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM A FROM
LIABILITY WHICH THEN FORCES
CEMETERY'S GROUNDS TO BE
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN THIS MEANS
THAT FAMILIES ARE LEFT WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THEIR DECEASED LOVED
ONES FOR MONTHS AND SOMETIMES
EVEN YEARS. YOU MAY FIND IT
VERY INTERESTING THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA. CEMETERY FUNERAL
BUREAU. REPORTED SHOWING THAT
OVER A HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
PUBLICLY OWNED CEMETERIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
EVENTUALLY FACE INSOLVENCY DUE
TO INSUFFICIENT E. R. C. F.
INCOME. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY
ONE WILL CORRECT THAT AND CLOSE
A LOOPHOLE AND CREATE A PROCESS
TO WHOLE CEMETERY OWNERS
ACCOUNTABLE INCREASED ENDOWMENT
INVESTMENT LEVELS AND WHOLE
COUNTIES. RESPONSIBLE AS A
TEMPORARY MANAGER AFTER AS A
LAST RESORT THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED A LOT OF GREAT SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE
ON ASSEMBLY BILL- SIX FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER GOOD
SENSE SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY SEVEN
NEWS HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
FOUR EIGHTY SIX FIFTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS AND ACCORDING TO
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND A CLEAR
OF THE YEARS OF CEDAR AFFECT
THE COMMUNITY THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBER I PRESENT AB SIX
FIFTY FOUR WHICH IS A TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP TO MY PREVIOUS MEASURE
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
SET THE STANDARDS TO INSURE OUR
WORKERS WERE PROPERLY NOTIFIED
WHEN THEY WERE EXPOSED TO
COVERT NINETEEN IN THE
WORKPLACE THIS BILL SIMPLY KEEP
THE PROMISES THAT WE MADE TO
THE HEALTH. HEALTH CARE
ADVOCATES IN ORDER TO ALLEVIATE
THEM FROM THE BURDEN OF DOUBLE
REPORTING THE URGENCY CLAUSE IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE WE DO NOT
CONTINUE TO BURDEN OUR HEALTH
CARE ADVOCATES WITH THIS DOUBLE
REPORTING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH USER
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT UP NO THE CLERK WILL NT
CLOSE THE ROLE. THIS IS A FIFTY
FOUR. VOEPEL. ALL THESE. THIS
WAS ENOUGH DINNER BREAK OFF HER
FIRST DESIRE TO VOTE. TWO
THIRDS. THIS IS A FIFTY FOUR
VOEPEL ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THERE TO VOTE. THIS
REQUIRES.
THIRTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS IS VERY VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL
MEMBERS SAID THERE ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR.
MITHRAS
MOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS. I KNOW
THAT THIS IS NOT GONNA BE
WELCOME BY MR BLOOM BUT WE WILL
BE TAKING A DINNER BREAK AND
WE'LL BE BACK AT SIX FIFTEEN.
SO THAT WE CAN RETURN TO
BUSINESS AND GET OVER THE
SENATE EVENING- BEFORE YOU
LEAVE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO A
VOTE CHANGE AFTER A RECESS YOU
MAY COME UP AND QUICKLY DO YOU
HAVE A CHANGE FROM THE DíAS.
WE WILL NOW RECESS.
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAYS DAVIES MAKES A
CHANGE TO AB TWO ONE FIVE FROM
AYE TO OPPOSE THANK YOU. PRO
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTEEN- TO
KNOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN VOTE CHANGE AB TWO
ONE FIVE I TO NOT VOTING. VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN SOME PEOPLE TO
FIFTEEN ODD TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK SILVA VOTE
CHANGE AB FORTY EIGHT I DO NOT
VOTING. TO CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUICK SILVA ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
EIGHT- TO NOT VOTING. PATTERSON
FILE FORTY TWO AB ONE OH FIVE I
DO NOT VOTING. BURKE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FIVE- TO
NOT VOTING.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE
RESUMING SESSION PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR. SO WE MAY TAKE UP
ITEMS. PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
THE STATE OF.
MEMBERS IT IS NOW
SIX THIRTY PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY CONTINUE TAKING
UP THE BUSINESS. RIGHT AS MR
FRAZIER SAYS WE'RE GONNA CRANK
IT OUT. PLEASE MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME. AVERAGE
PLEASE RETURN THE FLOOR SO WE
MAY TAKE UP ITEMS. ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
MEMBERS
WE ARE TAKING UP ITEMS.
WHEN AB
EIGHT NINE EIGHT NINE I TO KNOW.
BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY
NINE- TO KNOW. MEMBERS WE ARE
BACK ON THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. IN FILE ORDER
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
FIVE. MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING
VOTES ON THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME
PLEASE RETURN MR GARCIA. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE.
AB. SIX SIX FIVE. THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AN ACT RELATING
TO RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE ELDERLY THANK YOU MR
GARCIA YOU MAILED IT MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB SIX
SIX FIVE WOULD BE MY FIRST
ATTEMPT. IN ESTABLISHING A
REQUIREMENT FOR RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR ELDERLY
WITH EXISTING INTERNET SERVICES
TO MAKE AVAILABLE AT LEAST ONE
INTERNET ACCESS TOOL TO ENABLE
RESIDENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN
VIRTUAL VISITS MEETINGS AND
OTHER SPECIFY A CRITERIAS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CSE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROOM TIE THAT
I FIFTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ASCERTAIN ON FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND
AGGRAVATED A HAZARDOUS WASTE DR
QUIRKY EMAIL. THANK YOU SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS. TODAY MY PLEASED TO
PRESENT A. B. SEVEN OH SEVEN
WHICH WILL RE WRITE THE MERCURY
THERMOSTAT COLLECTION ACT.
MERCURY CONTAINING THERMOSTATS
HAVE NOT BEEN SOLD IN THE STATE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX MANY
BUILDINGS AND HOMES STILL
CONTAIN THEM AND THEN THOSE
THERMOSTATS NEED TO BE
COLLECTED MANAGED. MERCURY
THERMOSTAT COLLECTION ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT PROVIDED THE
STATUTORY PLAN OF ACTION FOR
COLLECTING THESE THERMOSTATS
HOWEVER WE HAVE FAILED TO
COLLECT. THERMOSTATS AND-
AUTOMATE THE DESIGNATED
COLLECTION TARGETS A. B. SEVEN
OH SEVEN REPRESENTS MORE THAN A
YEAR CONVERSATIONS. WITH THE
THERMOSTAT MANUFACTURERS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY TO RE
WRITE THE COLLECTION PROGRAM IN
GARNER GREATER SUCCESS WITH
MERCURY THERMOSTAT COLLECTION.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION I ASK
THE ARRIVAL. THANK YOU DR WORK
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLUB
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL.
TYLER NICE FORTY SIX NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS
WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FIGHT A LOT FILE ITEM TO A ONE
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM TO- TO.
I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY EIGHT AND ONE NINETY
NINE AS WELL. PASS RETAIN A
FIVE TWO HUNDRED. WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP AND PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FELL INTO A THREE WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP. FILE ITEM TO-
FOR. AB SEVENTY NINE BY MR LOW
BURGLARY. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES. MISTER
LUCKY MALE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY NINE HELPS TO
ENSURE GREATER ACCESS TO
HEPATITIS GREETINGS I THINK THE
MEMBER FROM CARSON FOR HIS
AUTHORSHIP AND HELPING TO
CHAMPION THIS ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW MISTER GIBSON IN THE
REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR. FROM
CAMPBELL. FOR BRINGING FORTH AB
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE. MEMBERS
APPROXIMATE THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN THOUSAND ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE CHRONIC
HEPATITIS C. INFECTION. IF IN
FACT HEPATITIS C. CASES IS TWO
POINT NINE TIMES HIGHER IN
AFRICAN AMERICANS- IN THAT IN
THAT SAME RACIAL GROUP
HEPATITIS B. AND HEPATITIS C.
COMPLICATIONS. ACCOUNT FOR OVER
A THIRD OF THE LIVER TRANSPLANT
IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER
SCREENINGS AND TREATMENTS CAN
PREVENT MOST OF THE
COMPLICATIONS. AND ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS DISEASE AND ALSO WITH
A DEATH A. B. SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
IS NECESSARY FOR THE FIRST STEP
IN ADDRESSING HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
OUT AB SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU
MISS GIPSON. SEE ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL. VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OUT CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE TELEVOTE
I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THERE IS A FILE
OR FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE PASS
AND RETAIN. FILE ITEM TWO OH
SIX IS AB EIGHT OH EIGHT.
SUPPORT SUPPORT MR STONE
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
AWAIT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
FOSTER YOUTH. MR STONE EMAIL
BUT THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
SAID KIDS BOTH THE LINK WITH
THE DEPENDENCY OUT OF STATE.
WHEN THERE HAVE NOT BEEN
ADEQUATE TREATMENT OPTIONS FOR
THEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA. DSS
HAD TO DECERTIFY ALL OF THOSE
OUT OF STATE FACILITIES LAST
WINTER AND LAST FALL BRINGING
ALL THOSE KIDS BACK WHAT EIGHT
AWAIT DOES. IS TO ATTEMPT TO
CLOSE THE GAP FOR THE HIGHEST
NEEDS KIDS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ENSURE IDEALLY THAT WE NEVER
HAVE TO SEND KIDS. OUT OF STATE
ANYMORE IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM.
TO SERVE THE MOST ACUTE NEEDS
OF KIDS AND IT SETS UP THE
ABILITY TO STEP DOWN AND STEP
OUT OF HIGHER INTENSITY
SERVICES AS QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE. THIS
IS A GAP IN OUR SYSTEM FOR
SERVING DEPENDENCY AND
DELINQUENCY CHILDREN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR STONE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. OUR
CLUB THE ROLE. THAT OF ALL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE TALBERT
AS FIFTY EIGHT ZERO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO OH SEVEN. AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN BY MR LEVINE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FOURTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER JOAQUIN AND
ACCURATE IN THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. MR LEVINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB EIGHT FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT EMPLOYEES EVERY LAW
<c.blue>NFORCEMENT AGENCY FROM</c>
CONDUCTING CONTACT TRACING AND
PLACE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ON
DATA COLLECTED FOR CONTACT
TRACING PURPOSES SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL PROHIBITS DATA
COLLECTED RECEIVER PREPARED FOR
CONTACT EIGHT TRADING PURPOSES
FROM BEING USED TO MAINTAIN OR
DISCLOSE FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSES
THAN FACILITATING CONTACT
TRACING EFFORTS MEMBERS
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE LESS
LIKELY TO WILLINGLY INTERACT
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT REGARDLESS
OF THE CONTEXT DUE TO DISTRUST
AND FEAR. AND HAVE BEEN
DISPERSED AT LEE AFFECTED BY
COBIT NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FOURTEEN WILL PROTECT THE DATA
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIANS AND
BUILD PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
CONTACT TRACING PROGRAM NEEDED
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM FURTHER SPREAD OF
COVER NINETEEN AND IN POTENTIAL
FUTURE PANDEMICS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
LIVING SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM QUICKLAW THE
ROLE. THE SIDE OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRABLE.
CLERK WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO AWAIT AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN BY DOCTOR WOULD
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD ENACT LEAVING
SPORTFISHING. DOCTOR WOULD
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF PERMISSION TO USE A
PROPER TO THEIR SMALL AND
HARMLESS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN WOULD CHANGE THE WAY
CALIFORNIA ISSUE SPORT. FISHING
LICENCES CURRENTLY ANNUAL
SUPPORT LISTED FISHING LICENSES
EXPIRE ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE LICENSE
WAS PURCHASED. THIS IS MY
AMERICAN AIRLINES CREDIT CARD.
IT EXPIRES ON IN JULY BUT IT
WILL BE RENEWED WITH THE FEE.
FOR THE NEXT JULY COSCO RENEWS
EVERY YEAR REGARDLESS OF WHAT
DAY OF THE YEAR I BY THE LIFE
BY THIS CARD. MY TRIPLE A CARD
I NEEDED THIS A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WHEN I HAD A DEAD BATTERY.
IT RENEWS EVERY YEAR REGARDLESS
BUT IF FISHING LICENSE IF YOU
BOUGHT IT IN FEBRUARY EXPIRES
IN DECEMBER. OR YOU BOUGHT IT
NOVEMBER IT IS EXPIRES IN
DECEMBER EVEN MY DENTAL LICENSE
AND THIS IS WHAT I GET IT'S A
PIECE OF PAPER THAT HAS TO LAST
TWO YEARS ACTUALLY GOES FROM
THE MONTH OF MY BIRTH. TO THE
MONTH OF THE BY BIRTH TWO YEARS
LATER FIFTY S. SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR THIS
BEAUTIFUL PIECE OF PAPER TO
KEEP MY DENTAL LICENSE. THIS IS
JUST A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL
FOLKS. IT'S BEEN TRIED MANY
TIMES BEFORE. THE BILL WOULD
INSTEAD MAKE LICENSE IS VALID
FOR A YEAR FROM THE TIME YOU
PURCHASE THEM JUST LIKE YOUR
COSCO JUST LIKE YOUR YOUR YOUR
CAR REGISTRATION. PROPOSAL IS
PART OF A LARGER RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND REACTIVATION
PROCESS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IS WORKING
ON. WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS BILL AS APARTMENT WAS
FORWARD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR V. I. BOPARA COMMONSENSE
GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT USE OF PROPS DOCTOR
WOULD. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLICK LIBERAL. THE
SERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE
CLARK WELL- CLOSER ALL. TIVER I
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO TEN. PARDON ME FILE
ITEM TWO OR NINE CORRECTION
FALLING TO A NINE AB EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE SYRIAN
AND IRAQ RELATING TO HIV
TESTING. MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE A HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TO OFFER
AN HIV TEST TO PATIENTS FOR
WHOM BLOOD IS DRAWN. IS ALREADY
BEING DRAWN THIS IS BASED ON
THEIR CONSENT AS WELL
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO SHARE A
QUICK STORY WITH ALL OF YOU. IN
SIX MONTHS IN IN IN FIVE
MONTHS- NOVEMBER ELEVEN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WILL BE
EXACTLY THIRTY YEARS WHEN MAGIC
JOHNSON. MADE IS ANNOUNCEMENT
OF HAVE BEING HIV INFECTED. THE
REASON WHY I BRING THIS UP IS
BECAUSE- AFTER THAT DAY.
TREATMENTS GOT BETTER ATTENTION
TO THE ISSUE GOT BETTER AND WE
SAW A SIGNIFICANT DECLINE TO
HIV CONTRACTION. AFTER THAT A
LOT MORE TIME AND MONEY WAS
SPENT TOWARDS THE RESEARCH AS
WELL. UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST DECADE
THERE'S BEEN A RISE IN NUMBERS
BECAUSE GENERATIONALLY SEEMS
THE YOUNGER GENERATION HAS
FORGOTTEN ABOUT WHAT IT WAS
LIKE TO LIVE WITH HIV AND VERY
QUICKLY DETERIORATE. BECAUSE OF
THE MEDICINE AND DRUGS RIGHT
NOW PEOPLE ARE LIVING LONGER
INTO THAT AND HAVING A LOT MORE
PRODUCTIVE LIVES. THIS BILL IS
GOING TO ENSURE THAT THIS
GENERATION THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
RISKY IN THEIR BEHAVIOR- IS
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THAT THEY ARE
H. OUT WHETHER THEY ARE HIV
POSITIVE OR NOT. A BILL DONE
THREE YEARS AGO ON A PILOT
BASIS ALLOW FOR US TO CAPTURE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS GOING THROUGH E. R.
A HOSPITAL ROOMS AND SAW THAT
2% OF THOSE WHO WERE REPORTING
TO E. R. ROOMS DID NOT EVEN
KNOW THEY WERE HIV INFECTED.
TWO OUT OF EVERY HUNDRED PEOPLE
SO THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE THE
PILOT PROGRAM AND MAKE IT
PERMANENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CARBONARO. THE SERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. THE
CLERK WILL. YOU CAN CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT FIVE FORTY FIVE
KNOWS TO. THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE A
MISTER RIVAS IS ITEM THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY NINE AB.
SEVEN NINETEEN. THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME REAL SEVEN NINETEEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
AND ALKYLATING TO BE'S. MYSTERY
THAT'S YOU MAY OPEN. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL LAST SEVEN ONE NINE IS A
NON- CONTROVERSIAL
AGRICULTURAL- THE COMMITTEE
BILL THAT MAKES VARIOUS- SOME
TECHNICALCHANGES TO THE APIARY
PROTECTION ACT RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISREAD S. C.
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLARK
WELL OVER THE ROLE. WHAT IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AND ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
EXACT VOTE. WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. MS
RAISE YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO ITEM TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE FORTY TWO
WOULD IT AND ITEM TWO SIX EIGHT
AB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE SOLACE.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TO TEN. PASS A RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN AM TO
TWELVE. THIS IS FILE ITEM. TO
THIRTEEN. FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN
AB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. BY MISTER
GARCIA CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES MR GARCIA
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
ARE FEW BILLS THAT WE GET TO
WORK ON THAT- DIRECTLY- FROM
IDEAS PROBLEMS THAT STEM IN OUR
COMMUNITY THIS SPECIFIC BILL.
CAME AS A RESULT OF A MEETING
WITH HOME CARE WORKERS
EXPLAINING TO US THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY WERE DEALING WITH
DURING THE THICK OF THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE STILL ARE IN.
AND ONE OF THEM WAS THE SAD
NEWS OF NOT HAVING THE
RESOURCES TO BURY THEIR LOVED
ONES WHO HAVE DIED AS A RESULT
OF OVER NINETEEN. AB EIGHT SIX
EIGHT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
EMERGENCY. FUNERAL EXPENSE FUND
TO REIMBURSE FUNERAL COSTS WHEN
THE CAUSE OF DEATH IS DIRECTLY
pEMERGENCY INCLUDING THE CURRENT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS OF COOPER
NINETEEN. THIS BILL WOULD
REIMBURSE LOW INCOMEFAMILIES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS I WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
ASSISTANCE. OF EXPENSES YET TO
BE PAID TO BE SENT DIRECTLY TO
THE PROVIDER. RELIEVING THE
OPERATIVE FROM STRUGGLING TO
COME UP WITH. MONEY UP FRONT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
COLLEAGUES THAT WILL HELP. A
LOT OF CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN HIT HARD BY THIS PANDEMIC
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
MISTER MATHIS YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION. I TO
ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT WE
HAVE A DUTY AS GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN WE LOSE LOVED
ONES DURING A PANDEMIC. THAT WE
AT LEAST TAKE CARE OF THEIR
BURIAL EXPENSES AND FOR THAT
REASON ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH S. SENOL
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLICK LIBERAL. ESERVER. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE SITE OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
BACK IN THE FILE THE FILE AT A
ONE NINETY EIGHT TO TAKE A
MISTER C. AS- AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE ANY AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN CORPORATE. I'M A
BILL SEVEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA CRISTINA GARCIA
AND ACTIVATING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. IS GARCIA. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
REQUIRES A STATE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO CONDUCT A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH ANALYSIS.
TO INCORPORATE INTO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SCORPION
PLAN EACH UPDATE. HI THIS
WORKING PLANET THAT HAPPENS
EVERY FIVE YEARS AND I THINK I
TO HELP US REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS
AND IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND
HEALTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA C. NO DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CARCLUB
THEY'RE ALL. MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- FOR TWELVE.
THOSE ARE ALL TIED IS FIFTY
THREE NO STATES THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK AND FALL
ORDER. BACK IN FILE ORDER THIS
IS FILE ITEM TO FOURTEEN. AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE MR
LEVINE. COOKERY ASSEMBLY BOAT
EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE SOME
MEMORABLE LEVINE AND OTHERS AN
ALKYLATING TO SLAUGHTER ANIMALS
MICHELLE LEVINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN AUTHORIZED THE MOBILE
PROCESSING OF CATTLE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL SEEKING TO PURCHASE
AN ANIMAL FOR THEIR OWN USE AND
CONSUMPTION THIS BILL AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT EXPANDS THE
SLAUGHTER SHEEP GOATS AND SWINE
FOR CONSUMPTION SO LONG THAT IS
CONSUMED BY THE OWNER THEIR
FAMILY ARE INVITED GUESTS IN
THE MEAT IS NOT RESOLD THIS IS
REALLY HELPING LOCAL FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO HAVE OTHERWISE
NEEDED TO TRACK. THEIR CATTLE
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY FOR
SLAUGHTER- WHEN IT COULD BE
DONE MUCH MORE HUMANELY MUCH
ONE FAMILY FRIENDLY ON THE FARM
AND ON THE RANCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MISS LIVING.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF NARAL. DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE REMOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. I
READ THAT WRONG. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE. TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO. ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO FIFTEEN AB EIGHT
NINETY CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES AND OTHERS AND
ACCOLADES PUBLIC RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS MR BY TESS THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT
NINETY ONE FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
PROMOTE THE INCLUSION OF WOMEN
IN MINORITY MONEY MANAGERS IN
THE ASSET MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. TO PROVIDE A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE UTILIZATION OF EMERGING AND
DIVERSE MONEY MANAGERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR MATTIS.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLICK
LIBERAL. DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE AYE AYES FIFTY
KNOWS TEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS. FILE ITEM TO SIXTEEN
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT BY MR
BERMAN MCCURRY ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT RELATING
TO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. MR
BERMAN. YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION I HAVE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM STUDENTS
THAT THE TRANSFER PROCESS
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
FOR YOUR INSTITUTION IS COMPLEX
CONFUSING AND DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE I'M GRATEFUL TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
HER STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. AB NINE TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD IMPROVING REIMAGINE THE
TRANSFER PROCESS FROM THE
STUDENT PERSPECTIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. TREMENDOUS COMPOSURE
MISTER BERMAN SENILE.
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERICAL OF THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO RESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM. TO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
ONE. COOKERY ASSEMBLY GO NINE
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VEHICLE TO A AN ACT RELATING TO
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING SHOULD
BE APPROVED BY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE THIRTY ONE TO YOU
TODAY EIGHTY NINE THIRTY ONE
REQUIRES A POST COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP A MORE ROBUST TRAINING
ON PEACE OFFICERS DUTY TO
INTERVENE WHEN. EXCESSIVE FORCE
IS BEING USE THERE IS A BROAD
AGREEMENT BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PROFESSIONALS POLICY MAKERS
AND CONSTITUENTS THAT WANT TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN. LAST YEAR
MINNEAPOLIS WAS A COMPLETE
PREVENTABLE AND UNACCEPTABLE.
THIS CURRICULA TEACHES OFFICERS
HOW TO INTERVENE EFFECTIVELY
AND SAFELY AND HELPS TO CREATE
THE CULTURE AROUND THE NEEDS OF
PEER INTERVENTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR MR LACKEY ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THE BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS TO TAKE PART THE DUTY
TO INTERCEDE. AND IT WILL BE
FOCUSED ON TRAINING AND
REFRESHER COURSES EVERY TWO
YEARS. THE CURRENT CURRICULUM
IN PLACE BY POST ADDRESSES USE
OF FORCE TRAINING BUT DOES NOT
FULLY CAPTURE THE IMPORTANCE OF
DUTY TO INTERCEDE TRAINING. THE
DIRTY DINNER C. DOES NOT. ONLY
ALREADY INCLUDED A CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SAFETY LAWS AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE. BUT THIS KIND
OF TRAINING HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO SAVE LIVES BY EQUIPPING
OFFICERS WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO STEP IN WHEN AN OFFICER
OR CIVILIAN HAS CROSSED THE
LINE. EMPOWERING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TO STAND
UP TO SUPERIORS WHEN
APPROPRIATE. AND COLLEAGUES.
WILL INSTILL CONFIDENCE WITHIN
THE INSTITUTION AND THE
COMMUNITY. IS CRITICAL THAT
THESE OFFICERS RECEIVE AS MUCH
TRAINING AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
OUR LINE OF WORK. THOSE AMENDED
DANGEROUS PATH ALMOST EVERY
DAY. THIS BILL WILL SAVE LIVES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S FOR THIS REASON THE LARGER
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LACKEY.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE MATTER. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. WE DESIGNED VOTE ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. THE
CLERK WILL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED
UP BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO EIGHTEEN. AB NINE FORTY
ONE BY MR BENNETT. COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE FARMWORKERS
MISTER BENNETT EMAIL BUT THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO
AB NINE FORTY ONE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH  GRANT PROGRAM FOR
THE CREATION OF FARMWORKER
RESOURCE PROGRAMS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. THIS BILL EXTENDS THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAD IN
VENTURA COUNTY TO DEVELOP THE
FIRST OF ITS KIND VENTURA
COUNTY FARMWORKER RESOURCE
PROGRAM- BY CREATING A GRANT
PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE OTHER
COUNTIES TO DO THE SAME THING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU. MISTER BENNETT WE HAVE THE
BILL IN CHIEF BEFORE THE BODY-
MR BETTER CAN YOU APPROACH THE
DESK PLEASE. SO WE MAY HAVE A
DISCUSSION. SELECT ONE OF THE
PRINCIPALS OFFICE. JUST A
LITTLE BIT.
CERVANTES NOT
TROUBLE. THERE'S NO BOEING ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR MEMBERS.
BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM TO
NINETEEN INTO TWENTY. PASS
RETAIN WE ARE FILE ITEM. TWO
TWENTY ONE. AB NINE FORTY EIGHT
CORRECT AMADOR NINE FORTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO REAL
ESTATE. MR HOLDING EMAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FORTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT REQUIRES THAT EVERY
CONTRACT FOR THE SALE OF REAL
PROPERTY CONTAIN A NOTICE
INFORMING THE BUYER AND SELLER.
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO REPORT
ANY SUSPICION OF A
DISCRIMINATORY APPRAISAL BY A
REAL ESTATE APPRAISER THROUGH
THE BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS INTERNET WEBSITE. OR
TELEPHONE NUMBER. FOR THOSE
THAT SEEK TO REFINANCE THEIR
PROPERTY THE NOTICE WILL BE
PROVIDED IN THE LOAN MATERIALS.
AB NINE FORTY I WOULD REQUIRE
THE BUREAU TO COMPILE THE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION AND
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON OR BEFORE JULY.
TWELFTH OF JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FINALLY THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE AN APPLICANT. FOR
PRES A LICENSING TO COMPLETE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY AND
ELIMINATION OF BIAS TRAINING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
HOLDEN. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CARCLUB RURAL. IS TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY TWO AB NINE
FIFTY BY MISTER WARD. THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY WILL NINE
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
AND ACKERLEY IN THE STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS. MR WARD EMAIL BUT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTY WOULD
AUTHORIZE CALTRANS TO SELL
EXCESS PROPERTY TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LONG TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS FOR FEEDING
PROGRAMS AT THE PROPERTY'S
ORIGINAL ACQUISITION VALUE BY
DOING THIS THE STATE CAN
SUPPORT THE TRANSFER OF
STRATEGICALLY LOCATED ACCESS
LAND. TO BE USED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PROVIDE AN
INNOVATIVE TOOL TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WARD. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CARCLUB
RURAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLIED OF A AYE
AYES FIFTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM
TWO TWENTY THREE THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN BY MISTER FRAZIER
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION. MR FRAZIER
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER%
SPEAKER. AS ALL OF YOU KNOW
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
BEEN ESPECIALLY IMPACTED BY THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
SCHOOL CLOSURES. IN AN EXPECTED
INFLUX OF DUE PROCESS CASES
RELATED TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
SCHOOL DISRUPTIONS WILL
OVERWHELM THE SYSTEM. CREATING
ADDITIONAL DELAYS TO SERVICES.
MORE NEGATIVE EDUCATIONAL
IMPACTS AND PROVIDE LITTLE
RECORDS FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OR THOSE FACING LANGUAGE
BARRIERS. AB NINE SIX SEVEN
GIVES ELEAZAR ONE ON ONE
MATCHING FUNDS FOR CRITICAL
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. IT WILL DELIVER
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
INVOLUNTARY DISPUTE RESOLUTION
PROCESSES WITH A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF PREVENTING AND
RESOLVING DISPUTES IN AN
EQUITABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER. EIGHTY NINE SIX SEVEN
REQUIRES AT LEAST TO CONFRONT
IN EQUITY BY CONDUCTING
OUTREACH TO FAMILIES WHO ARE
TYPICALLY LEFT OUT OF THE
PROCESS AND UNABLE TO ACCESS
THEIR DUE PROCESS RIGHTS. AB
NINE SIX SEVEN ALL ALSO CREATES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENHANCES
FAMILY SUPPORTS BY INCLUDING
SELFLESS CD IN FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS FROM ALL
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE HAVE COME
TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I REALLY DO WANT TO THANK
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND IS
CHAIR AND STAFF BECAUSE THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION AND
THEY HAVE BEEN AMAZING. WITH
THEIR HELP GOING FORWARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB NINE SIX SEVEN TO
DEMONSTRATE OUR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER. SAY NO
DISCUSSION I'M SORRY I MISSED
ONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SIX SEVEN
THEIR WORK STATUS TO COVER
NINETEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION FUND
I WANT TO ESPECIALLY THANK THE
AUTHOR. FOR HIS LEADERSHIP THE
COVER NINETEEN SCHOOL SHUT DOWN
SEVERELY AFFECTED STUDENTS
ACROSS OUR STATE PARTICULAR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES THE
EDUCATION OF ALMOST EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITY HAS
BEEN INCONSISTENT AT BEST SINCE
SCHOOL CLOSURES IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY. RENTS HAVE EXTRA
EXPERIENCE OVERWHELMING
CHALLENGES AND FELLOW ATTEMPTS
TO SECURE HELP MUCH NEDED
HANDS ON SERVICES. SUCH AS
THERAPISTS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE NOT
PERFORM WELL THROUGH A COMPUTER
SCREEN. STUDENT WITH
DISABILITIES WERE MOST IMPACTED
BY THE AFTER THE SCHOOLS AND
THE CHALLENGES THAT ONLINE
LEARNING PRESENTED. MANY
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES RELY ON CRITICAL WE
NEED NEEDED HANDS ON EDUCATION
AND THERAPIES. BOTH WHICH WERE
TAKEN AWAY FOR OVER A YEAR. OUR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES ARE
BEHIND AND IN DIRE NEED OF OUR
SUPPORT THIS WILL PROVIDE. THE
NECESSARY FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE RETURN TODAY EDUCATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL PROGRESS THE
STUDENT WITH DISABILITIES
DESERVES I ASKED MY COLLEAGUES
TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENT WITH THIS BILL ACROSS
THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR ONE. THIS VALLADARES THIS IS
SUPPORT SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
RISE. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR- WE KNOW THAT MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS AND- CALIFORNIA
HAVE EXPERIENCE LEARNING LOSS
THIS YEAR- BUT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT IS IT FOR OUR SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS THEY'VE
ACTUALLY- EXPERIENCE SOMETHING
CALLED REGRESSION AND THIS
REGRESSION IS SEVERE AND IT IS
THE RESULT OF A THEIR ADVANCE
ADVANCEMENT AS SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS HAS HAPPENED BECAUSE
OF YEARS OF SERVICES AND
THERAPIES. AND THIS IS BEEN ON
THEY HAVE REGRESSED THIS PAST
YEAR IT COULD BE A MORE
IMPORTANT A VITAL AND CRITICAL
TIME FOR US TO PROVIDE FUNDING
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU. EVER
DRIVE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISS VALDERS SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION MR FRAZIER YOU MAY
CLOSE YOU WISH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST ENCOURAGE ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES TO ENGAGE. IN
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
THEIR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
DEPARTMENTS ATTEND IT PEAS AND
SUPPORT OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
OF FOLKS IN THIS EFFORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
YEAH WITH TAX CLUB IN THE-
MEMBERS. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRABLE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS REGARDING THE
BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SO ITEM UP THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO TEN. AB EIGHT
FORTY THREE. CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT FORTY
THREE IS A NARROW BILL AIM TO
ALLOW COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS TO ACCESS AN
EXISTING STATE PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES COST RECOVERY. FOR
RENEWABLE BIO ENERGY
ELECTRICITY PROJECTS. PRIVATE
UTILITIES ARE CURRENTLY THE
ONLY ENERGY PROVIDERS ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PROGRAM AND THEY ARE
NOT USING THE CAPACITY
THEMSELVES. THE BILL APPLIES TO
THE SAME PROGRAM RULES TO CCA'S
AS I- USE AND DOES NOT CHANGE
THE EXISTING CAP OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MEGAWATTS. THAT'S
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR ALL. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS FUNDS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. INSTEAD
OF. CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTE. I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN. THIS
IS BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER.
ON. TWO TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY
SIX. THAT BRINGS US TO MISS
CARILLO FILE ITEM TWO TWENTY
SEVEN AB ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TUNNEL
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND OTHERS IMMACULATE
VICTIM COMPENSATION THIS
CARILLO Q. MAIL. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM BEYOND
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TENNELL
SEVEN A MEASURE THAT WOULD
RIGHTFULLY COMPENSATE PEOPLE
SPECIFICALLY WOMEN WHO WERE
INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZED UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S PREVIOUS EUGENICS
LOS AND THEREAFTER BY CREATING
THE FORCED STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM. YOU
JANICE PRACTICES HAVE LONG A
SHAMEFUL HISTORY IN OUR COUNTRY
INCLUDING INVOLUNTARY AND FOR
STERILIZATION BETWEEN NINETEEN
OH NINE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE AT LEAST TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WERE STERILIZED UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S EUGENICS LOSS
MAKING UP ONE THIRD OF
STERILIZATIONS NATIONWIDE ONE
OF THE MOST COMPELLING CASES OF
FORCED AN UNKNOWN
STERILIZATION. IN THE LATE
NIGHT HAPPENED IN THE LATE
NINETEEN SIXTIES THAT L. A.
COUNTY HOSPITAL IN THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT IN WHICH
MEXICAN AMERICAN AND IMMIGRANT
LATINO WOMEN WERE STERILIZED
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT POST
LABOR THESE WOMEN NEVER KNEW.
WHY THEY CAN NEVER HAVE
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN THE PAIN
CONFUSION ANGER DEPRESSION AND
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES THESE
WOMEN FACE IS DOCUMENTED IN THE
FILM NO MATHIS NO MORE BABIES
THESE THESE WOMEN ARE NOW
ELDERLY AND LEAVING OUR WORLD
EVERY SINGLE DAY. ALTHOUGH THIS
HORRIFIC LAW WAS REPEALED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE I LATER
STATE AUDIT RE-ATTEMPT FORTY
FOUR WOMEN WERE STERILIZED
DURING LABOR AND DELIVERY
WITHOUT PROPER CONSENT WHILE
INCARCERATED FROM TWO THOUSAND
SIX. TO TWO THOUSAND TEN.
DATING TO THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED WOMEN WERE
INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZED IN
PRISON DURING LABOR AND
DELIVERY AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
FORCED STERILIZATIONS WERE
PERFORMED DURING OTHER
SURGERIES. IT IS CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE SURVIVING
INDIVIDUALS. WHO SURVIVES
STERILIZATION UNDER THE LAW AND
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
SURVIVORS OF PRISON
STERILIZATION ABUSE THESE
ABUSES ARE ALSO REFLECTED OF
THE FILM BELLY OF THE BEAST.
ONLY AFFECTED INCARCERATED
WOMEN OF COLOR WITH 65% OF
SURVIVORS IDENTIFYING AS BLACK
HISPANIC MEXICAN OR OTHER. IT
IS SHAMEFUL TO KNOW THAT EVEN
TO THIS DAY MANY SURVIVORS
STILL DO NOT KNOW THAT THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE CAPACITY WAS
VIOLENTLY STOLEN FROM THEM.
FORCED AN INVOLUNTARY
STERILIZATION HAS IMPACTED MORE
THAN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN
SOME CASES THERE WAS EXTREME
SIDE EFFECTS LIFELONG HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS SOCIAL ISOLATION
AND EVEN DEATH. MEMBERS THE FOR
STERILIZATION COMPENSATION
PROGRAM IS MORE THAN MONETARY
COMPENSATION. IT PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR OUT REACH
IDENTIFICATION APPEALS PROCESS
AND PAYMENTS MOST IMPORTANTLY
IT OFFERS A SEMBLANCE OF
JUSTICE THAT CONFRONTS
CALIFORNIA'S SHAMEFUL PAST. AB
TENNELL SEVEN WILL PROVIDE SOME
CLOSURE TO THOSE HARM AND A
GOVERNMENT SPONSOR
STERILIZATION PRACTICE AND
ENSURE THAT IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN. THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
IN HEALING COMMUNITY AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND ENDING
THE PERPETUATION OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
INEQUALITIES. THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE INCLUDES THE RIGHT TO BE
A PARENT TO BE A FATHER TO BE A
MOTHER AND NO AMOUNT OF
COMPENSATION WILL EVER MAKE
THAT RIGHT BUT THIS. THIS IS
ANOTHER STEP TOWARDS JUSTICE
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I WANT
TO THANK. ALL THE MEMBERS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED FOR THE
PAST. FEW YEARS THAT I HAVE
BEEN IN THIS IN THIS CHAMBER
TRYING TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
AND AS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS LEGISLATION I AM SO
THANKFUL. ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN WHOSE RIGHTS TO BECOME A
MOTHER WERE TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO MISSILE LACKING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I HOPE THIS IS ALSO
SUPPORT SUPPORTS WILL BE BRIEF.
MEMBERS I STAND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LOS ANGELES ON
THIS VERY. SAD SAD ISSUE AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR THIS BILL I
WANT TO ALCOHOL. INHUMANE AND
UNCONSCIONABLE. THIS PRACTICE
WAS. THIS WAS GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED IN HUMANITY. NO
COMPENSATION TO MAKE UP FOR
THIS INJUSTICE BUT IT WILL
SIGNIFY OUR SUPPORT FOR THESE
VICTIMS IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
EXPRESS. OUR SADNESS FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES WHEN I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. DAVIS LACKING MS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT AND PEOPLE
DON'T NEED TO ASK WHY WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO GET THIS BILL-
INTO THE BUDGET FOR A FEW YEARS
NOW AND I'M SO GRATEFUL TO OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND- OF COURSE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WHO ENSURED. THAT THIS YEAR AND
I LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PROPOSAL
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE MONEY
TO ACTUALLY FUND THIS PROGRAM
SO IT WOULD NOT BE AN EMPTY
PROMISE AS LONG AS THE GOVERNOR
GOES ALONG WITH IT. AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM- LOS
ANGELES FOR BEING. AS
PERSISTENT TO SAY THE LEAST TO
ENSURE THAT WE GOT THIS BILL
THROUGH THIS YEAR AND-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN ALL SUPPORT
HER EFFORTS IN THIS IT IS A
RIGHT TO IT RIGHTEOUS RIGHT
JUST BECAUSE- THANK YOU
RESIDENTS ALSO HAS RIVAS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES-
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL TO US
TODAY. I WAS BORN MY SISTER AND
I WERE BORN AT L. A. COUNTY
HOSPITAL. IN THE EARLY
SEVENTIES. AND WHILE A MEXICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN WERE BEING
STERILIZED YOU KNOW I DON'T
EVEN KNOW. IF MY MOM WAS ONE OF
THEM. BUT I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF WOMEN LIKE HER THAT WERE
VICTIMS. AND I WENT THAT'S WHY
I WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING TIS- YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO OUR FAMILIES- AND
IT SHOULD'VE NEVER HAPPENED AND
THEY SHOULD BE COMPENSATED SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VETERANS
MYSTERY PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS-
MISTER THANK THE AUTHOR FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR BRINGING THIS
TOPIC UP- IT'S A TOPIC THAT
PLAGUES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE TALKED ABOUT
COVERT NINETEEN IN THE VACCINES
BEING ADMINISTERED IN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY. A
LOT OF OUR ELDERS AND OUR WOMEN
WERE HESITANT TO GET THAT
VACCINE BECAUSE OF THIS VERY
THING THAT YOU'RE BRINGING UP.
A STERILIZATION PROCESS THAT
TOOK PLACE. AS AS LATE AS THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE NOT
ONLY MOVE FORWARD TO STERILIZE
WOMEN OF ALL ETHNICITIES BUT
AGAINST ALSO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
NATION. SO ON A THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THIS ISSUE AS WE STAND
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THESE
TYPES OF THINGS DO NOT HAPPEN
AGAIN. AGAINST ALL OF OUR
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION. AND
ESPECIALLY STANDING UP FOR THE
VOICES OF ALL THOSE NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN THAT WERE FORCED
STERILIZATION ON THEM I'M FROM
THE STATE SO THANK. YOU AND
URGE YOUR AYE SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ADAM MISS CARILLO YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS EUGENICS LAWS WERE
IN HUMANE THEY SHOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN PART OF CALIFORNIA
HISTORY BUT UNFORTUNATELY THEY
ARE AND IN THIS MOMENT ON THIS
DAY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE RIGHT FOR WHAT WAS DONE SO
WRONGLY TO SELL MANY WOMEN. TO
SO MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
AND NOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY AND DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MYSTERY ON WITH THAT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE AND DESIRE TO VOTE THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL ANTI
VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MISS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE ITEM NINE AB FOURTEEN
NINETY CHAU ITEM ONE FIFTEEN AB
TWELVE THIRTY SIXTEEN ITEM TWO
FIFTY THREE AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY THREE. THIS IS DOCTOR
QUIRKS. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FIVE.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY TO HIGHWAYS
DR PARK. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
NINE FIFTY FIVE- AND- SPEAKER
DUE TO CONFUSION ABOUT
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
PROJECT PERMITS SOME BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS HVE
BEEN DELAYED BY OVER A YEAR AB
NINE FIFTY FIVE SIMPLY REQUIRES
CALTRANS TO NOTIFY ENCROACHMENT
PERMIT APPLICANTS ALL
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS UP
FRONT IN SUCH A THIRTY DAY
MILESTONE FOR CALTRANS TO
VERIFY THAT THE APPLICATION IS
COMPLETE- THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU ARRIVE. THANK YOU. THEY GET
A COURT. SAY NO DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL.
ZADOROV MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY EIGHT. NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. BACK
IN FILE ORDER. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHT AB TEN
SEVENTEEN BY MISS CORK SILVA.
THANK THIRTY WILL THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORK SILVA AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MS CLARK SILVA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TEN SEVENTEEN THE
RIGHT TO REST ROOM ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE HAVE ALL USE THE
RESTROOM ON THIS FLOOR MANY
SEVERAL MAYBE MANY OF US
SEVERAL TIMES TODAY. THE FIRST
THING WE DO IN THE MORNING. AND
IT'S THE FIRST THING OUR
CHILDREN DO OUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. BUT FOR MANY. THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE A RESTROOM. TO
USE ANYTIME OF THE DAY.
COVETOUS SHED LIGHT THAT MANY
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
USE- RESTROOM. AT A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT AT A RETAIL PLACE.
IN PUBLIC PARKS. AND AS I SAID
LAST WEEK ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS
GO OUTSIDE AND SEE MANY
HOMELESS SITTING ON THE STREET
AND JUST LAST WEEK AFTER I
SPOKE ON THE FLOOR AND I WAS
WALKING HOME. I SPOKE TO ONE
GENTLEMAN NAMED DAVID. AND I
SIMPLY ASKED HIM WHERE DO YOU
USE THE RESTROOM. AND HE SAID
ANYWHERE I HAVE TO BUT HE'S
LEARNED TO TRAIN HIMSELF TO USE
IT INFREQUENTLY. WHICH MATTER
OF FACT. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
ON THE KIDNEYS. THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE IT WILL SIMPLY TAKE AN
INVENTORY OF WHERE RESTROOMS
ARE LOCATED FOR PUBLIC FROM
CITIES TO COUNTIES. NOW BECAUSE
OF COVED WE KNOW MANY RESTROOMS
HAVE BEEN CLOSE BUT EVEN BEFORE
THAT MANY MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE STARTED TO
CLOSE THE RESTROOMS. BECAUSE OF
ISSUES THIS DOES NOT ONLY
PERTAIN TO HOMELESS. IT ALSO
PERTAINS TO FAMILIES WHO WANT
TO TAKE THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN TO
PARKS IT ALSO PERTAINS TO
FAMILIES WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
SEE. THEIR OWN CHILDREN PLAY
SPORTS IT PERTAINS TO OUR
SENIORS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SET
OUT AT THE PARK. ALL OF US NEED
TO USE THE RESTROOM MANY TIMES
A DAY AND SIMPLY GOING OUT FOR
A PARK DATE BECOMES VERY
MINIMAL IF THERE'S NOT A CLEAN
RESTROOM AVAILABLE. SO I STAND
HERE AND ASK YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TEN SEVENTEEN THE RIGHT TO
RESTROOMS ACT A TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
THIS GONZALEZ YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE
ACTUALLY EXPANDED IT WHICH IS
RARE IN APPROPRIATIONS AND I'LL
EXPLAIN WHY THIS IS NOT JUST A
PROBLEM WITH HOMELESS IT'S NOT
JUST A PROBLEM WITH. FAMILIES
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR WORKERS
WE'RE HEARING MORE AND MORE
STORIES OF WORKERS HAVE TO
URINATE INTO A- A WATER BOTTLE
BECAUSE THERE'S NOWHERE FOR
THEM WHEN THEY'RE PROVIDING
DELIVERIES OR OTHER THINGS TO
USE THE RESTROOM QUITE FRANKLY-
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THAT. IS
A GENDER SPECIFIC AND THAT MEN
HAVE AN ABILITY TO RELIEVE
THEMSELVESIN A WAY WOMEN
DON'T- IT IS AN ISUE THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS LONG TERM THE
LACK OF PUBLIC BATHROOMS IN
ASSESSABLE PUBLIC BATHROOMS IS
AN ISSUE FOR ALL OF US. AND SO
I REALLY APPLAUD MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR TAKING
THIS ON I DON'T THINK THIS IS
THE LAST OF THE BILLS I THINK
THIS IS JUST THE START TO
UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE RIGHT TO
USE RESTROOM SHOULD BE
FUNDAMENTAL NO MATTER WHERE YOU
WORK NO MATTER WHERE YOU PLAY
NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE NOT JUST FOR THE HOMELESS
NOT JUST FOR FAMILIES NOT JUST
FOR WORKERS BUT FOR ALL OF US.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ. HIS
PARA QUE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'LL BE BRIEF BUT I
WANTED TO THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL IN MY WORK
AS AN ATTORNEY IN SAN FRANCISCO
I REPRESENT HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE GIVEN
CITATIONS FOR EXACTLY THESE
KIND OF VIOLATIONS PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE TO GO TO
THE BATHROOM AND HAD NO CHOICE
AND I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT THEY
THEN GOT A CITATION THEY
COULDN'T PAY BECAUSE THEY ARE
HOMELESS AND COULDN'T AFFORD IT
A WARRANT WENT OUT. AND THEY
THEN COULDN'T GET PUBLIC
HOUSING AND CITIES HOMELESS
PEOPLE WERE STUCK ON THE
STREETS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO RESTROOM THIS IS
SO KEY TO FIGHTING ARE HOMELESS
PROBLEM SO THANK YOU. THANKS
BURKE A HAND. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON
THE ITEM. WAS QUICK SILVA YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. YES TEN
SEVENTEEN AGAIN CAME OUT OF
SOME OF THE WORK THAT I'VE DONE
REGARDING HOMELESSNESS BUT IT
SIMPLY IS AS WE VOTE. ALL DAY
LONG THROUGHOUT THIS WEEK ON
MAJOR BILLS THAT AFFECT
HOMELESSNESS THAT AFFECT LAW
FOR WORKERS SOME OF THE MOST
BASIC RIGHT TO USE THE RESTROOM
IF WE CANNOT DO THAT AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SIMPLY
PROVIDE A RESTROOM. AS WAS
NOTED FOR NOT ONLY PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BUT
FOR SENIORS FOR OUR CHILDREN
FOR FAMILIES THEN WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO SO LET'S GET BUSY
AND LET'S GET TO WORK AND LET
SUPPORT A. B. TEN SEVENTEEN.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS. THIS
ADVERT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE ANTIVIRUS FIFTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE UP A
COUPLE OF MR GRAY'S ITEMS. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE. AB.
THREE TWENTY FIVE. CORKERY.
SOME LEGAL TO TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AND OTHERS
NOT RELATING TO PROFESSIONS
VOCATIONS MAKING APPROPRIATION-
FOR. MISTER GRAY YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWO TWENTY FIVE
MAKES IT EASIER FOR VETERANS TO
TRANSLATE THEIR TRAINING- INTO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AFTER
MILITARY LIFE IT'S GOOD BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DECIDED WELL.
WE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF I. SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES AND MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO ZERO
THREE. AB SEVEN EIGHTY THREE.
CORKERY SOME REAL SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
AN ACT RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY MISTER GREG. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
SEVENTY THREE STREAMLINE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS OF SURFACE MINING
OPERATIONS. GRADING CERTAINTY
FOR THE EMPLOYER AND A SAFER
WORKING ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
EMPLOYEE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. I THINK IT WAS
GREAT SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CARCLUB THE ROLE
MEMBERS. THESE ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. BACK IN FILE ORDER AB
APARTMENT FILE ITEM TWO TWO
NINE A. B. TEN TWENTY ONE. THAT
IS FILE ITEM TWO TWO NINE AB
TEN TWENTY ONE. COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AN ACT
RELATING TO IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS THE CEMEX THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TEN TWENTY ONE.
VERY SIMPLY THIS BILL AS
AMENDED WOULD ADD ONE AT
NONVOTING MEMBER TO IMPALER
IRRIGATION DISTRICT'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND ALSO COMMISSIONED
A STUDY TO HELP DETERMINE
VOTING RIGHTS IMPALER ADDITIONS
DISTRICTS GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE
AND HELP ENSURE ELECTRICAL
SERVICE TO THE COACHELLA VALLEY
IN PERPETUITY THIS BILL IS
NEEDED. FOR THE NINETY TWO
THOUSAND DISENFRANCHISED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IMPACTED BY
OUR MP IMPAIR THEIR GEISHA
DISTRICT POLICY BUT HAVE NO
SAY. NO VOICE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A VOTE ON THE BOARD
THAT SETS THAT POLICY. THIS
LEGISLATION IS ABOUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
REPRESENTATION AND NOTHING MORE.
THE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE A VOICE ON
MATTERS THAT IMPACT THEIR DAY
TO DAY LIVES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I BOUGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER MESS. MISTER EDUARDO
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
BUT I ALSO WANTED TO JUST MAKE
IT KNOWN THAT LIVE LOCALLY-
THERE ARE. PREFERRED PATHWAYS
THAT BOTH THE INTERROGATION
DISTRICT AND A FEW OF THE LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS WOULD RATHER
UNDERTAKE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. UNFORTUNATELY AT THOSE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE JUST BEGUN.
AFTER TWO YEARS OF HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY. ATION DISTRICT TO
PURSUE A PATH THAT WOULD BE
MORE INCLUSIVE TO THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE SERVED BY
THEIR UTILITY IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY I RISE BECAUSE THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT IMPACTS THE
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT. AND THE
PEOPLE IN THE AUTHORS DISTRICT
I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT- PARTIES
BECAUSE OF THIS MEASURE. WILL
BE FORCED TO COME TOGETHER AND
TRY TO COME UP WITH A
REASONABLE AN AMICABLE
SOLUTION- BUT THIS BILL IS HERE
N. I. RISE AGAIN TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF AB. TEN TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
MISTER MASON A CLOSER TO H.
WELL THANK YOU I WANT TO JUST-
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM A
COACHELLA- DONE AN AWFUL LOT OF
WORK TOGETHER HE UNDERSTANDS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS MEASURE
ALSO JUST WANNA TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THE CHAIR
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WHO'S DONE OFF A LOT
OF WORK. ON THIS IS WELL THIS
IS REALLY- JUST THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF WHAT WE DO
THERE'S STILL AN AWFUL LOT OF
WORK TO DO ALSO WANT TO THANK-
THE IMPAIR GEISHA DISTRICT FOR-
TAKING STEPS FORWARD I TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN GET THIS THIS
RIGHT WITH THAT. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. CLICK
LIBERAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRABLE. BURKE WELL. CLOSE
ROLE TYLER I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY ONE. THIS
IS A B. TEN TWENTY FOUR CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES MR
SANTIAGO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- BUT
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
PRESENTED A BILL TO CONTINUE TO
CLEAN UP THE WORST
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER THAT
WE'VE SEEN ON THE WEST COAST I
KNOWN AS EXCITE MANY OF YOU
KNOW AND HAVE SUPPORTED- THE
CLEAN UP EFFORTS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE YOU HAD
LEAD CONTAMINATION RUIN THE
LIVES OF MANY PEOPLE IN FACT
WE'VE HAD BIRTH DEFECTS HIGH
LEVELS OF CANCER. AND ASTHMA
RATES- THE PERIL OF VERY FEW
OTHER PLACES AND THIS IS ALL
BECAUSE- DTS CSPD AGENCY THAT
WAS THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY FAILED TO
PROTECT THE FOR OVER FORTY FOR
ALMOST CLOSE TO FORTY YEARS AND
HERE WE ARE NEEDING TO CLEAN
THIS UP NOW I'M EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION TO CONTINUE TO
CLEAN UP BUT MUCH MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE. IN THIS BILL
WOULD THIS BILL- IS A
CONTINUATION OF THAT IT WOULD
IMPLEMENT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
OVERSIGHT OVER DTS SEIZE
CONTROL OVER THE X. I CLEAN UP
IT REQUIRED TO TSC PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENT FIXED PRICE
CONTRACTING. FORMAS MUSCLES ALL
HAS. HAS WASTE CLEANUP THAT
THEY OVERSEE IT HAS HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY WOULD
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TO CONTINUE
THE CLEAN UP OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. THANK YOU MISS
SANTIAGO MS GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM. LA FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE HE LED AN
AUDIT. TO LOOK AT HOW WE WERE
DOING WITH THE CLEAN UP INSIDE
A LOT OF YOUR LIKE WE'RE NOT
DONE WITH THIS EVERY YEAR WE
KEEP COMING BACK AND SENDING
YOU AN EXCITING APPROPRIATION
IN YOUR BILL. BUT MOST OF MY
COLLEAGUE DECIDED LET'S MAKE
SURE WE'RE DOING IT RIGHT AND
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING BEST
PRACTICES AND SO THIS BILL IS
ENSURING NOT ONLY THAT WERE
CLEANING UP THESE HOMES. AND WE
KEEPING THAT- THE COMMUNITY
SAFE BUT THEY WERE DOING IN THE
BEST WAY OF PROTECTING THE TAX
DOLLARS AND SO I WANT TO THANK
HIM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS GARCIA. AND
WITH THAT. DEGREE CABALLERO.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY TWO AB TEN
THIRTY SIX CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AN ALKYLATING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE. MR
GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES ARISE
PERCENT MAYBE TEN THIRTY SIX A
BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK. FOR FUTURE STATE
EMERGENCIES AND SUPPORTER
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY. IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT THAT CALIFORNIA
IS NOT EQUIPPED TO MEET ITS
NEEDS FOR SUCH A GOOD SUCH AS
MASS TESTING KITS VENTILATORS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. HELLO ARE
MANUFACTURED HISTORY HAS PROVEN
RESILIENT DURING THIS CRISIS
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
MANUFACTURERS STILL FACE
CHALLENGES. A COMPETING IN A
GLOBAL ECONOMY THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS ACT ADDRESSES
THESE TWO ISSUES BY.
AUTHORIZING THE AYE BANK TO
ESTABLISH THE MANUFACTURING
DISASTER. THE DIFFERENCE I BACK
PRO. SUPPORTING ARE MANY
INDUSTRYWILL BE WILL CATALYZE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC COMEBACK
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. THE CLUB
THERE ALL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE CHARLIE BUT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY
THREE AB TEN FORTY SIX I MISS
RUBIO. THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC RUBIO AN
ACCOLADE TO PRENATAL SERVICES
MISS RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE TEN
FORTY SIX WHAT CAN BEING
STAKEHOLDER PARTICIPATING IN
EVIDENCE BASED MATERNAL INFANT
AND EARLY CHILDHOOD HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS WITH STATE
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY MORE
EFFECTIVE MECHANISMS FOR DRYING
DOWN MEDICAL FUNDING OVER THE
PAST FORTY YEARS MATERNAL
INFANT HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THEIR VALUE
WITH SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES. AND SOME OF
THE MOST COMPLICATED FIRST TIME
PREGNANCIES. ENSURING MEDI CAL
FUNDING IS EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY DRAWN DOWN IN
CRITICAL IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING ALL FAMILIES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE ACCESS. THIS
MEASURE HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BY PARDON SAYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
RUBIO. SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. CARCLUB
RURAL. IT IS ADVERT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLICK WELL
CLOSER ALL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
EIGHT. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASSER CAME ON FILE ITEM.
TWO THIRTY FOUR. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
TO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN THIS IS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
THIS IS FILE ITEM. SIXTEEN AB
TWO FIFTY FIVE. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ
WITH AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO FIFTY FIVE WITH THE MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
THIS RESOLUTION ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU AB TWO
FIVE FIVE IS THREE TWELVE
NINETEEN SMALL BUSINESS VIXEN
RELIEF ACT. BUT WE ARE AMENDING
THE BILL TO TAKE OUT THE
URGENCY CLAUSE. I THINK I WAS
RESEARCHING WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT. IN
BACK ON FILE. IN FINAL ORDER
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
SEMBLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTIVATING ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MISTER COOPER HE MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS A.
B. TEN SEVENTY WILL PERMIT
DISTILLED SPIRITS MANUFACTURERS
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE UP TO
TWELVE OUTDOOR PATIO UMBRELLAS.
TO LOCAL RESTAURANTS
RESTAURANTS AND BARS ARE NOW
JUST STARTING TO COME BACK TO
LIFE NOT A DAUNTING BE CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO THEIR SUCCESSFUL
RECOVERY. THIS BILL SIMPLY HELP
TO GET OUR RESTAURANTS ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES UP ON THEIR
FEET AGAIN AND LEVY A COST FOR
THEM IS THIS THE RECOVERY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS COOPER.
SAY NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
CLICK LIBERAL. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THEM. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
SERVER. WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL
YOU WHAT I SIXTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. IT'S.
THERE IS THIS IS FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY SIX. AB TEN SEVENTY TWO
I MISS REYES CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AND
ACCORDING TO SMALL BUSINESSES
MITHRAS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TEN SEVENTY
TWO WHICH WILL HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES BY EXPANDING GO
BUSINESSES SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM OR TAPE. TAPE OFFER
SMALL BUSINESS SERVICES SUCH AS
FREE OR LOW COST ONE ON ONE
CONSULTING AND LOW COST
TRAINING. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS EASIER BILL. THANK
YOU MISS REYES. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL. YOU DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS WILL DECIDE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS AT
ABOUT. CARDWELL CLOSER ALL THE
TIME BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SEVEN AB
ELEVEN OH FOUR. BY MISTER
GRAYSON CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR AMBULANCE
SERVICES AND DECLARE THE YEARS
EITHER OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. THIS GRAYSON EMAIL
BUT- MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN ZERO FOUR WILL ENSURE
THAT THERE IS CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS IN
THE STATE. EMERGENCY AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SYSTEM. THEY ALSO PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN HOMELAND SECURITY AND
DISASTER RESPONSE INCLUDING BE
EVACUATING THAT INCLUDING
EVACUATING HOSPITALS IN THE
PATH OF WILD FIRES AND
RESPONDING TO COVER NINETEEN
CRISIS. AS WITH OTHER EMERGENCY
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
PLACED AN ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC
STRAIN ON PROVIDERS WITHOUT
IMMEDIATE ACTION FROM THE
LGISLATURE FUNDING FOR AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS WILL EXPIRE
IN TWO MONTHS. AND ANY
REDUCTION OF FUNDING AT THIS
TIME WITHOUT DOUBT OF REPLACE
THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF MANY
EMERGENCY HELICOPTER BASIS. AT
RISK OF CLOSING PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL AREAS AND THOSE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS. WHO HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF MEDIC CAL
UTILIZATION MEMBERS THIS IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO PROVIDE AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICES THE FUNDING
THAT THEY NEED. TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE LIFESAVING SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ONE OF OUR-
FAVORITES GRAYSON MISTER
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. AS A
FATHER WHOSE DAUGHTER IS ALIVE
TODAY BECAUSE OF AN AIR
AMBULANCE HELICOPTER AND LIVING
OUT IN A RURAL AREA WHERE WE DO
NOT HAVE. THE TYPE ONE TRAUMA
CENTER IN EAST CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE HELICOPTER BE ABLE TO
FUNCTION. TO SAVE LIVES I
ABSOLUTELY RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOU TO- GIVE HER AYE VOTE
HIS BILL AND- MY DAUGHTER IS
ALIVE BECAUSE OF THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER AND
MISTER COOLEY IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY PLEASED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. ERROR AMBULANCES ARE
SO IMPORTANT WHEN YOU HAVE THAT
SORT OF CRISIS THAT COMES UPON
YOU. IN NINETEEN NINETY. I WAS
CAMPING AT A PLACE CALLED BAY
LAKE IN THIS YEAR IS DEVELOPED
HEATSTROKE WENT INTO A COMA.
THERE WAS NO HELIPAD AT MAY
LAKE. OF OFF THE TOP OF THE
ROAD IN THIS YEAR'S SO ON TOP
OF JUST THE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES. THEY NEEDED A PILOT
WHO CONSIDERING SELF ON THE
LAKE CREEPERS KIDS ACROSS A
GRANITE OUTCROPPING AND SET THE
THING DOWN- WITHOUT. HITTING A
NEARBY TREES WITH THE ROTORS-
AND I DIDN'T COME OUT OF THAT
COMA FOR SEVERAL DAYS I WENT
FROM. THERE TO YOSEMITE TO
MODESTO ALL AN AFTERNOON- SO
VERY VITAL SERVICE BUT IT'S A
VERY UNIQUE SKILL SET THAT'S-
CONSOLIDATED IN THESE AIR
AMBULANCE PILOTS. DAVIDGE
COOLEY MS GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HILL- MISTER SPEAKER
I DO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THAT I DO UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE TO SAY WE'VE SEEN THIS IS
AN EMERGENCY MEASURE FOR. I
THINK FOUR EIGHT TIMES NOW- AND
WE CONTINUE DESPITE OUR OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW IT IS FUNDED
CONTINUE TO PASS IT THROUGH.
THE TRUTH IS IF YOU GET CAUGHT
JAYWALKING YOU'RE PAYING FOR
AIR AMBULANCES IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL FEE ON TOP OF A
TICKET ANY TICKET THAT YOU GET
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
EXPRESSED OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW THIS IS FUNDED FOR MANY
YEARS. BUT BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE TO FIND
IT THAT WAY I HAVE GOTTEN COULD
I HAVE GOTTEN COMMITMENTS FROM
THE AUTHOR THAT THIS IS IT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND A NEW
FUNDING SOURCE WHICH WE NEED TO
FIND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
SERVICE- AND THOSE OF YOU WHO
KNOW WHO DEAL WITH US IN
APPROPRIATIONS. NO USUALLY WHEN
I SAY IT'S THE LAST YEAR TO
LAST YEAR BUT- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT WE DO WANT TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR A ROLE RESIDENTS
IN THIS IS IMPORTANT BUT WE
NEED TO FIND A NEW FUNDING
SOURCES. IF YOU JAY WALKING NOT
BE PAYING FOUR DOLLARS FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE'S AREA AMBULANCE
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
FUND THESE PROGRAMS WITHOUT
BURDENING. I'M WORKING IN
MIDDLE CASS COMMUNITIES AND SO
I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR IN
COMMITTING THIS YEAR TO BE THE
VERY LAST YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
FIND IT THIS WAY. THANK
RESIDENTS ALL SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISDIRECTION YOU MAKE CLOTHES
IF YOU WISH THANK YOU SO MUCH I
THINK THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE SUPPORT IN
PARTICULAR OF ONE COLLEAGUE
THAT IS ENCOURAGED TO FIND A
PERMANENT FUNDING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND WITH THAT CLERK
LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF
THE- WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLE. TALLY THE
VOTE HI SIXTY SEVEN NO. ZERO I
SIXTY SEVEN OH ZERO THE URGENCY
AND I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE TAKE A MISTER GRAYSON
IS FILE ITEM TO A ONE THAT IS
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE THIS IS
FILE ITEM. TWO OH ONE AB SEVEN
FIVE THREE AND THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
ACCOLADES TO CONTAMINATION. MR
GRACIE MAKE AN OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AGAIN AND
MEMBERS A. B. SEVEN FIFTY THREE
EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUND THAT CREATES A
STAKEHOLDER TASK FORCE THAT
WILL STUDY EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY OF THE FUND TO
REMEDIATING CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES THAT SERVE THE
STATE'S HOUSING PURPOSES. IT'S
THAT IS A PATHWAY TOWARD
REMEDIATING BROWNFIELD SITES
AND JOB AND TRANSIT RICH AREAS
CALIFORNIA HAS A MASSIVE
HOUSING SHORTAGE HOUSING IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN URBAN
AREAS ESPECIALLY NEAR JOBS AND
TRANSIT HOWEVER BILLABLE URBAN
INFILL LAND IS OFTEN PASSED
OVER DUE TO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FROM PREVIOUS
DEVELOPMENT. THESE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES TAKE UP VALUABLE
LAND IN AREAS WHERE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS NEEDED THE MOST
THE UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUND HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
FOR CLEANUP OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES INCLUDING ON BROWNFIELD
PROPERTIES. THANKS TO THE
EFFORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
REDUCE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION THERE ARE FAR
FEWER NEW APPLICANTS TO THE FUN
THAN EVER BEFORE WHICH PRESENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO USE THE
FUNDING TO CLEAN UP PROPERTIES
ON WHICH HOUSING CAN BE BUILT.
AND ULTIMATELY FURTHER ON
HOUSING GOALS I HAVE COMMITTED
TO TAKING AMENDMENTSIN THE
SENATE THAT WILL MOVE THE
OPPOSITION TO NEUTRAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK IMAGE GRAYSON C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS AT ABOUT.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR MEMBERS.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL CALVET
HIGHS FIFTY SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING
TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE I'M
TWO THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS BACK
IN FILE ORDER. FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY NINE IS. AB ELEVEN
THIRTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY ROLE LEVIN
THIRTY WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD DOCTOR
WOULD ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THE
MMS TALE AB ELEVEN THIRTY
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOUNG
DOCTOR WHAT MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR WE WILL HOLD THEM
SCAN SENT ON THIS UNNATURAL
CALL VOTE. ARGUMENTS MISTER
FLORA IS REQUESTING A ROLL CALL
VOTE. ON THE AMENDMENTS MEMBERS
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. IS ANY
AMENDMENTS TO AB ELEVEN THIRTY
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE
MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING. IS
THE THRESHOLD. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSER ROLE. TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN MM
UNSERVED OPTED BILLS OUT TO
PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM. TO FORTY. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO FORTY ONE AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT TIME IS
PETRIE-NORRIS CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
RULE ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND ACCOLADES ALCOHOLISM OR
DRUG ABUSE. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AT ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH IMPROVES
PROTECTIONS FOR PATIENTS
SEEKING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT I AB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT WILL INCREASE STANDARDS
BY ESTABLISHING MINIMUM
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LICENSED DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY
AND TREATMENT FACILITIES AND
RECOVERY RESIDENCES. AB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN IS SPONSORED BY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA AND
HAS ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THAT. I THINK IT IS
PETRIE-NORRIS SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. OR CALL
THE ROLL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OF THE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. BURKE WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEMS TO FORTY TWO AND TWO
FORTY THREE. WITH THE SPECIFIED
TO FORTY FOUR THIS IS PASTOR
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TWO FORTY
FIVE. INTO FORTY SIX WE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM CHIU
FORTY SEVEN THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM. TWO FORTY EIGHT A.
B. TWELVE FORTY SEVEN BY MISTER
CHOW. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. THIS IS SHALL YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWELVE
FORTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
PROSECUTION OF COMPUTER HACKING
TO COMMENCE WITHIN THREE YEARS
OF THE DATE OF DISCOVERY. ALL
WITHIN THREE YEARS AFTER THE
OFFENSE COULD HAVE REASONABLY
THEN DISCOVERED IN RECENT YEARS
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT DATA
BREACHES ARE NOT ALWAYS MADE
KNOWN TO THE VICTIMS IN A
TIMELY MANNER. FOR EXAMPLE. THE
TWO YAHOO DATA BREACHES THAT
OCCURRED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE AND TWO THOUSAND FOUR
AFFECTING MORE THAN ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION USERS. WERE NOT
REVEALED UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS WELL
COMPUTER HACKING COMMENCES FROM
THE DATE OF THE OFFENSE. MAKING
THE VICTIMS WHO DISCOVER A DATA
BREACH YEARS AFTER THE FACT
UNABLE TO SEEK CRIMINAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. AB TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
BY ALLOWING FOR PROSECUTION OF
VIDEO OF THESE THE COMPUTER
HACKING WITHIN THREE YEARS OF
THE DATE OF DISCOVERY RATHER
THAN THE DATE OF THE OFFENSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I THINK
WE SHALL SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK OVER
THE ROLE. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT A VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE I. SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO FORTY NINE IS AB TWELVE
FIFTY. SEPARATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FIFTY BYASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND ACCORDING TO
PUBLIC UTILITIES MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS MANY COMMUNITIES IN
OUR STATE LACK ACCESS TO
DRINKING CLEAN DRINKING WATER
BECAUSE THEY BELONG TO SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE UNABLE
TO MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE WATER
QUALITY. WATER SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION HAS PROVEN TO BE
A SOLUTION TO MAKING SURE THESE
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER UNFORTUNATELY
THE LONGER REVIEW OF A
CONSOLIDATION TAKES THE LONGER
CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT WITH
UNDRINKABLE WATER IN A RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING WATER SYSTEM. AB
TWELVE FIFTY WOULD SET
STATUTORY TIMELINES FOR THE CPC
TO REVIEW WATER SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. I THINK IT WAS
CALDERON SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OVERALL.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS THAT IS
THERE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM TWO
FIFTY FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY ONE
IS AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY MR
BELOW FOR COREY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND OTHERS
AND ACCOLADES ANIMAL HEALTH.
MISTER BLOOM YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THE
CALIFORNIA PET BLOOD BANK
MODERNIZATION ACT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS BOTH THE SHORTAGE OF
ANIMAL BLOOD. FOR VETERINARY
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE AND PHASE
OUT THE OBSOLETE INHUMANE
PRACTICE OF CAPTIVE CLOSE CALL
IN THE CANINE BLOOD BANKS IN
OUR STATE. BY AUTHORIZING THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA LICENSE
VETERINARIANS TO OPERATE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS TO
PRODUCE AND SELL OR TRANSPORT
TRANSFER ANIMAL BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS. THIS BILL REPRESENTS
A THREE YEAR EFFORT TO
MODERNIZE ANIMAL BLOOD BANKING
IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M PROUD TO
BE CO AUTHORING THIS BILL WITH
SENATOR WILK. AND THIS IS AN
AMAZING ALLITERATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MATHIS MAYES AND MULLIN.
SOUNDS LIKE A OFFER OF. OR A
SIXTIES FOLK TRIO. THIS THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I BETTER STOP WE
WILL STOP ON THE HEAD AS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. NESSIE DAMAGE
BLINDNESS MATHIS HERE
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF. THE AUTHORS
WRITE IT THIS BILL IT IS BEEN A
THREE YEAR IN PROGRESS BILL I
TRULY JUST WANT TO VOICE MY
APPRECIATION FOR HIM FOR
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
THIS TO REALLY FIND TO THIS AND
GET THIS RIGHT SO WE CAN ENSURE
THAT ANIMAL BLOOD BANKS-
CONTINUE THAT WE CONTINUE
PROVIDING THE SOURCE BUT ALSO
SET UP THE COMPONENTS TO PHASE
THAT OUT AND MOVE TOWARDS A
VOLUNTARY APPROACH. SO BIG
SHOUT OUT TO THE AUTHOR ON HIS
HARD WORK ON THIS ONE THANK YOU
MEMBERS ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK GOODNESS MATHIS.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
RESERVE A. OFFICIALS. BACKWELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP. I.
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BRIEFLY BACK TO- FILE ITEM
TO EIGHTEEN. THIS YOUR CALL
THIS IS MISTER BENNETT'S AB.
NINE FORTY ONE. THE CLERK FOR
RE. SOME AGO NINE FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND
OTHERS AND ACTIVITIES
FARMWORKERS MISTER BENNETT MAY
BRIEFLY REMIND US ABOUT THE
BILL THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT- AB NINE FORTY ONE
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A GRANT
PROGRAM TO CREATE FARMWORKER
RESOURCE CENTERS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL- I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE- THIS- HAS BEEN
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS BENNET
SEEING NO DISCUSSION. ON THE
ADAM- CORPORAL. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE OF THAT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TO FIFTY
TWO AND TWO FIFTY THREE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY FOUR AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY MR WENT
QUICKLY. SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND ACCOLADES MENTAL
HEALTH. MS HERMAN EMAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE WHICH HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS BILL
WILL ESTABLISH A FULL TIME
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF CRISIS
SERVICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
DEVELOP AN EFFECTIVE CRISIS
CARE CENTER. THAT A SYSTEM THAT
WILL SAVE LIVES AND RESOURCES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
WENT. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM FOR CORPORAL.
ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY NINE
OH ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
FIVE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE IN THE DATA
COLLECTION. MISTER MURATSUCHI.
YOU MAY OPEN. ON THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU I AM PRESENTING AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE NOW
TURN A GENERAL BONTA. THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH EQUITY BILL THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA. TO BE COLLECTED BY
STATE AGENCIES AND SHARED USING
A STANDARDIZED AND DISENGAGE
THE DATA BASED ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY. WE SAW DURING THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC THAT
THEIR TREMENDOUS DISPARITIES
NOT ONLY ALONG RACIAL LINES BUT
ALSO A WITHIN ETHNIC GROUPS.
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES WERE A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF THIS WITH. THE COVER
NINETEEN RATES BEING
PARTICULARLY UP THE HIGHEST
AMONG GROUPS LIKE THE NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
VIETNAMESE FILIPINOS AND OTHERS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CARCLUB
OTHER ALL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS
THAT A VOTE OF MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF. WELL. CLOSE
ROLE TIED UP I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TO FIFTY
SIX AND TWO FIFTY SEVEN. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM. TWO FIFTY EIGHT.
PASS AND RETAIN ABOUT. ONE TWO
FIFTY NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY. AB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
BY MS CERVANTES. KERKORIAN
AMIGO FOURTEEN FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACCORDING TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
MR BY TESS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FORTY FORTY
ONE WILL REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO LOCALS
WHO ARE CREATING EMERGENCY
EVACUATION PLANS FOR THE
TREATMENT AND TRANSPORTATION OF
CRITICALLY ILL NEWBORN INFANTS
DURING DISASTERS WERE EXTREMELY
FRAGILE AND TECHNOLOGY
DEPENDENT DURING EMERGENCY
DISASTER THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS A LOCAL AND REGIONAL
UNIQUE VULNERABILITIES OF
CHILDREN THEIR SPECIAL NEEDS
SHOULD BE ADDRESS AND EMERGENCY
PLANNING TO ENSURE THAT
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES AND FAMILIES
ARE PREPARED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IBM. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTIN'S SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CABALLERO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS SAID OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRABLE.
WELL HOUSE ROLE. TELL YOU TO
VOTE. I SIXTY NINE KNOWS BRO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY ONE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWO SIXTY TWO.
MEMBERS. IT'S GETTING LATE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO SIXTY TWO
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER- DONG
ACCOLADES AIR POLLUTION MISTER
DONNELLY YOU MAY OPEN MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. RESOURCES
BOARDS PROJECT EIGHT HUNDRED
INITIATIVE TO SUPPORT THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ONE THOUSAND TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED ZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE TRUCKS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS PROVIDING
FUNDING TO OFFSET THE COST OF
PURCHASING ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
WILL BE CRITICAL TO
ACCELERATING THE STATE'S
TRANSITION TO CLEAN GOODS
MOVEMENT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK MISPRONOUNCING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. OR CALL
THE ROLL CALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO
BACK TO FILE ITEM TO SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER DALY THIS IS AB FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE CORKERY. SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AN
ACCOLADE AND TRANSPORTATION MR
DALY THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WAS ASKED TO BRING
THE BILL UP THIS EVENING- IT
MAY NOT APPEAR ON YOUR FILE.
BUT IT'S AN INNOCENT SIMPLE
BILL TRUST ME. IT EXTENDS THE
AUTHORIZATION FOR CALTRANS AND
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO UTILIZE THE DESIGN
BUILD PROCUREMENT METHOD. FOR
STATE FUNDED TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THE PROCESS ALLOWS
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO
STREAMLINE THE RESOURCES
RESULTING IN TIME SAVINGS AND
COST SAVINGS. AGAIN THIS
AUTHORIZES THE DESIGN BUILD
APPROACH. FOR TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. I FOR
ONE TRUSTEE MR DAILY. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLICK OVER
THE ROLE MEMBERS OF. HE SAID
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF
THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSER TYLER SEVENTY
KNOWS. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO SIX THREE
IN FILE OR TWO SIXTY THREE A.
B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AND ALKYLATING TO
COURTS MR STONE EMAIL THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE BILL ASKS THE COURTS
WHO AS EMPLOYERS HAVE.
LACTATION ROOMS FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND THAT'S THE COURTS
TO ALLOW ATTORNEYS WHO WERE IN
COURT QUITE OFTEN TO BE ABLE TO
USE THOSE LACTATION ROOMS
ATTORNEYS ARE NOT EMPLOYEES OF
THE COURTS BUT OUR OFFICES THE
COURTS TO THIS IS A VERY
APPROPRIATE THING TO ASK THE
COURTS TO DO AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THE COMMISSION ON
SCENE DISCUSS OR DEBATE. CLICK
OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
I AM PREPARED
TO LIVE THE CALL. ONLINE MS
RACES MEASURE THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY FOUR EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO
VOTE. AT. EIGHT ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SERVER.
THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE. CHIDE ABOUT IS
FORTY EIGHT NOSED TWO THE
MEASURE NAY FIFTY FOUR VOTES ON
THE VERGE. THAT MEASURE FAILS.
AND MISS RADIUS NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION. MEMBERS N.
FILE ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY FOUR AB THREE SIXTY
THREE. BY MISTER MEDINA COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AN
ACT RELATING TO VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION MR MEDINA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THREE SIXTY
THREE MODERN BAEZ'S AND
STREAMLINES THE VOUCHER
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WITH CALLED
LAWYER TO GET MORE CLEAN
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS REDUCE SAME
NOTICE. OF LOCAL THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE- BUT INSTEAD OF.
BURKE WELL CLOSE ZERO CHILDHOOD
EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS WHY THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS A RICH ABOUT ITEMS TO SIX
THREE TO SAY. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TO ONE A SEVENTY THREE BY
MISTER LOW. THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME BILL SEVEN TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY LOW ACCOLADE TO
HEALING. MISTER LOW THANK YOU
VERY MISS SPEAKER ASPECTS ASK
DR. YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. C.
OF A LOCAL THE ROLE THIS. IS A
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ABOUT.
ALL MY VOTE. RESERVE. AND.
BURKE WELL CLOSE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO FIFTY EIGHT AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO BY MR
GABRIEL CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE HEALTH
FACILITIES. MR GABRIEL YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M PLEASED TODAY PERCENT AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD
IMPROVE AND INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. AND BAD
DESIGNATION PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY
PROCESS IN ORDER TO INCREASE
PATIENT SAFETY AND STANDARDS OF
CARE. OFFICES WORK CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
TRY TO THE BILL EVERYONE CAN
GET BEHIND. SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS THANKFUL AND
RESPECT THE QUESTION ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR GABER. ST
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON ITEM.
CLICK OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT. WE RESERVE A
MEMBERS VOTE OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS. IT IS OUT OF A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP. HIGHS
FIFTY NO SEVENTEEN. THAT MAY
PASSES AND WE ARE GOING TO BACK
IN THE PICK UP MISTER HOLDEN
FILE I ONE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE TO THIS IS FILE A ONE
EIGHTY THREE. AB TWELVE.
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE BY
SOME MEMBER HOLD AND ARE TO FOR
MISTER HALL. THANK YOU MISSUS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWO IS A
BILL THEY WILL GIVE TO CITY IN
MY DO. TO PURSUE PROBLEMS BUT
OF CAN OF HOW IN THE END OF. AS
A LANDLORD SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL WILL ALLOW OF PRIVATE H.
USED PURCHASE LAND ALL BIKE.
FOR THE ORIGINAL PER PRICE ONLY
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF HOMES AND
ACRES OF LAND THAT ARE OWNED BY
CALTRANS AND THE SEVEN TEN
NORTH CORRIDOR. WHEN CALTRANS
PURCHASED THE LAND IN REAL
ESTATE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
OR NINETEEN SIXTIES PRICES THEY
PLAN TO BUILD A FREEWAY THROUGH
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
FULL OF AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
ASIAN OWN HOMES. AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. NOW THAT THE
FREEWAY IS NOT GOING TO BE
BUILT THIS TIME TO ALLOW THESE
COMMUNITIES TO PUT THEMSELVES
BACK TOGETHER. THIS BILL MAKES
IT EASIER FOR CITIES A
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS TO DO THAT
BY PURCHASING UNIMPROVED VACANT
LAND. FOR THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE
PRICE THE REVERDY ACT CREATED A
PROCESS TO SELL THESE HOMES IN
A WAY THAT IS FAIR AND
AFFORDABLE. HOWEVER IT HAS
CREATED A BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS
THAT IS DIFFICULT FOR CITIES
AND RESIDENTS TO NAVIGATE.
REFORMS ARE NEEDED. RECENT
AMENDMENTS DO NOT REQUIRE
SKILLED LABOR BUT ONLY
ENCOURAGES IT FOR PROJECTS AND
IS NOT SPECIFIC TO THE PROJECTS
IN THIS BILL. THE BILL HAS
SUPPORT FOR A NUMBER OF A
NUMBER OF GROUPS OF MY
DISTRICT. THAT ARE WORKING FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I NEED YOUR SUPPORT OF
RETURNING THE COMMUNITY BACK TO
THE LOCALS. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS OF.
ZACKS A VOTE ON MEMBERS OUT OF
A. ALL ROADSIDE OF. PARKWAY.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU I SIXTY
FIVE ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ANNOUNCEMENTS. BEFORE
WE LEFT THE QUORUM CALL FOR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY SESSION
WILL START AT TEN AM TOMORROW
SESSION WILL START AT TEN AM
TOMORROW. WARM CALL STILL PLAY
MEMBER FORM CALLED PLAY. MS.
MS
RANGE YOU'RE RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM TWENTY TWO I'M SORRY
I DIDN'T TWO SIX SIX AB NINE
SEVEN FIVE THREE OF US TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED. AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WHERE ARE THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE FOOD WHILE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT OUR I RISE TODAY
TO GERMAN IN MEMORY OF OFFICER
JIMMY AND- WHAT DO WAS A SIX
YEAR VETERAN. OF THE STOCKTON
POLICE DEPARTMENT. JIMMY WAS A
SON A FATHER AND A OUTSTANDING
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY. WE CAN
ALL BE PROUD OF JIMMY WAS KNOWN
FOR HIS WILLINGNESS TO HELP
OTHERS. HE WAS ALSO KNOWN FOR
LOVE FOR LOVING AND CARING FOR
HIS FAMILY AND SERVING HIS
COMMUNITY AND- WE- WHO WARNED
HIM ARE GRATEFUL FOR HIS
SERVICE AND HE'S DEEPLY SADNESS
BY HIS LOSS. LEAVES A LEGACY OF
COMPASSION FAIRNESS AND AN
IDEAL FOR THOSE WHO KNEW HIM TO
CONTINUE CONTINUE TO ASPIRE.
YOU KNOW I DIDN'T KNOW OUR
SYRIAN AND- BUT I ATTENDED THE
FUNERAL. AND IF I TELL YOU
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL. VIBER SAYING. NO IT
WAS A SAD THAT THAT NOT ONE
OFFICER DID NOT HAVE A TWO YEAR
THAT'S NOT BAD THERE WAS THE
FACT THAT. HIS BEST FRIENDS
CAME IN. NOT JUST OFFICERS BUT
THE BOOKS I GOT UP AND SPOKE TO
HIM ABOUT HIM YEAH THEY THEY
CALLED IN THE BIGGEST ASIAN
AEROSOL RIGHT I MEAN HE WAS
HUGE RIGHT BUT HE WAS USED TO.
PROMISE HEART- THE RESEARCHERS
WERE TALKING ABOUT IN LIGHT.
YOU KNOW HE HE HE WOULD WALK IN
THE ROOM WHEN AND IF AN OFFICER
WAS DOWN OR SAD OR- OR HAD A
TOUGH DAY HE KNEW HOW TO BRING
A SMILE HE KNEW HOW TO.
ENCOURAGE GERMAN AND- MAKE HIM
LAUGH AND- YEAH I JUST I SPY
GOT TO I WOULD I WAS SO PROUD.
THAT I WENT NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT
I DO BUT JUST THE FACT THAT OF
WHAT HE DID WHAT HE DID FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST I REQUEST EVERYONE HERE
TODAY TO JOIN ME. IN A MOMENT
OF SILENCE FOR OFFICER JIMMY
JIMMY AND. MEMBERS PLEASE RISE
FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
AMERISUR JIMMY AND REST IN
PEACE. THANK YOU MAY BE ABLE
TO- THANK YOU MEMBERS. MS NO
WAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE JOIN IN
MEMORY OF RALPH ALLEN FROM
SANTANA. RALPH ALLEN WAS BORN
ON OCTOBER TWENTIETH NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO ON A RURAL FARM IN
NEBRASKA DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION. HE ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF NEBRASKA HE
STUDIED ARCHITECTURE AND MET
HIS WIFE JOYCE. WE'RE TAKING A
BREAK FROM A STEADY. MISTER
RALPH. SERVICE COUNTRY AS A
NAVY PILOT DURING THE KOREAN
WAR. UPON HIS STUDY RALPH
ENJOYS HEADED WEST TO BEGIN
THEIR NEW LIVES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE HE WAS
STATIONED DURING HIS TIME IN
THE NAVY. THROUGH HIS FIRM
RALPH ALLEN AND PARTNERS.
RAFIKI NATIONALLY RECOGNITION
FOR HIS USE OF CONCRETE AND IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY CONSCIOUS
DESIGNS OVER THE YEARS ALLEN'S
FIRM WAS AWARDED NUMEROUS
HONORS AND PRIZES A HIGH POINT
HIS CAREER RALPH ALLEN A
PARTNER WAS NAMED THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTURES
CALIFORNIA FIRM OF THE YEAR IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE HE
RECEIVED HIS A. I. A FELLOWSHIP
IN DESIGN IN NOTEWORTHY
ACHIEVEMENT THAT ONLY 1% OF THE
WORDS ARCHITECTURES CAN CLAIM.
ALSO HIS CAREER. ROB WAS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE SANTA ANA KIWANIS CLUB IN
THE LOCAL BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB.
I PERSONALLY DON'T REMEMBER
TIMES WHEN I WAS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT HE WASN'T THERE.
ALWAYS BEING. A SPONSOR A
VOLUNTEER HE ENJOYS LOVE THE
CITY OF SANTA ANA. HE WAS ALSO
A CLASSIC CAR ENTHUSIASTS IN
HIS CARS WOULD OFTEN BE SEEN IN
LOCAL PARADES NOT ONLY JUST FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS. BUT FOR
CHILDREN AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AS WELL. RALPH ALLEN WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS A DEDICATED
FAMILY MAN A GREAT FRIEND. IN
NEIGHBOR AND SOMEONE WHO LOVES
HIS COMMUNITY ALCHEMY WILL BE
DEARLY MISSED AND WE SEND OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS TO HIS
FAMILY I ASK THAT WE TURNED IN
HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISSED WHEN. ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY. JUNE THE SECOND FOR
SESSION AT TEN AM TEN AM
TOMORROW THURSDAY JUNE THIRD
FLOOR SESSION. ALSO AT TEN AM
ALL OF THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED. SINGER FOR THE
BUSINESS AYE READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MS
PETRIE-NORRIS MOVES AND MR
SANTIAGO SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED. UNTIL
WEDNESDAY JUNE THE SECOND. AT
TEN AM WE ARE RETURNED.
OKAY.
RANDY VOEPEL. AB EIGHT NINE
EIGHTY NINE NO TWO HI. VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
ASSEMBLY DOLE NINE EIGHTY NINE
NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
RIGHT VOTE CHANGE
PETRIE-NORRIS AB FORTY FIVE YES
NOT VOTING. FROM CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
ASSEMBLY GO FORTY FIVE I DO NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGE
PETRIE-NORRIS AB SIX ONE FOUR I
TO THIRTY. FOLK CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BETWEEN ASSEMBLY RULES
FORTY I DO NOT VOTING.
THREE
BUT. VOTE CHANGE FILE TWO SIXTY
FOUR AB THREE SIXTY THREE CHIU
CHANGING VOTE FROM I TO NOT
VOTING. BOTH CHANGE SOME MEMBER
CHIU ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
FOUR I TO NOT VOTING.
CORRECTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY THREE
ARCH NOT VOTING.
WHERE THIRTY.
FILE ITEM TWO SIX FOUR A. B.
THREE SIX THREE. I TO NOW.
BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTY THREE- TO THE.